GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME TO
OUR ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE FOR TODAY'S HEARING IS
TAKING PLACE IN ROOM FOUR FOUR
FOUR. WE WILL BE ACCEPTING
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END OF
THIS HEARING BOTH IN THE HEARING
ROOM AND ON THE PHONE. THE PHONE
NUMBER TO CONNECT ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND SHOULD BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN IF YOU
ARE WATCHING. THIS HEARING
ONLINE THE PHONENUMBER IS TOLL
FREE. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE
TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. THE
PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR FOUR IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE
CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX. THREE
ONE NINE TWO ZERO NINE NINE AND
THE STAFF MEMBER WILL ASSIST
YOU. WE ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO
PROVIDE WRITTEN TESTIMONY BEFORE
THE HEARING PLEASE SEND YOUR
WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO BUDGET SUB
FOR. AT ASM DOT CA DOT GOP
WITHOUT ROLL CALL PLEASE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KOREA ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COOPER YEAH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LACKEY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NECESSARY AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WICKS HERE.
TODAY WE WILL HEAR THE
ADMINISTRATION'S MAY REVISED
PROPOSALS AS WE NAVIGATE THIS
HISTORIC BUDGET OUR SUBCOMMITTEE
HAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO DELIVER ON
CRITICAL PROJECTS AND SERVICES
IMPORTANT TO ALL CALIFORNIANS
THIS YEAR IN OUR SUB COMMITTEE
WITH CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS BECAUSE
WE HAVE THE SHARED GOAL TO
ENSURE THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS.
OUR HOUSE HOUSING AS WE'VE
STATED IS IN FACT A HUMAN RIGHT
OUR HEARINGS HIGHLIGHTED THE
NEED TO BUILD MORE HOUSING UNITS
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE OPTIONS WITH
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES TO MOVE
ON HEALTH INDIVIDUALS OFF THE
STREET AND ONTO A PATHWAY TOWARD
STABLE HOUSING ARE HEARINGS ALSO
HIGHLIGHTED THE NEED TO EXPAND
PROVEN PROGRAMS THAT PROVIDE
RELIABLE OPTIONS FOR FIRST TIME
HOME BUYERS. AS WE EVALUATE THE
MAY REVISE HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS PROPOSALS WE SHOULD
KEEP THOSE PRIORITIES IN MIND WE
ALSO DEDICATED TIME TO HELPING
SMALL BUSINESSES SURVIVE THE
PANDEMIC AND CREATE STRONG
COVERT RECOVERY EFFORTS TO BOOST
OUR ECONOMY AND HELP COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AS WE LOOK FORWARD WE NEED TO
DETERMINE WHAT TOOLS ARE SMALL
BUSINESSES NEED TO NAVIGATE THE
CURRENT NVIRONMENT AND TO BE
SUCCESSFUL WE SHOULD HAVE
ALLEYWAY PROGRAMS WHETHER THEY
WERE DESIGN AMID THE PANDEMIC
AND IF SO ARE THOSE PROGRAMS
STILL VIABLE TODAY AND ARE THEY
THE PROGRAMS THAT SMALL
BUSINESSES NEED. AMONGST MANY
PRIORITIES AND STUFF FOR EDT
CONTINUES TO BE A TOPIC OF
DISCUSSION ON HOW WE CAN IMPROVE
THE SAFETY NET SYSTEM DESIGNED
TO HELP CALIFORNIANS IN NEED ON
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS RELATED TO
INSURANCE ENSURING ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO THE
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS AND
OPPORTUNITIES THAT CAN ENSURE
GOOD JOBS AND UPWARD MOBILITY.
THIS INCLUDES ADULT STUDENTS
SEEKING A SECOND OR THIRD CAREER
AS WELL AS GRADUATING HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS WE'VE HAD JOIN
HEARINGS ON THE NEED FOR HEALTH
CARE WORKERS AND I'M GLAD TO SEE
THAT IT'S ALSO A PRIORITY TO THE
GOVERNOR. I'M GRATEFUL THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE INCLUDES
HEROES TO PAY FOR ALL HEALTHCARE
WORKERS THIS IS A STEP IN THE
RIGHT TO ACTION. AND A POLICY
DISCUSSION THAT I'M PROUD TO
HAVE LED WITH THE SUPPORT OF MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE ASSEMBLY. AND
SPEAKER RENDON. I LOOK FORWARD
TO CONVERSATIONS THAT WILL
ENSURE ALL HEALTH CARE WORKERS
ARE INCLUDED IN THE PROPOSAL
FROM HOSPITAL WORKERS TO THOSE
IN COMMUNITY CLINICS AND
SPECIALTYCARE. LASTLY I WOULD
BE REMISS IF I DIDN'T SAY THAT
IN ADDITION TO HEALTHCARE
WORKERS THAT WOULD BE IMPORTANT
FOR US TO RECOGNIZE. ALL HEROES
AMID THE PANDEMIC. THAT WE HAVE
CALLED ESSENTIAL FROM
FARMWORKERS GROCERY STORE
WORKERS SANITATION WORKERS AND
SO ON. BASICALLY THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT KEPT OUR
SOCIETY OUR SOCIETY MOVING.
WHILE MANY OF S WERE ABLE TO
STAY HOME SAFE AND QUARANTINED
WE CANNOT FORGET THAT THE LAST
TWO YEARS. HAVE BROUGHT
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT TO FAMILIES
AND COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. SOME OF WHICH
HAVE LOST THEIR LIVES DUE TO THE
PANDEMIC. BEFORE WE HEAR FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION I WANT TO
GIVE MY COLLEAGUES AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE COMMENTS.
ON THEIR BUDGET PRIORITIES WITH
REGARDS TO ISSUES UNDER THEIR-
JURISDICTIONS AND WHAT'S
IMPORTANT TO THEM. ANYONE ON THE
COMMITTEE I MISS WICKS PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP IN THIS.
BUDGET COMMITTEE- APPRECIATE
FOLKS COMING IN TODAY- YOU KNOW
I APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
COMMITMENT HOUSING HOMELESSNESS
AND HE'S OBVIOUSLY DONE A LOT
MORE- THAN PREVIOUS GOVERNORS-
BUT I ALSO WANT TO SEE A LOT
MORE MONEY IN THE BUDGET FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. IN MANY OF
MY COLLEAGUES AND I WENT ON THAT
STATE WOULD HOUSING FOR THE
FALL. WE WENT TO EVERYWHERE FROM
CHICO TO INLAND EMPIRE TO FRESNO
LA. AND EVERY SINGLE STOP. IT
WAS RAISED WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
MONEY FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING- WE
HEARD IT FROM EVERY COMMUNITY
LARGE AND SMALL- AND SO IT'S AN
OBVIOUS ISSUE OBVIOUSLY SINCE
WE'VE GOTTEN RID OF
REDEVELOPMENT THAT'S- THAT A
CHALLENGE FOR A LOT OF OUR LOCAL
MUNICIPALITIES- AND I KNOW THAT
OUR STATE'S FLAGSHIP AFFORDABLE
pGONNA RUN OUT OF FUNDS- AND I
KNOW IT I THINK THERE'S JUST A
REMAINING- TURNED FIFTY MILLION
. WHICH WILL BE AWARDED NEXT
YEAR- SO I KNOW THE STATE'S OWN
AND ARE THOSE ARE THE
MINISTRATIONS OWN STATE WHAT
HOUSING PLAN CALLS FOR AN
ADDITIONAL ONE POINT TWO MILLION
NEW UNITS OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FOR. LOWER INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
I'M SO I THINK WE'RE NEEDS TO
SEE SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE M. H.
P. PROGRAM IN PARTICULAR IN THE
ACCELERATOR FUND WHICH WAS
CREATED LAST YEAR TO
CONSTRUCTION OF THIS. SO I JUST
WANT TO YOU KNOW. AS ONE
LEGISLATOR WHO ALSO WAS TO BE
THE HOUSING CHAIR- CALL FOR MORE
FUNDING FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
SO I THINK IT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE LL KNOW WE NEED TO DO- YOU
KNOW THEY SAY YOU ARE. BUDGET
REFLECTS OUR VALUES AND I THINK
FOR MANY AT LEAST IN MY DISTRICT
AND I KNOW MANY FOLKS IN
CALIFORNIA OUR VALUES ARE. THAT
WE VIEW IT AS A MORAL IMPERATIVE
TO ENSURE WE DON'T HAVE PEOPLE
SLEEPING ON OUR STREETS- IN ALL
OF OUR COMMUNITIES- URBAN
SUBURBAN AND RURAL ARE FACING
THIS CRISIS RIGHT NOW- AND SO
THIS CRISIS I THINK WARRANT
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES.
SIGNIFICANT ONGOING RESOURCES
WHICH WILL BE A CONTINUED COMP A
CONVERSATION I KNOW IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND I KNOW THAT AGAIN
HÌNH I KNOW THE GOVERNOR SAID A
LOT IN THE SPACE BUT- I WOULD
ASK FOR FORMER. MORE RESOURCES
BECAUSE WE HAVE A GROWING. AND
CATCHMENTS AND UNDERNEATH OUR-
HIGHWAY OVERPASSES WE HAVE.
CONSTITUENTS WERE LIVING IN
THEIR CARS WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO
ARE BARELY HANGING ON TO AFFORD
RENT WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE
LOSING THEIR HOMES- IT'S SIMPLY
NOT OK. SO I JUST WANT TO BE ON
THE RECORD AS A FIERCE ADVOCATE
AND FIGHTING FOR MORE FUNDING
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING- AND I
KNOW THAT THOSE VALUES ARE ALSO
THE GOVERNOR'S VALUES AND I
APPRECIATE THAT BUT WITH THAT
JUST PREACHING THE CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU MISS WICKS AND
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTNERSHIP AND-
THE WORK THAT YOU DO AND THE
LEADERSHIP THAT AND I'M HOW YOU
READ AND HOUSING COMMITTEE. TO
ENSURE THAT WE USE OUR OUR
BUDGET APPROPRIATELY AND ENSURE
THAT. WE'RE MOVING FORWARD AS A
SOCIETY. TO COOPER GOOD ALRIGHT
LET'S BEGIN THEN. WEWILL BEGIN
ON THE VOTE ON THE CALENDAR WE
HAVE FOUR ITEMS FOR
CONSIDERATION I SPLIT INTO TWO
MOTIONS THE FIRST MOTION IS A
VOTE ON THE ON ISSUES ONE TWO
AND THREE. CHAIR RECOMMENDS
ADOPTING ADAPTING THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS CAN I GET A
MOTIONS. GREAT THANK YOU ROCK UP
PLEASE. AREA HI I COOPER COOPER
HI BLACKIE. IS AREA WICKS WEEKS
I. THE SECOND MOTION IS A VOTE
ONLY ON ISSUE FOR THE CHAIR
RECOMMENDS ADOPTING THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS CAN I GET A
MOTION. THANK YOU ROLL CALL
PLEASE. AREA FIVE THREE AYE
COOPER. COOPER AYE BLACKIE. IS
THERE ANY. WICKS HI WE EXPECT.
OKAY YEAH.
LIKE YOU WOULD LIKE TO ADD ON TO
THE VOTING CALENDARS YEAH SURE
OKAY THANK. MOTIONS TO ADOPT THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION FOR VOTE
ONLY ISSUES ONE TWO AND THREE
WACKY I LIKE THE ACT. SECOND
MOTION IS TO ADOPT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS PROVIDE ONLY
ISSUE. FOR BLACKIE NO LIKE IN.
MEASURE ONE FOUR YES THIS IS A
QUICK CALL MEANT ON THE-
ADULTHOOD. IT WAS MENTIONED YOU
KNOW WORKING ADULTS NEED JOBS
THEY NEED THAT THEY NEED THE
EDUCATION SO I THINK THIS SO
IMPORTANT AND FOLKS ARE TRYING
TO BETTER THEMSELVES GO BACK SO
I SUPPORT THAT WHOLEHEARTEDLY.
THANK YOU FOR THAT MISTER COOPER
. FOR THIS HEARING THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WILL BEGIN
BY PROVIDING AN OVERVIEW OF THE
MAY REVISION PROPOSALS UNDER SUB
FORCE RESTRICTIONS THE
CORRESPONDING MAYBE VISION
LETTERS ARE AVAILABLE ON OUR SUB
COMMITTEE WEBSITE WE WILL THEN
TRANSITION TO THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE ANALYSIS
FOLLOWED BY MEMBER QUESTIONS.
BUT OUR MOST IMPORTANT TASK AT
HAND TODAY IS TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC TO VOICE OUR POSITIONS ON
THE MAY REVISION TO FURTHER
ENGAGE IN THE BUDGET PROCESS I
WANT TO KNOW THAT SOME
DEPARTMENT REPRESENTATIVES MAYBE
TESTIFYING AT OTHER MAY REVISION
HEARINGS AS WE SPEAK BUT WE KNOW
SET FORTH ABSOLUTE MOST PART
ONE. BUT EFFORTS HAVE BEEN MADE
TO ENSURE ADEQUATE COVERAGE FOR
THIS IMPORTANT HEARING IF A
MEMBER QUESTION CANNOT BE
ANSWERED TODAY STAFF WILL
IMMEDIATELY FOLLOW UP AFTER THE
HEARING TO OBTAIN RESPONSES THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WILL NOW
PRESENT THEIR MAY REVISION
PROPOSALS. ARE FOLLOWING THE L.
L. WILL PRESENT. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CRIMINAL THAT LOOK MAKE SURE
YOUR MIKE IS ON. OKAY OKAY THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE CHRIS
COOK WITH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
AS NOTED WE'VE BEEN ASKED BY THE
COMMITTEE TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW
OF ASSEMBLY SUB FOR MAY REVISION
LETTERS FROM FINANCE- AS
IDENTIFIED IN YOUR AGENDA- IF
IT'S OKAY WITH THE CHAIR WE
COULD JUST RUN THROUGH ALL OF
THEM AT ONCE AND TAKE COMING
AFTER GREAT. OKAY SO BEGINNING
WITH THAT BIT BUSINESS CONSUMER
SERVICES IN HOUSING AGENCY- ARE
MOST NOTABLE ISSUES INCLUDING-
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS. TWENTY FOUR MILLION ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND OVER THREE
YEARS TO STABILIZE THE BUREAU.
FOR PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY
EDUCATION FUNDING WHILE AN-
IMPROVED- LICENSING FEE MODELS
DEVELOPED FORCES LICENSES. UNDER
THE DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS
CONTROL TWENTY POINT FIVE
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
FOR CANNABIS LOCAL JURISDICTION
RETAIL ACCESS GRANT PROGRAM TO
ASSIST LOCAL JURISDICTIONS. IN
THE DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF LOCAL RETAIL-
LICENSING PROGRAM. AND STATUTORY
CHANGES TO REFORM CANNABIS TAXES
TO HELP STABILIZE THE CANNABIS
RETAIL MARKET MOST. MAJOR
CHANGES INCLUDE SETTING THE
CULTIVATION TAX RATE AT ZERO
BEGINNING JULY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
SHIFTING THE POINT OF COLLECTION
AND REMITTANCE FOR. EXCISE TAX-
FROM DISTRIBUTION TO RETAIL ON
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND
MAINTAINING A 15% EXCISE TAX
RATE AMONG OTHERS. FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING- THE MAYOR VISION
INCLUDES RESOURCE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT TO CREATE A COMMUNITY
CONFLICT RESOLUTION AND
CONCILIATION TEAM TO IDENTIFY
AND PROVIDE CONCILIATION
SERVICES TO COMMUNITIES AFFECTED
BY HATE INCIDENTS OR OTHER
DISCRIMINATION. ADMIN RESOURCES
FOR THE COMMISSION ON THE STATE
I HATE AS ESTABLISHED BY AB
ELEVEN TWENTY SIX AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. AND STATUTORY A
PROPOSED THAT STORY CHANGES
RENAMING THE DEPARTMENT TO THE
CALIFORNIA CIVIL RIGHTS
DEPARTMENT TO BETTER REFLECT THE
DEPARTMENT'S EXISTING ROLE AND
RESPONSIBILITIES. FINALLY WE
HAVE THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. WHERE
THERE'S TWO POINT SEVEN BILLION-
APPROPRIATED IN THE CURRENT YEAR. AS AUTHORIZED BY SB ONE
FIFTEEN FOR ELIGIBLE STATE AND
LOCAL EMERGENCY RENTAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM APPLICATIONS
RECEIVED BY MARCH THIRTY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THERE'S N
ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
OVER TWO YEARS FOR THE ADAPTIVE
REUSE PROGRAM TO CONVERT
EXISTING- EIGHT INFRASTRUCTURE
UNDER UTILIZE RETAIL. AND
COMMERCIAL BUILDINGS INTO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION OVER TWO YEARS TO HOUSE
UNSHELTERED INDIVIDUALS ON STATE
OWNED LAND THROUGH GRANTS TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FOR INTERIM
HOUSING AND SITE PREPARATION.
AND FINALLY A HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION IN THE CURRENT YEAR FOR
ADDITIONAL HOME KEY GRANTS.
MOVING ON TO GENERAL- THE
GOVERNMENT OPS AGENCY. MOST
NOTABLE- ADJUSTMENTS INCLUDE SIX
HUNDRED MILLION AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY SIX ARE
MILLION GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
TWO OR EXCUSE ME TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR. AND FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE TO SUPPORT THE
COMPLETION OF THE MIDDLE MILE
BROADBAND INITIATIVE. FIFTY FIVE
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND AN
ONGOING RESOURCES FOR FOUR
POSITIONS TO SUPPORT SHORT TERM
IT PROJECTS THROUGH- PROVED TO
BUY TECHNOLOGY MODERNIZATION
FUNDING OR RECOMMENDED BY C. T.
STABILIZATION SERVICES
ASSESSMENT TEAM. AND FINALLY AT
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
ADMINISTRATIVE RESOURCES- FOR
THE FOR THE BOARD TO IMPLEMENT
THE YOUNG CHILD AND FOSTER YOU
TAX CREDITS. AND THE PAYMENT
FLEXIBILITY PROGRAM. AND
RESOURCES TO ADMINISTER THEIR
CAL EITC FOR CALIFORNIA EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT OUT REACH AN
ONGOING FUNDING. FOR THAT CAL
EITC OUTREACH GRANTS AND VITA
TAX PREPARATION. FOR THE LABOR
WORK FORCE AND DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY THERE IS A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SIX MILLION- ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR THE INITIAL PLANNING
AND IMPLEMENTATION FOR EVD NEXT
A FIVE YEAR MODERNIZATION
INITIATIVE FOR EDIE'S
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
DISABILITY INSURANCE AND PAID
FAMILY LEAVE PROGRAMS. FORTY
FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION OVER
THREE YEARS TO SUPPORT EDT FRAUD
INVESTIGATIONS- AND PROSECUTION
EFFORTS. AND A REDUCTION OF ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN POINT
SEVEN MILLION TO REFLECT UPDATED
ESTIMATES FOR THE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE LOAN INTEREST OWED TO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. FOR THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD SEVENTEEN MILLION OVER TWO
YEARS TO EXPAND HIERO TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS AND INDUSTRY
SECTORS THAT SUPPORT THE STATE'S
RESPONSE TO EXTREME HEAT. THIS
PROPOSAL WAS PART OF A LARGER
EXTREMELY PACKAGE THAT WAS
DISCUSSED IN DETAIL AND ASSEMBLY
SUBTREE LAST WEEK. FOR NOW AND
FOR THE DEPARTMENT INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS SIMILARLY TWENTY FOUR
POINT FIVE MILLION OVER TWO
YEARS TO PROTECT VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS THROUGH TARGETED
OUTREACH EDUCATION AND STRATEGIC
ENFORCEMENT. BEFORE AND DURING
HEAT EVENTS TO PROTECT WORKERS
FROM HEAT RELATED ILLNESSES
PRESENT NOTED FROM THE PREVIOUS
ISSUE THIS WAS DISCUSSED AND
ASSEMBLY SUBTREE. PREVIOUSLY AND
FINALLY A SHIFT FROM THE
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARDS-
JANUARY PROPOSAL- FOR THE HEALTH
CARE ACCESS. GOING AND SHIFTING
THAT TOWARDS- THE PROPOSED TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION FOR THE
APPRENTICESHIP INNOVATION
FUNDING PROGRAM WHICH WILL
PROVIDE FUNDING TO SCALE
INNOVATIVE APPRENTICESHIPS.
RENDON SHIPS- PROGRAMS EXPANDING
EXISTING NONTRADITIONAL
APPRENTICESHIPS. GOOD AFTERNOON-
MARC BERMAN OF THE PERMIT OF
FINANCE FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT THE MAY REVISION
INCLUDES FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND TO THE
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF THE SMALL
BUSINESS ADVOCATE TO PROVIDE
RELIEF GRANTS OF 1-000-025-0000
DOLLARS TO SMALL BUSINESSES AND
THE TEN INDUSTRIES THAT HAVE
MOST NEGATIVELY BEEN IMPACTED BY
THE PANDEMIC. OF THE MAY
REVISION ALSO INCLUDES SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND TO THE CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF
THE SMALL BUSINESS ADVOCATE TO
PROVIDE GRANTS OF THIRTY
THOUSAND TO FIFTY THOUSAND TWO
SMALL AGRICULTURAL BUSINESSES
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY THE
DROUGHT THESE BUSINESSES
INCLUDES SMALL FARMERS AS WELL
AS MANY TYPES OF SUPPORT OF
AGRICULTURAL BUSINESSES THIS
PROGRAM WILL FUNCTION SIMILARLY-TO THE EXISTING COVERED NINETEEN
RELIEF GRANT PROGRAM AND WILL BE
IMPLEMENTED IN CONSULTATION WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE. FOR THE
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY THE
PAY REVISION INCLUDES TWENTY
MILLION ONE TIME. AND FOUR POINT
EIGHT MILLION ONGOING GENERAL
FUND TO SUPPORT THE
REORGANIZATION OF THE OFFICE OF
DIGITAL INNOVATION CENTER FOR
EXCELLENCE AND TRANSFORMATION
AND CAL DATA TEAM UNDER A NEWLY
ESTABLISHED OFFICE OF DATA. AND
INNOVATION THE OFFICE OF THE TO
AND INNOVATION WILL EXIST WITHIN
THE GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY
IN TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE. SB ESTABLISHED BY A
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE AS A
STANDALONE DEPARTMENT BEGINNING
IN. TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR.
GOOD AFTERNOON TEN WEBER
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ALL SPEAK
TO THE GENERAL GOVERNMENT
FINANCE LETTER. FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF VETERAN
AFFAIRS MEMBERS OPPOSES FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS OF ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA VETERAN HEALTH
INITIATIVE THIS INITIATIVE IS
INTENDED TO SUPPORT BETTER
MENTAL HEALTH AND BETTER AND
SUICIDE PREVENTION EFFORTS AND
INCLUDE THAT RICH HAD YOU CAJUN
CAMPAIGN. GRANTS TO THEIR
ANSWERS PROVIDERS AND FUNDING%
FOR A TEAM TO RESEARCH BETTER
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FINANCING THEIR
VERSION PROPOSES THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS OF GENERAL FUND OVER
THREE YEARS FOR GRANTS TO COUNTY
ASSESSOR'S OFFICES FOR IT
UPGRADES. AND THEIR TWO NEW TAX
RIPPLES ONE OF THE EXTENSION OF
THE PAYCHECK PROTECTION PROGRAM
TAX CONFORMITY TO THOSE WHO
RECEIVE LOANS AFTER MARCH OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND THE OTHER
IS A FIX TO THE MAIN STREET TAX
CREDITS THAT TAXPAYERS DESERVE
THE CREDIT HAVE MORE FLEXIBILITY
TO CLAIM THE CREDIT ON THEIR
INCOME TAX RETURNS. YEP NATURE
MEMBERS HER SCRIPT OF THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCIER PRESENT ON
THE CONTROL SECTIONS. WE HAVE
FIVE CONTROL SECTIONS WITH.
AMENDMENTS PROPOSED THE MAYOR
VISION. THE FIRST CONTROL
SECTION IS EIGHT POINT SEVEN
FIVE WHICH RELATED TO
APPROPRIATIONS ARE THE FEDERAL
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT AND
JOBS ACT- THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDED CONTROL SECTION EIGHT
POINT SEVEN FIVE TO CREATE- JUST
BUDGET ITEMS TO MEET STATE
MATCHING REQUIREMENTS FOR
FEDERAL INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING.
THE MAY REVISION PROPOSES
AMENDMENTS TO CREATE OR JUST
BUDGET ITEMS- TO ACTUALLY
EFFICIENTLY IMPLEMENT THAT
FEDERAL INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING.
SECOND ITEMS CONTROL SECTION.
ELEVEN POINT NINETY ONE. THE
GOAL OF THIS CONTROL SECTION IS
TO OPTIMIZE THE USE OF GENERAL
FUND FOR OVER NINETEEN SPENDING-
BY MAXIMIZING THE UE OF VARIOUS
FEDERAL FUNDS INCLUDING THE
FEDERAL EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
AGENCY OR FEMA. PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDED ONE
POINT TWO FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
IN GENERAL FUND- TO COVER COVERT
COSTS IN THE BUDGET YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE- AND THE
MAYOR VISION PROPOSES.
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR A TOTAL
OF TWO POINT THREE THREE BILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND FOR
COVERT COSTS IN THE BUDGET YEAR.
ADMINISTRATION ALSO POSES SOME
TECHNICAL CHANGES. TO BUDGET
EMERGENCY RESPONSE FUNDING.
THROUGH THE EMERGENCY. RELIEF
FUND INSTEAD OF THE GENERAL
FUND. THIRD AYE MR SECTION POINT
NINE SIX- THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDED CONTROL SECTION ELEVEN
POINT NINE SIX TO PROVIDE
FLEXIBILITY- TO MAKE
ADMINISTRATIVE ADJUSTMENTS TO
HOW THE STATE FISCAL RECOVERY
FUNDS APPROPRIATED CALIFORNIA
UNDER THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN
ACTS WERE TO BE EXPENDED- AND
THEY REVISION MAKES TECHNICAL IN
CLARIFYING CHANGES- ALSO
INCREASES THE- STATE. REVENUE
LOSS ESTIMATE TO UP TO SIXTEEN
POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS. AND
ALSO SHIPS ABOUT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS FOR THREE PROGRAMS
CURRENTLY FUNDED BY THE STATE
FISCAL RECOVERY FUNDS TO THE
GENERAL FUND. FOURTH ITEM IS
CONTROL ECTION TWELVE POINT
ZERO ZERO WHICH IS STEP WHICH IS
THE STATE APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT.
ON THE FINANCE LETTER FOR THIS
CONTROL SECTION- REFLECTS SEES
ME UPDATES THE PRIOR YEAR STATE
APPROPRIATION LIMIT TO REFLECT
REVISED GROWTH FACTORS AS WELL
AS SHIPS IN FINANCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY AT THE MAY
REVISION. THE REVISED STATE
APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
FISCAL YEAR IS ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS WHICH MARKS A FOUR POINT
THREE BILLION DOLLAR INCREASE
OVER THE JANUARY ESTIMATE. AND
THE FINAL ITEMS CONTROL SECTION
THIRTY FIVE POINT FIVE ZERO. AND
THIS CONTROL SECTION FINANCE
LETTER REFLECTS UPDATED GENERAL
FUND REVENUES AS WELL AS
ESTIMATES FOR THE BUDGET
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT FOR
PROPOSITION TWO TWENTY FOURTEEN
AS REQUIRED BY STATUTE. AND THE
BUDGET STABILIZATION ACCOUNT
ESTIMATES REFLECT UPDATED
REVENUES AT THE MAYOR VISION.
AND WITH ME ARE MY COLLEAGUES
FROM PARTNER FINANCE RELEVANT
DEPARTMENTS TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE THANK
YOU. SIR L. A. O. SKINNER
PERCENT WRECKED. YEAH THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR GRANULAR FROM THE L.
A. O. ALL RIGHT YOU'RE OVER
THERE SORRY IS. FROM THE PEANUT
GALLERY LA HOPE IS- BEFORE-
MOVING TO OUR OUR COMMENTS ON
THE INDIVIDUAL PROPOSAL JUST
VERY BRIEFLY WANT TO OFFER A
COUPLE OF HIGH LEVEL COMMENTS ON
THE KIND OF THE STRUCTURE THE
MAY REVISION OVERALL. OVERALL
THE MAY REVISION ALLOCATES FIFTY
TWO BILLION AND A GENERAL FUND
SURPLUS WITH THE LARGEST TWO
CATEGORIES GOING TO NATURAL
RESOURCES AND TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAMS. OTHER MEMBERS INCLUDES
THIRTY NINE BILLION PROPOSALS TO
ME A STATE APPROPRIATION LIMITS
REQUIREMENTS AND THIS INCLUDES A
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION- IN TAX
REFUNDS AND THIRTEEN BILLION FOR
CAPITAL OUTLAY- THE MIRRORS AND
DOES LEAVE SOME SELL
REQUIREMENTS UNADDRESSED IN
PARTICULAR. A THREE POINT FIVE
BILLION IN REQUIREMENTS IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND WE
THINK- OVER TWENTY BILLION IN
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR AND
DOESN'T SET FORTH A PLAN FOR
ADDRESSING THOSE FUTURE
REQUIREMENTS- WHICH WE THINK
PRESENTS SOME RISKS TO THE THAT
BUDGET PLAN- IN ADDITION WE SEE
THAT CERTAIN. ECONOMIC
INDICATORS THAT HISTORICALLY
HAVE A SIGNALED- A RECESSION
COULD BE ON THE RISE IN ARE
SUGGESTING THAT THE BUDGET MAY
BE FACING SOME DOWNSIDE RISK
GOING FORWARD- GIVEN THESE
FACTORS WE WOULD SUGGEST OF THE
LEGISLATURE THAT RESERVES WILL
BE ESSENTIAL. TO THE STATE AND
MAINTAINING ITS CURRENT LEVEL OF
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES GOING
FORWARD- SO WITH THAT LET ME.
MOVE THROUGH OUR COMMENTS ON A
NUMBER OF THE ITEMS POSE HERE
STARTING WITH OF THE CANNABIS
PROPOSALS- WE THINK THE
PROPOSALS TO MOVE- THE RETAIL
EXCISE POINT OF COLLECTION AND
TO ELIMINATE THE CULTIVATION
TAX- MATCH RECOMMENDATIONS.
WE'VE PREVIOUSLY MADE IN OUR
TWENTY NINETEEN REPORT- THE PER.
RATE CHANGE FOR THE RETAIL
EXCISE TAX IS PERHAPS MORE
COMPLEX THAN WOULD BE IDEAL-
THAT BEING SAID WE- WE RECOGNIZE
THAT THE PROPOSAL'S KALU TRYING
TO STRIKE A BALANCE BETWEEN-
KEEPING FUNDING FOR THE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE FUNDED OUT OF THESE
REVENUES BUT HELPING LICENSE
CANNABIS- THE LICENSE CANNABIS
MARKET COMPETE WITH THE ILLICIT
MARKET. ON HOUSING- WE THINK
THAT CONTINUES THEY FUNDING TO
ADDRESS THESE AREAS IS.
REASONABLE GIVEN THE SCALE OF
THE CHALLENGES FACED BY THE
STATE BUT WE THINK THERE MAY BE
OPPORTUNITIES TO LEVERAGE.
EXISTING PROGRAMS TO ACHIEVE
EFFICIENCY IS AN APPROVED
PROGRAM MINISTERED MINISTRATION
AS OPPOSED TO PURSUING SOME OF
THE NEW AND EXPANDED PROGRAMS
THAT THE MAY REVISION SETS
FORTH- IN ADDITION THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSES TO. ALLOCATE
HOUSING FUNDING FOR HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS OVER MULTIPLE
YEARS- UNDER THE CONSIDERATION
OF SOME OF THE ISSUES
SURROUNDING THE STATE
APPROPRIATIONS ON THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT TO
CONSIDER APPROPRIATING. ALL OF
THE FUNDING THIS YEAR A TO BE
DISPERSED OVER A NUMBER OF YEARS
AND THIS WOULD HAVE THE
ADVANTAGE. OF ALLOWING THE
LEGISLATURE TO WEIGH IN NOW ON
AN AMOUNT OF MONEY TO GO TO
HOUSING- AND SPREADING THAT
BENEFIT OVER A NUMBER OF YEARS-
MORE OVER AN ADDITIONAL BENEFIT
THAT COULD BE GAINED FROM THAT
IS AS WE MENTIONED- IF IN FACT
THE STATE DOES. START TO SEE
SOME ECONOMIC SLOWDOWN IN FUTURE
YEARS IT IT COULD GAIN SOME
BENEFIT AND HAVING ADDITIONAL
INFRASTRUCTURE DOLLARS GOING
INTO THE ECONOMY. IN THOSE IN
THE FUTURE TIME PERIOD. ON A
BROAD BAND- WE KNOW THAT THE
BUDGET YEAR. THERE'S NO
APPROPRIATION IN THE BUDGET YEAR
AND THERE'S NO ABOUT YOUR BILL
OR OVER LANGUAGE THAT CODIFIES.
THE OUT YOUR ALLOCATIONS THAT
ARE PROPOSED. UNDER THE MAY
REVISION- IN ADDITION THERE ARE
OTHERS ANTICIPATED FEDERAL FUNDS
COMING TO THE STATE IN TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR AND TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS MADE. SOME
ALLOWANCES FOR THOSE FUNDS TO
FLOW INTO THE STATE'S EFFORTS IN
THIS AREA. ON GIVEN THESE
FACTORS WE THINK THE LEGISLATURE
COULD- THE LADY MAKING ANY
DECISIONS ON THESE
APPROPRIATIONS- OR UNTIL NEXT
YEAR. ON THE TAX BILL
FLEXIBILITY- WE THINK THAT THE
CONCEPT- DOES HAVE SOME MERIT-
BUT WE FEEL THAT THE PERHAPS-
LIKELY MODEST BENEFITS THE MOST
TAXPAYERS- I CANNOT JUSTIFY THE
RELATIVELY HIGH COSTS OF
ADMINISTERING THE PROGRAM IS
ESTIMATED. BY THE ADMINISTRATION
. ON E. I. T. C. OUT REACH
THERE'S A NUMBER OF PROPOSED OUT
REACH EFFORTS- WE HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT- ONE PROPOSAL FOR FTV TO
PROACTIVELY REACH OUT TO
HOUSEHOLDS WHO MAY BE ELIGIBLE
FOR YET YOU SEE BUT DID NOT
CLAIM IT. AND WHILE THIS SEEMS
LIKE IT COULD BE A REASONABLE
PROPOSED- BASED ON PREVIOUS
ATTEMPTS TO MAKE SIMILAR EFFORTS
WE THINK IT'S LIKELY TO BE AN
EFFECTIVE. ON THE PROPOSALS
WITHIN GOBIZ TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL RELIEF GRANTS TO
BUSINESSES- THE STATE HAS MADE A
CAN'T RELIEF GRANTS TO SMALL
BUSINESSES FOLLOWING AN APPROACH
THAT PRIORITIZE. RAPID
DISBURSEMENT OF ASSISTANCE TO
BUSINESSES AND WE THINK THAT
THAT WAS  WARRANTED AS A
PRIORITY DURING THE HEIGHT OF
THE PANDEMIC BUT- THAT APPROACH
DID MAKE SOME TRADE OFFS IN THE
YEARS OF TRANSPARENCY AND
OVERSIGHT AND EFFECTIVE
TARGETING AND WE THINK THAT
APPROACH IS NO LONGER WARRANTED
NOW THAT THE ECONOMY. HAS
RECOVERED FROM THE DEPTHS OF THE
PANDEMIC AND SWEET- I. REJECTING
ALLOCATING FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
FOR THE NEW HARD HIT INDUSTRIES
GRANT PROGRAM SIMILARLY ON THE-
RELIEF GRANTS- FOR AT DROUGHT-
WE HAVE A SIMILAR CONCERN- THE
PROPOSALS TO FOLLOW AGAIN A AND
AN EMERGENCY MODEL THAT APPROACH
IS GETTING THE FUNDING OUT
RAPIDLY. AND GIVEN THAT DROUGHT
IS A LONG STANDING PROBLEM FOR
THE STATE WILL CONTINUE TO BE A
PROBLEM GOING FORWARD WE DON'T
THINK THAT THAT KIND OF- THAT
THAT APPROACH THAT PRIORITIZES
RAPID DISBURSEMENT OVER THESE
OTHER FACTORS IS APPROPRIATE AS
AN APPROPRIATE MODEL FOR THAT
FUNDING. ALL ON THE O. D. I.
PROPOSAL WERE STILL REVIEWING
THE PROPOSAL- IT GENERALLY
APPEARS REASONABLE GIVEN THE
OVERLAP. IN ADMINISTRATIVE AND
PROGRAMMATIC RESPONSIBILITIES OF
THESE ENTITIES WITH THEN GOV
OPS. WE THINK THERE ARE SOME
ELEMENTS THAT COULD BE CLARIFIED
IN TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE. AND
FINALLY ON THE OFFICE OF
COMMUNITY- PARTNERSHIPS AND
STRATEGIC COMMUNICATIONS- IN. IN
JANUARY WE NOTED THERE COULD BE
SOME MERIT IN HAVING A PERSON
WITHIN THE ADMINISTRATION TO
BETTER COORDINATE THE STATE'S
EFFORTS. ARE OFTEN DISPARATE AND
DUPLICATIVE EFFORTS- FOR PUBLIC
AT REACH ACROSS STATE AGENCIES-
BUT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL TO CREATE A LARGE NEW
OFFICE WITHIN- PR- RAISES MANY
CONCERNS FOR US IT'S ALSO NOT
CLEAR WHETHER IT MAKES SENSE. TO
MOVE- PUBLIC EVERYTHING
ACTIVITIES IN THE AREAS OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AND DROUGHT- FROM
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
TO. A NEW AGENCY AT OPR- WE'RE
CONCERNED THAT THIS COULD DELAY
THOSE OUT REJECTED BT'S AND
WE'RE ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT
WHETHER THEADMINISTRATION HAS
ADEQUATELY CONSIDERED. OR TAKEN
TAKEN STEPS TO AVOID DUPLICATION
OF EFFORTS WITH LOCAL AGENCIES
DOING SIMILAR OUTREACH. WITH
THAT WERE HAPPENING ANSWERING
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATIONS- MISTER COOPER
YEAH I DO HAVE A QUESTION
REGARDING THE MIDDLE MILE WE
TALKED ABOUT- IS A FLEXIBILITY
TO ALSO USE THAT SUPPORT FOR THE
LAST MILE PROJECTS THERE'S A BIT
THE SAME COST PRESSURES. CRISCO
WITH DEPARTMENT FINANCE- I
BELIEVE THERE MAY BE A COLLEAGUE
ON THE LINE WHO COULD ANSWER
THAT.
BOB. HI THIS IS SCOTT ADAMS THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF- BROADBAND
AND DIGITAL LITERACY- STANDING
UP FOR PARKMAN ROAD WHO SAID
OVER AT THIS BUDGET COMMITTEE
HEARING- YOU REPEAT THE QUESTION
PLEASE. AS FAR AS THE FUNDING
FOR THE FOR THE MIDDLE MILE IS
OUR FLEXIBILITY BUT IT CAN ALSO
BE USED TO SUPPORT THE LAST MILE
PROJECTS THEY'RE SUBJECT TO THE
SAME COST PRESSURES. I'M NOT TO
SURE BACKUP NEW DEAD. ON EASY
SUBMITTED BY BOB RELATED COST
PRESSURES THE BELMONT. YOU'RE
YOU'RE CUTTING OUT I GOT BITS
AND PIECES OF WHAT YOU JUST SAID
. I'M SORRY THE PROPOSAL THAT
WAS SUBMITTED IT'S REALLY AREN'T
. COST PRESSURES SPACE TO MODEL
AND WHY THEY MAY BE SIMILAR ON
THE LINE MONTH THAT WE'RE GOING
START AND WE'RE TO ASK YOU CARE
OFF AND HOPEFULLY WERE ABLE TO
pCRITICAL THAT OUR CONVERSATIONS
ARE BROADBAND OR ABLE TO.
CLEARLY HEAR YOU. HOW IS THIS
YOU HEAR ME NOW. BETTER YES
THAT'S BETTER. YES. MAKE YOUR
POLICIES I'M- I WE'RE NOT QUITE
- THE FUNNY THING IS PREPARE IT
FOR THE DAM MILE. ON THAT THEY
CALL PRESSURES AND FISH WITH THE
MIDDLE MOM AND WHILE THEY MAY BE
THE SAME FOR THE MONTH- I WOULD
TO CIRCLE BACK YOU FOR ANY ON
THE- YEAH IF YOU COULD DO THAT
BE GREAT. THANK YOU. THE ALL ALL
OF THAT MISTER THERE HAVE BEEN A
OF HERE WHERE GET THE
CONVERSATION WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
FOLLOW UP AND GET TO INFORMATION
AND THAT INFORMATION ARRIVES
LATE HOW QUICKLY OR HOW SOON CAN
WE SET A DEADLINE FOR YOU TO
PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION. HI I
THINK WE CAN PROVIDE THAT WITHIN
THE NEXT. YOUR. TO THE NEXT DAY
OR TWO OKAY THANK YOU. JUST
WANTED TO KNOW DID THIRD OF EACH
OF THESE COMMISSIONERS- DURING A
LOT OF THE LAST SO WE WOULD HAVE
TO CONSULT WITH THEM AS WELL.
OKAY THANK YOU. AN ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS MISTER COOPER. OKAY
APOLOGIES THAT I HAD TO STEP OUT
AND GO VOTE IN UTILITIES RIGHT
NEXT DOOR- I DO HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS RELATED TO THE
PROPOSALS PRESENTED TODAY WE'RE
GOING TO START OFF WITH-
HOMELESSNESS THE MAY REVISION
INCLUDES A NEW PROPOSAL CALL THE
INTERIM HOUSING PLACEMENTS THAT
PROVIDES FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
OVER TWO YEARS TO ADDRESSED.
UNSHELTERED HOMELESSNESS ON
STATEOWNED LAND THROUGH TURKEY
GRANTS TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THERE IS NO TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE OR BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL DETAILING THE GRANTS
THE ACCOUNTABILITY PROVISIONS OR
HOW THE PROPOSAL THE PROPOSAL
AND PROGRAM WILL ROLL OUT CAN
YOU PROVIDE MORE DETAILS. CRISCO
THE DEPARTMENT FINANCES- WELL
ALLOW MY COLLEAGUE ON THE LINE
TO- TO GET READY I WILL SAY
THOUGH THAT WE WE'VE BEEN IN
CONTACT WITH STAFF AND WE'RE
PREPARING TO HAVE MORE DETAIL
WRITTEN TO SHARE AND PROVIDE- I
STAFF ON THE COMMITTEE. BUT WHAT
ASSET WHEN'S THE DEADLINE FOR
YOU TO DO THAT. I COULD DO IN
THE NEXT DAY OR SO. FINALIZING
THE DOCUMENT NOW BUT I WILL ASK
THAT MY COLLEAGUE AT FROM CALAIS
C. H. H. C. D. TO PLEASE-
ELABORATE A LITTLE BIT MORE IN
THE PROPOSAL WITH. IF THIS IS
SUCH A CARD GAME ANDTHE DEPUTY
SECRETARY FOR HOUSING AT THE
BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES AND
HOUSING AGENCY AND I'LL BE
SPEAKING ABOUT THIS CRISIS OF
WHAT WE'RE SPLIT IN THE OTHER
HEARING- THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION CHAIR. OF THE PROPOSAL
IS TO HAVE THE STATE ASSIST WITH
THAT INTERGOVERNMENTAL
COORDINATION FOR LAND SITE
PREPARATION AND PROCUREMENT OF
STRUCTURES THAT CAN BE USED TO
EXPEDITE HOUSING PLACEMENT
OPTIONS. REALLY TO ENSURE THAT
UNSHELTERED. UNSHELTERED
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE CURRENTLY ON
STATE RIGHT OF WAY. GET EXCEPT
IT CAN'T MINCE INTO STABLE
SUPPORTIVE INTERIM AND PERMANENT
HOUSING SETTINGS I'M THIS WOULD
INCLUDE FUNDING FOR THE
STRUCTURES FUNDING FOR SITE
PREPARATION WHEN REQUIRED. AND
ALSO SERVICES COMPONENTS THE
GRANTS WOULD BE ADMINISTERED BY
EACH TV AND WE WOULD WORK IN
CLOSE PARTNERSHIP WITH I. C. H.
TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR BEST
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS CONTINUE
TO STAY ALIGNED AND COORDINATED
WITH THINGS EXISTING PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU. THANK THANK YOU FOR
THAT MY CONCERN IS THAT
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR I HAVE ASKED
A NUMBER OF QUESTIONS ON THE
INCOMING GRAHAM PROCESS A
PROCESS THAT HAD VERY LITTLE
STRUCTURE AND STILL LEFT ME IN
THE COMMITTEE WITH MORE
QUESTIONS THAN ANSWERS THE
INCOMING GRAHAM PROGRAM HAD
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE IN THIS
PROGRAM DOES NOT ADDITIONALLY
I'D LIKE TO KNOW OUT OF THE WHAT
IS ADDRESSED HERE **** STATE
OWNED LAND WHICH IS CALTRANS
PROPERTIES. WHAT IS THE
PERCENTAGE OF UN HOUSED
INDIVIDUALS COMPARED TO THE REST
OF ENCAMPMENTS ACROSS THE STATE
PARTICULARLY SKID ROW WHICH IS
THE BIGGEST ENCAMPMENT IN THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY WHICH IS NOT ON
STATE PROPERTY. THAT'S A VERY
GOOD QUESTION I'M SURE I DO NOT
HAVE THOSE STATISTICS AT THE
READY I THINK THAT THE PIECE
THAT I WOULD BUT WE CAN SHARE
THE BEST INFORMATION THAT WE
HAVE AVAILABLE. THE PEACE. AFTER
THAT AFTER THE HEARING TODAY-
THE PIECE THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
LIFT UP IS JUST THE URGENCY- AND
THE- LACK OF SAFETY THAT EXISTS
FOR. I'M SHELTERED INDIVIDUALS
REGARDLESS OF WHERE THEY ARE
PARTICULARLY ON STATE RIGHT OF
WAY BECAUSE IT IS A J. SENT. TO
BE A KILLER TRAFFIC V. VERY FAST
MOVING VEHICULAR TRAFFIC AT
TIMES I'VE BEEN THIS IS RESIDENT
WITH SOME OF THE THINGS THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS SHARED ABOUT THE-
THE LACK OF I'M NOT ONLY
STABILITY AND BASIC SERVICES FOR
FOLKS. I'M LIVING THERE BUT ALSO
JUST SPECIFICALLY FOLKS THAT-
ARE SO ADJACENT TO ROADWAYS SO
THAT'S WHY THERE'S THIS FOCUS
HERE ON MAKING SURE THAT B. I'M
STATE IS ADDRESSING ENCAMPMENTS
ON ITS OWN LAND AND WORKING IN
COORDINATION WITH LOCALS I'M TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S WAYS TO
EXIT. SAFELY THANK YOU I DON'T
THINK THE WEARER DEBATING THE
MERITS OF. ENSURING THAT SAFETY
IS A PRIORITY ON. ON RIGHT AWAY
IS ON FREEWAYS ON CALTRANS
PROPERTY WHERE ASKING FOR THE
DETAILS AS TO HOW THIS PROGRAM
IS GOING TO BE ROLLED OUT. AND
COMPARATIVELY SPEAKING WHAT IS
THE PERCENTAGE OF IN HOUSE
INDIVIDUALS ON RIGHT OF WAYS
VERSUS THE PERCENTAGE OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE. NOT ON
STATE OWNED PROPERTY. YES I
UNDERSTAND AND THANK YOU FOR
THAT- WHAT I CAN SAY IS THAT THE
NUMBERS OF INDIVIDUALS ON STATE
RIGHT OF WAY OR IN THE THOUSANDS
I DO NOT HAVE THE NUMBERS OF THE
INDIVIDUALS LIVING ON IN. ON
CAN'T MEDS AND SKID ROW OR IN
OTHERS AREAS AT THE READY. THE
WAY THAT THIS WOULD BE
ADMINISTERED I AM IS REALLY.
THROUGH EACH TV THAT THE GRANTS
WOULD BE ADMINISTERED BUT AS I
MENTIONED- KELLY C. H. BRINGING
THEIR SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTISE.
ACCORDING TO SHIN WITH EXISTING
PROGRAMS INCLUDING BUT NOT
LIMITED TO THE ENCAMPMENT
RESOLUTION PROGRAMS TO ENSURE
THAT WE'RE GETTING SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY- COMPONENTS BUT I
KNOW THAT YOU'RE INTERESTED IN
AS YOU JUST STATED- ADDITIONALLY
WE WOULD BE PARTNERING CAN ABOUT
A STRIKE TEAM BASIS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE STATE CAN
ASSIST WITH PROCUREMENT OF
STRUCTURES. IDENTIFIED STATE OF
LAND FOR CITING- AND WORK TO
PROVIDE- OVERSIGHT OF SITE
IMPROVEMENTS IF LOCALITIES
NEEDED THAT SUPPORT. ELIGIBLE
APPLICANTS WOULD BE CITIES AND
COUNTIES. WHERE PEOPLE ARE
I'M AT THE ELIGIBLE USES COULD
BE THOSE STRUCTURES FOR RAPID OR
INTERIM SHELTER SITE PREPARATION
INCLUDING ELECTRICAL OR
SANITATION LAND ACQUISITION IF
NEEDED AND SERVICES FOR UP TO
THREE YEARS. THANK YOU FOR THAT
I JUST DID A QUICK GOOGLE SEARCH
WHILE LISTENING TO YOUR
PRESENTATION AND CALMATTERS HAS
AN ARTICLE BASED ON THE LAST
CALIFORNIA COUNT WHICH PUT THE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE THOUSAND
PEOPLE. THAT ARE ON HOUSE ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IF YOU
DO THAT THE SAME SEARCH FOR SKID
ROW IT'S OF MORE THAN EIGHT
THOUSAND PEOPLE THAT ARE ON
HOUSE ON SKID ROW SO AS WE
CONTINUE TO DEBATE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION OVER TWO YEARS TO
ADDRESSED UNSHELTERED.
INDIVIDUALS ON STATE OWNED LANDS
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
NEED PRIORITIZE WHERE THE NEEDS
ARE THE MOST- WHICH AS MENTIONED
SKID ROW IS THE BIGGEST
ENCAMPMENT IN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY
- AS WE PRIORITIZE. YOU KNOW
WHERE THESE FINDINGS ARE GOING
TO GO ESPECIALLY IF WE CAN DO A
COMPARISON ANALYSIS A TO HOW
MANY FOLKS ARE ACTUALLY ON.
STATEMENT THAT WOULD BE
INCREDIBLY HELPFUL TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT VERY MUCH- I
JUST WONDER IF I MAY WOULD JUST
MENTION ONE MORE THING AND THAT
THIS IS NOT CERTAINLY AS YOU
KNOW WELL THIS IS NOT THE ONLY
STRATEGY THAT WE ARE PUTTING
FORWARD OR ARE CURRENTLY
IMPLEMENTING WHEN IT COMES TO
ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS- AND
WORKING WITH ENCAMPMENTS AROUND
THE STATE. SO THIS IS ANOTHER
IMPORTANT SOLUTION ONE WHERE AS
YOU MENTIONED WE ALL WILL NOT BE
DEBATING THE MERITS OR THE NEED
FOR BRINGING PEOPLE INTO MORE
SAVE SITUATIONS- BUT REALLY AS
ANOTHERIMPORTANT TOOL FOR A
VERY CRITICAL NEED- WE WEEK WE
CAN FOLLOW UP WITH MORE DATA AS
YOU REQUESTED. THANK YOU AND IF
WE CAN FOLLOW UP AS TO I ASKED
IN THIS LAST COMMITTEE AS WELL-
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES DID
APPLY FOR A GRANT FOR I BELIEVE
SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLARS TO HELP
WITH THE ENCAMPMENTS ACROSS GET
ROW. AND I AM TALKING ABOUT SKID
ROW SPECIFICALLY AS THE CITY OF
LOS WITHIN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES IT IS NOT IN MY DISTRICT
SPECIFICALLY BUT IT'S RIGHT NEXT
DOOR TO THE DISTRICT THAT I
REPRESENT AND WITH THE CONTINUED
ECONOMIC BOOM IN DOWNTOWN LOS
ANGELES SKID ROW CONTINUES TO
GROW AND IT CONTINUES TO GROW
OUTSIDE OF SKID ROW AND IT'S NOW
GROWING. IN THE NEIGHBORHOODS
ACROSS THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
SO AS WE LOOK AT THIS BEING THE
HIGHEST AND MOST IMPORTANT THING
THAT CALIFORNIANS ARE TALKING
ABOUT I THINK IT BE IMPERATIVE
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
FOCUS ON BE BIGGEST ENCAMPMENT.
WHICH IS RIGHT HERE AT HOME. IN
OUR OWN STATE IN MY OWN BACKYARD
IN LOS ANGELES. SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE-
pTO KNOW. A REASON AS TO WHY THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES WAS NOT
GRANTED THAT SIXTEEN MILLION.
GRANT FOR ENCAMPMENTS. AND
FIGURE OUT A SOLUTION. THAT
ULTIMATELY ALSO HELPS-
NAVIGATORS ACROSS A SKID ROW IN
PARTICULAR. THANK YOU I'M I MAY
HAVE ANOTHER COLLEAGUE ON FROM
OUR INTERAGENCY COUNCIL ON
HOMELESSNESS BUT I'M OUR
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
COUNCIL IS IN THE SENATE.
HEARING SO AT VICTOR ARE YOU ON
AND DID WAS THERE ANYTHING YOU
WANTED TO ADD RELATED TO. THIS
YEAR. YES ARBITRON YOUR GRANTS
DIRECTOR WITH CALA SPEECH THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION MANAGER ON-
SO. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
DESIGNING INTO THE NEXT ROUND
TRIP IN CAMDEN RESOLUTION GRANTS
AS WE WOULD IMMEDIATELY
PRIORITIZED- A FUNDING THOSE
PROPOSALS THAT WERE NOT FUNDED
DURING THE FIRST ROUND I'VE
ALREADY HAD A WONDERFUL VERY
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATION WITH THE
LOS ANGELES- WITH THE FOLKS WHO
PRESS AMID THE PROPOSAL FROM LOS
ANGELES FOR SKID ROW- AND HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM ABOUT-
PROPOSAL AND SOME NEXT STEPS.
AND ASSURING THAT IF THE- FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION IN KEVIN
RESOLUTION- PART TWO WHERE TO
MOVE FORWARD THEY WOULD BE AT
THE FRONT OF THE LINE- FOR
HAVING THAT. HAVING A PROPOSAL
FUNDED- AS YOUR ALL THE WHERE
THE FIRST ITERATION OF THE
PROGRAM'S ONLY FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS- WE WERE OVERSUBSCRIBED
. IT WITH PROPOSALS- NEARLY
THREE TIMES OVER WHAT WAS
AVAILABLE- AND ONE OF THE IT WAS
COMPETITIVELY- SCORED
APPLICATION IT WAS NOT. BASED ON
POPULATION NEED LIKE SOME OF OUR
OTHER BLOCK GRANT FORMULA ARE-
AND ONE OF THE REQUIREMENTS OF
COURSE WAS TO SUPPORT AS MUCH
GEOGRAPHIC DIVERSITY AND THE-
AWARDS AS POSSIBLE- AND WE GET
AWARD PROPOSALS FOR TO OUR
PROPOSALS IN L. A. COUNTY ONE IN
LONG BEACH AND ONE IN THE CITY
OF LA AND WE REALLY LOOK FORWARD
TO. CONTINUING TO WORK WITH CITY
OF LA- TO FIND ADDITIONAL
PROPOSALS AS NEW RESOURCES COME
ONLINE. THANK YOU FOR THAT. WELL
WILL CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION
SAYS AS NEEDED THEN THANK YOU
WELL LET'S MOVE ON TO QUESTIONS
ON HOUSING CAN FINANCE EXPLAINED
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
RELATED TO HOUSING WHAT IS THE
GOAL BY LAYERING THESE GOALS
OVER THE EXISTING PROGRAM WHO
DECIDES WHAT AND HOW. THE GOALS
WORK. THANKS FOR THE QUESTION SO
THE HOUSING TRADABLE INTENT IS
TO- IDENTIFY SOME PRIORITY AREAS
IN THE STATE MANY OF THOSE WHICH
ARE ALREADY EXISTING- I BELIEVE
ALL OF THEM ARE EXISTING HOUSING
POLICY GOALS. FOR EXAMPLE-
REDUCE SEEN EM TEA AND THE
CLIMATE FOCUSED OBJECTIVE SO
THAT THE TRAILER BILL IS MORE-
INTENDED TO BRING THOSE ALL
TOGETHER AND USES AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR SOME OF THE STATE PROGRAMS
AND HOUSING. TO POINT TO AND TO
IDENTIFY THOSE HOUSING PRIORITY
AREAS AND TO BE USED. AS THE
GOALS THAT THAT THOSE PROGRAMS
ARE TRYING TO ACHIEVE. THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE SAYS THAT
THIS POLICY WOULD GO INTO EFFECT
JULY OF JULY FIRST OF THIS YEAR.
HAS THIS POLICY BEEN VETTED
ANYWHERE- OR WITH ANY
STAKEHOLDERS AND IF SO WITH WHOM
. I'LL ASK IF THERE'S ANY
COLLEAGUES FROM- THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING RESEARCH ON THE LINE IF
THEY'VE HAD ANY CONVERSATIONS
WITH ANY STAKEHOLDERS. HONEST
LANGUAGE.
THIS IS CAN YOU HEAR ME THIS IS
NEW IN TARA KEEP FROM OPR YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT YES I AM
I DO NOT HAVE. INFORMATION ON
THAT IMMEDIATELY AT HAND BUT WE
WILL FOLLOW UP TO GET
INFORMATION ON THAT QUESTION. IS
THERE SOMEONE THAT YOU CAN CALL
THAT MAY HAVE THAT INFORMATION
ON HAND FOR THIS HEARING. HI
SORRY ABOUT THAT. ISSUE AND YET
LET ME REACH OUT TO A COLLEAGUE
HERE AND SEE IF WE CAN GET A
RESPONSE JUST ONE JUST ONE
MINUTE. SHARKS. THE REQUESTED MR
COOPER- I WANNA GO BACK ON
SOMETHING I FORGOT TO ASK
EARLIER CHARLOTTE FALL DATE
LET'S GIVE THEM SOME TIME TO DO
A LITTLE BIT OF RESEARCH AND YOU
CAN ASK YOUR QUESTION AS WELL
THANK YOU. THE OTHER CANNABIS
TAX PROPOSAL COULD YOU TALK
ABOUT THE STRUCTURE OF IT. AND
GO MORE IN DEPTH ON THAT. SURE
IS THE DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS ON
THE LINE. HI NICOLE ELLIOTT
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT
CAMPUS PLAN TO BE HERE WITH YOU
GUYS TODAY I'M ALSO JOINED BY
NICK MADURO'S- I BELIEVE OR SEND
YOU WILL SEND FROM THAT COMPANY
DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION. I HAD TO SPEAK
ON THIS ISSUE IF EITHER OF THEM
ARE ON THE LINE WHICH WE ARE
DOING DOUBLE DUTY AND BOTH AT
COMMITTEE HEARINGS RIGHT NOW.
YES THIS IS NICK WITH- SOME
ONLINE. THANK YOU NICK WOULD YOU
LIKE TO WALK THROUGH THE TAX
PROPOSAL. SURE SO A SITE
TESTIFIED I RECENTLY- WE HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS AROUND THE
CURRENT STRUCTURE OF THE-
CANNABIS TAXES AND STATE- AND
RECOMMENDED THAT WE BOTH
SIMPLIFY THE TAX STRUCTURE TO
MAKE IT EASIER FOR TAXPAYERS-
SIMPLER FOR CONSUMERS AND
FRANKLY- ENABLE OUR TEAM TO
BETTER MINISTER THE TAX- THAT
CANNABIS TAXES. AS WELL AS TO
ADD ENFORCEMENT PROVISIONS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN- WORK MOST
EFFECTIVELY TO- ADDRESSED THE
ARE VERY SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM OF
THE ILLEGAL MARKET- THAT WE FIND
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND SO- THE PROPOSAL WOULD MOVE
THE EXCISE TAX WHICH IS THE 15%
TAX- FROM THE DISTRIBUTOR TO THE
RETAILER WHICH IS- THE WAY THE
TAX WAS STRUCTURED IN PROP SIXTY
FOUR- THAT WOULD HAVE A NUMBER
OF BENEFITS- FIRST IT WOULD
ALIGN BETTER LINE THE TAX WITH.
PROP SIXTY FOUR IT WOULD
ELIMINATE THIS- SITUATION WE
HAVE CURRENTLY WHERE WE- COME UP
WITH IT- AVERAGE STATEWIDE
MARKUP RATE. TWICE A YEAR- THAT
RESULTS FRANKLY IN WILDLY
VARYING TAX RATES- FOR VARIOUS
PARTS OF THE STATE AND IT'S VERY
CONFUSING- TO CONSUMERS AND
RETAILERS- WE BELIEVE THAT WOULD
RESULT IN BY MANY FEWER
REPORTING ERRORS ON OUR RETURNS-
IT WILL MAKE OUR COMPLIANCE
EFFORTS MUCH MORE
STRAIGHTFORWARD- AS WELL AS
ALLOW US TO. LEVERAGE OUR VERY
LARGE SALES AND USE TAX- JEAN TO
ALSO TRY TO ADDRESS THE-
PROBLEMS IN THE CAMPUS MARKET
SINCE. THE CANNABIS RETAILERS
ARE SALES AND USE TAX PAYERS SO
WE'RE ALREADY WORKING WITH THEM
ON SALES AND USE- AND
FURTHERMORE IT- THE MOVE MOVING
THIS TO THE POINT OF SALE- WOULD
ELIMINATE A LOT OF THE DISPUTES
THAT WE'RE- IN BETWEEN. JUST AND
RETAILERS ABOUT WHO IN FACT DOES
THE TAXES AND- WHETHER OR NOT
THE DISTRIBUTORS HAVE BEEN-
GIVEN THE MONEY FOR THE TAXES
AND WOOD- I BELIEVE THAT THIS
REALLY STREAMLINED THE THIS
SITUATION FOR US IN THE
ENFORCEMENT PIECES ARE EQUALLY
IMPORTANT IT WOULD SIMPLY GIVE
US THE TOOLS THAT WE HAVE IN
OTHER TAX PROGRAMS INCLUDING
SALES AND USE TAX. AS WELL AS IN
OUR- TOBACCO TAX PROGRAMS TO
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE
COMPLYING WITH THE TAXES- YOU
COMPLAIN I CAN GOING TO THOSE IN
MORE DETAIL IF YOU'D LIKE BUT-
THEY'RE PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD-
AND ALIGN OUR CANNABIS TAXES
WITH THOSE OTHER. TAXES. THANK
YOU. I KNOW WE HAVE THE SAME
ISSUE LAST YEAR AND ADJUSTED AND
ON A DIFFERENT TOPIC. ON THE-
THE FUNDING FOR EDUCATION AND
INTERVENTION TREATMENT. IT WAS
IT WAS VERY VERY LAST YEAR WHAT
IT WAS. I THINK THEY DIDN'T GIVE
ALL THEY GASSER ARE COMPLETE
ANSWER WHAT WHAT THAT DID
SPECIFICALLY. CAN SOMEONE COME
ALONG THAT. HI THIS IS KIMBERLY
HARVEST DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE
HAVE A- DOCUMENT THAT WE'VE
SHARED WITH COMMITTEE STAFF
MOVED OVER TO YOU ON WHAT YOU TO
THE DEPARTMENTS DO WHAT THAT
FUNDING. CAN YOU TELL ME THAT
REYNELLA- I DON'T HAVE AT HAND
I'M SORRY. BUT BUT IT IS THE
THREE BUCKETS A 60% FOR THE
YOUTH EDUCATION TREATMENT
PREVENTION. 20% FOR NATURAL
RESOURCE PROTECTION AND THEN 20%
OR LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT OF
SAFETY. SURE SO I'D LIKE TO
BROKEN ON THAT ALSO THE LAST
BUDGET CYCLE WHAT IT DID FOR
THERE WAS DIFFERENT LAST TIME
WAS THIS TIME ALSO. IF YOU COULD
READ THAT ALSO ON THE EDUCATION
PORTION. OKAY WILL PROVIDE THAT
TO YOU- EITHER THIS AFTERNOON OR
TOMORROW. OKAY THANK YOU. THE
REPORT. THANK YOU. I REGARDING
THE PROPOSED CANNABIS RETAIL
GRANT PROGRAM WHAT WOULD BE THE
TIMELINE TO ROLL OUT THIS
PROGRAM IS THERE AN ANTICIPATED
ANTICIPATED DEADLINE. FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO APPLY. THANK
YOU FOR THAT QUESTION- WE WOULD
ANTICIPATE IF APPROVED WOULD
SEEK TO- ISSUE THE SOLICITATION
FOR THIS GRANT PROGRAM IN THE
FIRST QUARTER OF TWENTY TWENTY
THREE AND I'M CALENDAR YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY THREE I SHOULD
SAY. SPENDING THE SIX MONTHS
BETWEEN JULY FIRST AND THEEND
OF THE YEAR WORKING WITH-
ELIGIBLE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO
DEVELOP A PROGRAM THAT BEST
SUITS THEIR NEEDS. SO THE SECOND
PART OF THE QUESTION THE
ANTICIPATED DEADLINE FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO APPLIES WITHIN
. YEAH THAT IS IT SO SORRY FOR
CLARIFICATION THAT WOULD BE PART
OF THE GUIDELINE PROCESS THAT WE
WOULD BE DEVELOPING WITHIN THE
NEXT SIX MONTHS BUT WE WOULD
OBVIOUSLY BE WORKING IN EARNEST
TO ENSURE THAT THAT SOLICITATION
PROCESS. I IS PRETTY SWIFT
SIMILAR TO THE WAY THAT WE
STRUCTURE IT ARTICLE
JURISDICTION ASSISTANCE GRANT
PROGRAM FROM LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
I WOULD OPEN IT CLOSED IN. TWO
MONTHS. THANK YOU AND WITH THE
DEPARTMENT BE ABLE TO INCLUDE IN
ITS ANNUAL REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE AN UPDATE ON THE
JURISDICTIONS THAT APPLIED AND
WHERE THE AWARDS WERE GRANTED.
ABSOLUTELY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS CODE TWO SIX ONE
NINE ZERO DOES REQUIRE US REPORT
ANNUALLY STARTING IN MARCH FIRST
OF NEXT YEAR WE CAN- VERY
HAPPILY I INCLUDE DATES ON THIS
PROGRAM AS PART OF THAT. WOULD
YOU BE ABLE TO. BREAK DOWN THE
JURISDICTIONS BETWEEN ASSEMBLY
DISTRICTS. OR HOW IS IN CHECK
HOW HOW IS A BROKE INTO. I SAW
IT WOULD BE PER CITY OR COUNTY-
I THINK WE CAN INDICATE IN THAT-
REPORTING STRUCTURE WHICH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT ASSOCIATED
WITH I THOUGHT I WOULD BE. YEAH
THAT WOULD BE REALLY HELPFUL IF
YOU'RE ABLE TO INCLUDE THAT. AND
LASTLY JUST TO KIND OF ECHO MR
COOPER'S QUESTION HOW WAS THE
19% EXCISE TAX CEILING
DETERMINED. A FOR THAT QUESTION
I WILL DEFER TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. HI THIS IS KIMBERLY
HARVESTING AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE 19% IS REFLECTIVE OF
WHAT THE TAX RATE IS NOW BECAUSE
THE TAX RATE IS CURRENTLY. ABOUT
FOUR IT'S 4% FOR CULTIVATION
WHICH WE ARE ZEROING OUT AND
IT'S 15% EXCISE TAX. SO IN AN
EFFORT TO TRY TO MAINTAIN A
BALANCE BETWEEN HELP THINKING OF
THE FOLKS THAT HAVE COME INTO
THE LEGAL MARKET WE WANT TO
SUPPORT THEM BY GIVING THEM A
TAX BREAK BY LOWERING THE
CULTIVATION IMMEDIATELY AND-
PROVIDE THAT WE'RE ALSO
COGNIZANT THAT THERE ARE
PROGRAMS. AS MEDICAL PREVENTION
TO THAT RELY ON FUNDING FROM THE
ALLOCATION THREE PART OF THE TAX
REVENUE SO WE'RE TRYING TO
STRIKE A BALANCE. BETWEEN THE
PROVIDING FUNDING FOR THOSE
PROGRAMS BUT ALSO LOWERING THE
TAX- ARDEN ON FOLKS WITH THE
IDEA THAT IF THE TAXES ARE LOWER
THE HOPE IS THAT THEY'LL BE
MORE. LEGAL CANNABIS SOLD SO
THAT THE OVERALL REVENUE.
REMAINS ABOUT THE SAME AND THEN
WE'VE ALSO- ARE PROPOSING A
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR.
GENERAL FUND BACK FILL TO SORT
OF MITIGATE ANY. LOWER REVENUE
IF NEEDED AND THEN THE TAX RATE
CHANGE- BETWEEN FIFTEEN AND
NINETEEN PERCENT. IS ANOTHER
MITIGATION STRATEGY. THANK YOU
MUCH APPRECIATE THE ANSWER. CAN
WE GO BACK TO. OF BACK TO
HOUSING TO THE QUESTION ON
STAKEHOLDERS IS THAT. DO WE HAVE
THE INDIVIDUAL ONLINE. FIVE IS
NEWMAN TARA KEY AGAIN FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF PLANNING
RESEARCH AND WE HAVE DONE SOME
PRELIMINARY OUTRAGE I DON'T HAVE
THE LIST OF STAKEHOLDERS AND
WHAT THAT ENGAGEMENT HAS LOOKED
LIKE- WE HAVE DONE NO FORMAL IN
ABOUT REGION ENGAGEMENT EFFORT
BUT- I CAN CIRCLE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES TO. GET ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION WE CAN SHARE THAT IN
THAT- AS A FOLLOW UP. OKAY THAT
WOULD BE REALLY GREAT IF WE CAN
HAVE THAT INFORMATION PLEASE.
LET'S MOVE ONTO A DIFFERENT
TOPIC AGO THIS. CAN GO BATES
EXPLAINED THE GRANTS FOR THE
HARD OF FOR THE HARD HIT
BUSINESSES HOW WAS THE PROGRAM
SIZED AND HOW WILL CAL ALWAYS BE
A ENSURE. THAT IT IS
ADMINISTERED EQUITABLY THIS THE
PROGRAM ON A FIRST COME FIRST
SERVE BASIS. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE QUESTION BRIAN RUTLEDGE
BUDGET OFFICER. GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. SO IN TERMS OF THIS
SIZE THE ADMINISTRATION WAS
TRYING TO. REVISED SOME
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT WE KNOW THAT-
BUSINESSES THAT WERE THE HARDEST
HIT AT SPECIFICALLY FOOD
SERVICES ACCOMMODATION THOSE
INDUSTRIES THAT SAW DRAMATIC
LOSSES IN TERMS OF PERCENTAGE OF
JOBS THAT WENT AWAY BUT UNDER
COBIT. WE'RE TRYING TO GET THEM
BACK TO WHERE THEY WERE AND TO
DRIVE THE RECOVERY SO THAT'S THE
IMPETUS FOR THIS PROGRAM. IN
TERMS OF THE SIZING ARE WE
ANTICIPATE THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF AWARDS TO
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF BUSINESSES-
THERE IS AVAILABLE RESOURCE
CONSTRAINTS SO- WE DO BELIEVE
THERE'S FIVE HUNDRED MILLION UP
DEMAND OUT THERE AN ELIGIBILITY-
BUT THAT'S IN TERMS OF HOW WE
GOT TO THE FIVE HUNDRED. MILLION
SO IN TERMS OF EQUITY WE THIS
COMMITTEES FOCUS ON EQUITY-
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE
WE KNOW THAT'S A PRIORITY
ADMINISTRATION CERTAINLY SHARES
THAT AND HELLO IT'S BE A- THE
DIRECTOR APOLOGIES- APOLOGIZES
COULD NOT BE HERE TODAY. BUT SHE
SHE SHARES THAT SO WITH THIS
PROGRAM THE HARD HIT INDUSTRIES.
THE WAY WE WOULD ENSURE THAT
EQUITY AND INCLUSION IT IS BIG
TEN YEARS WE WOULD LEVERAGE THE
COBIT RELIEF GRANT PROGRAMS
NETWORK OF TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROVIDERS- AND OTHER EXISTING
PRACTICES THAT ESSENTIALLY IN
THE LAST TWO YEARS WE'VE
DEVELOPED- IN IN GETTING OUT
GRANTS TO SMALL BUSINESSES FOR
RELIEF. I WOULD ALSO DO
CAMPAIGNS MEDIA CAMPAIGNS IN
MULTIPLE LANGUAGES THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE SORT OF
WORKED OUT AND ARE. MOVING
TOWARDS A SUCCESSFUL MODEL SO WE
WOULD BASICALLY BE LEVERAGING
THE COMPANY RELIEF GRANT
PROGRAM. TRYING TO USE THE
NETWORKS AND THE PRACTICES WE-
WE'VE SEEN THAT ARE EFFECTIVE IN
GETTING AWARENESS UP. AND ALSO
ENSURES THAT DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES HAVE A MAXIMUM
PARTICIPATION. THAT WHILE ALL
LEAVE IT THERE BUT- HAPPY TO ADD
ANYTHING IF THAT'S HELPFUL. DO
YOU THINK THAT THE PROGRAM WILL
BE OVERSUBSCRIBED. WE DO THINK
THE AWFUL FIVE HUNDRED WILL GO
OUT AND PROBABLY YOU KNOW
RELATIVELY QUICKLY- THERE'S
BEEN- THE THOUGH THE WAY IT'S
GONE IS IT'S NOW. THERE'S BEEN A
COUPLE DIFFERENT WAYS OF FUNDING
THROUGH THE COVERED RELIEF GRANT
PROGRAM SO WE HAVE A SENSE OF.
THAT THE TIMING ON HOW THOSE
WAYS OF FINDING GO OUT. AND IN
RECENT MONTHS THERE'S BEEN A
LITTLE BIT OF A SLOWDOWN WHICH
DOES MAKE US THINK THAT THE FIVE
HUNDRED. I IS A PRETTY GOOD-
ESTIMATE FOR TERMS OF IT
WOULDN'T GO OUT DAY ONE IT'S NOT
IS IT- GOING TO THE FULL. VALUE
WOULD BE MASSIVELY
OVERSUBSCRIBED SO WERE WE DON'T
CLAIM THAT THIS IS THE PERFECT
NUMBER BUT WE DO CLAIM IT'S- I
PRETTY. SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT AND
THAT THE THAT IN OUR OVERALL
FISCAL RESILIENCY DESIGN IS- IT
SORT OF. MAKES SENSE. OKAY THANK
YOU I KNOW IN IN OUR LAST
HEARING WE DISCUSSED- YOU KNOW
HOW HOW DO WE EXTEND
OPPORTUNITIES TO BUSINESSES AND
OUTRAGE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS. SO
THAT WE'RE NOT GOING AFTER THE
SAME BUSINESSES THAT HAVE
ALREADY. APPLIED OR HAVE
KNOWLEDGE AS TO HOW TO APPLY BUT
REALLY. ALSO INCLUDE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO OUTREACH TO
COMMUNITIES OF INTEREST YOU KNOW
DIFFERENT LANGUAGES DIFFERENT
CULTURES. TO ENSURE THAT THEY
TOO ARE ALSO PART OF. THE
CONVERSATION ON ECONOMIC
RECOVERY. YEAH I'LL JUST ECHO
THAT POINT AND KNOW THAT
CALLAWAY'S BA IS DEFINITELY
TAKING THAT. INTO CONSIDERATION
THAT'S BEEN THEIR GOAL AND THERE
HAS BEEN A LEARNING CURVE BUT IT
WORKED WE'VE GOTTEN BETTER AND
WE ANTICIPATE THAT THE- YEAH
RICH HERE IS ALREADY IN PLACE
THE TO THE NETWORKS OF TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE NONPROFITS. REYES
PARTNERS TO HELP GET THE WORD
OUT AND SO WE'RE- WE WOULD BE
EXCITED BECAUSE WE THINK THERE'S
A- THERE'S BEEN. SUCH A NETWORK
BUILT UP THAT WOULD BE AFFECTED
HER. I BELIEVE THAT I HAD ASKED
IN A PREVIOUS HEARING AND
FORGIVE ME IF THERE WAS SHARED
AND I'LL JUST ASK AGAIN. IF WE
CAN PUT YOU CAN PROVIDE A LIST
OF ALL THE- NOT OFFICE
STAKEHOLDER COMMUNITY GROUPS
THAT YOU POTENTIALLY WORK IN OUR
WORK WITH. THE CAN HELP WITH
THIS PROGRAM AND OUTREACH
EFFORTS. I APPRECIATE THAT ALL I
CAN I CAN GET BACK TO YOU- I
DON'T WE HAVE NOT SHARE THAT
SENSE- MY APOLOGIES IF THAT WAS-
MISTAKE BUT BUT ESSENTIALLY WE
CAN ALL GET BACK TO YOU. GREAT
THANK YOU- AND MOST RECENTLY I
WAS REALLY ALARMED. TO HEAR THE
PROPOSAL WHICH WAS LATER
WITHDRAWN. TO FUND INSTACART
WITH A CALIFORNIA COMPETES TAX
SUBSIDY. DOES THE GOVERNOR'S NEW
CAL COMPETES PACKAGE INCLUDE
PROVISIONS TO FOCUS THE
SUBSIDIES ON COMPANIES. WITH
STRONG LABOR COMPLIANCE
INCLUDING. PROPERLY CLASSIFYING
WORKERS AVOIDING WAITSTAFF AND
COMPLYING WITH OSHA STANDARDS.
SIR GOBIZ DEFINITELY IGNORE ALL
AGES THE CONCERN- WE KNOWLEDGE
AND HAVE- HEARD AND TALKED
CLOSELY WITH. SPECIFICALLY ON
THE ASSEMBLY SITE IN GENERAL THE
LEGISLATIVE. FOLKS THAT WE'VE
BEEN PARTNERING WITH SO WE
ACKNOWLEDGE AND HAVE- THOUGHT
CLOSELY ABOUT THIS INTERNALLY.
BEAT THE PACKAGE WE ARE PUTTING
FORWARD FOR KHALKHIN PETE'S.
DOES NOT HAVE A NEW. FRAMEWORK
OF ANY SORT TO THE PROGRAM
ITSELF IN TERMS OF WHO IS
ELIGIBLE TO APPLY OTHER SOME
OTHER TWEAKS I TO THE PROGRAM OR
PROPOSING THAT ARE NOT RELATED
TO THE INSTACART. SPECIFICALLY
BUT WE HAVE HEARD THE CONCERNS
WE'VE- WE'VE BEEN PROCESSING
INTERNALLY AND WE ARE YOU KNOW
ESSENTIALLY I THINK THAT IT'S A
- IT'S NOTED AND- ON OUR RADAR
HERE. I'M GLAD THAT IS BEING
NOTED BUT IF I AM GOING TO BE
JUST SPECIFICALLY VERY CLEAR.
THE LEGISLATURE SPECIFICALLY
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE WOULD NOT BE
IN AGREEMENT WITH CAL COMPETE
SUBSIDIES GOING TO COMPANIES
THAT DO NOT HAVE STRONG LABOR
PROTECTIONS COOL MISCLASSIFIED
WORKERS AND WERE PART OF A LARGE
A LARGER CONVERSATION RELATED TO
WAIT WAIT STAFF AND NON
COMPLIANCE WITH OSHA. SO I HOPE
THAT THAT CLEAR IN THE DIRECTION
OF ANY TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
MOVING FORWARD. DEFINITELY HEARD
LOUD AND CLEAR SUB APPRECIATE
THAT THANK YOU- MISS WICKS YOU
WANTED TO GO BACK AND HAVE A
CONVERSATION- QUESTION ON
HOUSING YEAH AN APOLOGIES FOR.
GOING BACK AND FORTH HERE- I
BELIEVE WHEN I WAS OUT I THINK
ELIADE SUGGESTED- INVESTING IN
MULTI YEAR FUNDING- I WAS NOT IN
THE ROOM NOW SO I WAS TOLD THAT
BUT I HOPE THAT'S THE CASE- IF
SO I AGREE- AND I JUST WANTED TO
ASK D. O. F. YOU KNOW IF YOU ALL
AGREE WITH. THE PREMISE THAT WE
NEED SOME SORT OF ON GOING
FUNDING TO TACKLE THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CRISIS IN THE STATE. AND
IF SO WOULD YOU HAVE A
RECOMMENDATION A VIABLE PATH FOR
THAT ONGOING FUNDING. SO I.
ADDED MORE BROADLY THE BUDGET IS
YOU KNOW PRECARIOUSLY BALANCED-
IT WITH THE CONSIDERATION OF OUT
YOUR SPENDING BY I BELIEVE IT
THAT NUMBER WAS IS LIKE NINETY
SOMETHING 9597% OF THE FINDING.
IS IN ONE TIME- INVESTMENTS SO I
DON'T THINK THE COMMITMENT FOR
ONGOING FUNDING FOR HOUSING
PROGRAM IS SOMETHING THAT. IS
WITHIN THAT THAT LARGER
BUDGETARY FRAMEWORK. BUT
DEFINITELY IF YOUR QUESTION IS
MORE OF HOW WE CAN DISTRIBUTE.
THE HOUSING FUNDING. UNLOCKS THE
YEARS I THINK THAT'S DEFINITELY
SOMETHING THAT WERE OPEN TO
HAVING A CONVERSATION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON. HOW TO STRUCTURE
THAT. AND IF NOT THEN ON GOING
WHAT ABOUT A SORT OF DEFINED
APPEARED OF TIME TO GIVE THIS A
LONG ENOUGH RUNWAY TO REALLY
SERVE TACKLE THE PROBLEM. YEAH I
MEAN AGAIN I WOULD JUST SAY IT
OPENED OF THOSE CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE LEGISLATURE ON ON HOW
TO STRUCTURE THAT FUNDING. OKAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS WICKS
LET'S MOVE ON TOWARDS EDT. I
UNDERSTAND EDT NEXT AIMS TO
MODERNIZE THE ENTIRE CLAIM
EXPERIENCE CAN SOMEONE EXPLAIN
HOW THIS PROPOSAL IMPACTS THE
VENDOR PROPOSAL INCLUDED IN THE
JANUARY BUDGET. YES AND IS
DIRECTOR FERRIES ON THE LINE
THEY CAN HELP I AM THANK YOU
NANCY. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MEMBERS- NEED TO VARIOUS WITH
EDT SO CURRENTLY- THE VENDORS
THAT WE HAVE IN THE JAN TEN PER
PROPOSAL. FOR MAINTAINING THE
SUPPORT THAT WE'VE USED OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS SOME OF THESE
WILL EVENTUALLY MERGE INTO EDT
NEXT- BUT FOR EXAMPLE FOR THE
TIME BEING WE STILL NEED THINGS
LIKE ACCENTURE TO COMPLETE. SOME
OF THE CSA RECOMMENDATIONS- WE
ALSO HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
MODERNIZE AT THE SAME TIME WE
CALL IT CARILLO MODERNIZATION-
TO BE PREPARED FOR A RECESSION
OR- SOME SORT OF AN UNEMPLOYMENT
SEARCH- OF COURSE CONSISTENT
WITH THE CS AT EIGHT AND STRIKE
TEAM RECOMMENDATIONS- JUST TO
SORT OF WRAP IT UP SOME OF
THESE. VENDORS WILL LIKELY BE
REPLACED AS WE ROLL OUT YOU'D
NEXT- WERE FINISHING UP THE CSA
CSA RECOMMENDATIONS AS THE COMPS
COMMITTEE IS AWARE- AND AT SOME
POINT THESE THINGS WILL MERGE I
YOU KNOW BASICALLY THE VENDOR
BCPS FROM JAN TEN. ARE TO TAKE
CARE OF WHAT WE ARE DOING NOW
AND EDT NEXT IS FOR THE FUTURE
AND FOR THE TOMORROW OF EDT.
WHICH IS ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
WE'VE AFTER THE BCPS PROBABLY
THE NEXT THREE YEARS AS MOST OF
THIS WILL PROBABLY BE ROLLED
INTO EDT NEXT. ENTER VERY I AM
SORRY I MISSED THE ANSWER BUT-
WHAT EXACTLY IS THE IMPACT TO
THE VENDOR PROPOSALS THAT WERE
INCLUDED IN THE JANUARY BUDGET
IF ANY AT ALL- SO EASY THE NEXT
EATING NEXT IS A SEPARATE
PROPOSAL THAN THE JAN TEN
PROPOSAL SO WE NEED TO JAN TEN
PROPOSALS TO MOVE WHAT WE'RE
DOING. NOW YOU KNOW I'M
UPDATING- LANGUAGE ACCESS YOU
KNOW SOME OF THE- SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT YOU'VE SEEN IN JAN
TEN THAT WE HAVE BEEN DOING OVER
THE PANDEMIC TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE READY. FOR A RECESSION
BECAUSE EDT NEXT AS A FIVE YEAR
PROJECT. AND SO WE THAT'S WITH
THOSE BCPS FOR THREE YEARS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS NO GAP.
IN IN SOME OF THE MODERNISATIONS
THAT WE'RE DOING. EBS TWO EDT
NEXT BEING FULLY IMPLEMENTED. Q.
AND WHAT IS THE TOTAL
ANTICIPATED COST OF THE
MODERNIZATION PROJECT. SO IT'S
I'M SORRY CHRIS DID YOU WANNA GO
FOR A HER JOURNAL SO YEAH. SO
THAT TOTAL- THE TOTAL PROJECTED
AMOUNT IS ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION FOR ONE TIME
COSTS WHICH IS IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE ROADMAP OVER A FIVE YEAR
PERIOD THERE ARE OTHER COSTS
THAT ARE- SEVERAL YEARS OF
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATIONS TO
SUPPORT EDT NEXT DURING THAT
FIVE YEAR PERIOD. THAT'S ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED MILLION SO IT'S
ABOUT A LITTLE BIT OVER A
BILLION DOLLARS. TOTAL THANK YOU
THANK YOU YOU KNOW I'D- THERE
ARE MOMENTS IN THIS COMMITTEE
WHERE I HEAR THE BILLION DOLLARS
YOU KNOW AND ABOVE AND IT'S SUCH
A JUST A JUST A MOMENT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS OUR- THE
CURRENT SITUATION WE FIND
OURSELVES AND RIDE IT MAY BE THE
ONLY. MOMENT THAT WE ALL LIVE
THROUGH WHERE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE SUMS THE SUMS OF
MONEY. SO THAT JUST. YOU KNOW
JUST A MOMENT OF REFLECTION
HERE. AT DIRECTOR VARIOUS HOW
MANY LANGUAGES ARE CURRENTLY
SUPPORTED BY EDT AND HOW MANY
ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE ARE PLANNED
TO BE SUPPORTED THROUGH THE
CONVERSATION EFFORT. SO WE
CURRENTLY HAVE I BELIEVE SIX
LANGUAGES THAT HAVE DIRECT PHONE
LINES ANSWERED BY EDT STAFF.
THAT BASICALLY DOES NOT SPEAK
THOSE LANGUAGES WE ALSO HAVE A
LANGUAGE LINE. THAT PROVIDE
INTERPRETER SERVICES- IN OVER
ONE HUNDRED LANGUAGES- A LOT OF
THIS IS THANKS TO AB ONE THIRTY
EIGHT THIS COMMITTEE- WE ALL
REMEMBER THAT VERY WELL FROM
LAST YEAR THAT- AND WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE. THE CALL CENTER
COURSE- AND I LANGUAGE ACCESS
AND EDT NEXT IS REALLY GOING TO
LEVERAGE THE CHANGES THAT WERE
MAKING RIGHT NOW PER AB ONE
THIRTY EIGHT WE ALSO HAD A-
MEDIATION- THAT SORT OF MERIT
ONE THIRTY EIGHT. SO GOING TO
LEVERAGE THOSE CHANGES THAT WERE
MAKING NOW- AND JUST BUILD UPON
THEM AT THE GOAL IS TO MAKE ALL
ENHANCEMENTS AVAILABLE TO
EVERYONE IN THEIR NATIVE
LANGUAGE. IT'S ALWAYS BEEN ONE
OF MY PRIORITIES AS I THINK THIS
COMMITTEE- KNOWS WELL- AND I CAN
GIVE AN EXAMPLE OF SOMETHING
THAT WE'RE DOING SOON IF YOU'D
LIKE OR LEAVE IT AT THAT. THANK
YOU DIRECTOR- INTERFERE HEARING
THIS COMMITTEE OUTLINED CONCERNS
WITH ID ME AND THE USE OF FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY. CAN YOU
PLEASE PROVIDE AN UPDATE ON HOW
THE DEPARTMENT PLANS TO ADDRESS
THE PRIVACY. WHAT'S WITH ID ME
SO THEY DO NOT USE OF FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY UNLESS
THE CLAIMANT WANTS TO BASICALLY
SO THEY- NOW THE ALTERNATIVE IS
THAT YOU CAN USE A TRUSTED
REFEREE. WHEN YOU GO THROUGH ID
ME WHICH IS A LIVE PERSON ON THE
OTHER THING THAT- DELETING THE
SELFIE SO IF YOU DO CHOOSE TO
TAKE A SELFIE- NUMBER ONE THEY
ARE NO LONGER USING THE ONE TO
MANY RECOGNIZE FACIAL
RECOGNITION- SO IT'S ONE TO ONE-
I BELIEVE THAT IT'S CALLED. AND
ONCE YOU TAKE A SELFIE AND
UPLOAD IT- ID NY IT WILL DELETE
THEM- RIGHT RIGHT AFTER THEY ARE
APPROVED BASICALLY. SO IT WAS IT
WAS THAT I MENTIONED THAT THE
IRS ALSO ASKED FOR THE SAME.
SAME THINGS FOR MY TEAMMATES. SO
I BELIEVE THOSE ARE THREE
CHANGES TO THE IDB PROGRAM THE
DELETION OF THE SELFIE BEING A
REFEREE- S. LIVE PERSON
INDIVIDUAL AND THE FIRST ONE
THAT YOU MENTIONED. THAT ONE TOO
MANY. THAT WAS THE STAR OF SORT
OF SOME CONTENTION ABOUT- ID ME
USING PHOTOS AGAINST OTHER
PHOTOS OF PEOPLE BUT THEY LONGER
DO THAT GOT IT OKAY. THANK YOU
MUCH APPRECIATED AND AGAIN THANK
YOU FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK AND
THAT OF THE EDT STAFF IN THE
LAST- TWO YEARS AND TRYING TO
HELP THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
AND- IT'S BEEN A- IT'S BEEN A
CHALLENGING TIME. WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE HELP OF THIS
COMMITTEE MARK ARE A LOT THANK
YOU YOU. MENINGIOMAS QUESTION
FOR THE DIRECTOR YES THAT'S A
GOOD QUESTION ON THAT GOING AWAY
FROM OFFICIAL RECOGNITION AND
THE IDEA ME CHANGING THAT DO YOU
SEE THAT CAUSING A POTENTIAL
INCREASE IN FRAUD. YOU KNOW I
MEAN I WILL SAY IS THAT WE
MEMBER COOPER THAT THAT'S A
GREAT QUESTION BECAUSE YOU KNOW
WE- REPORTS FROM YOU KNOW I DO
NEED SOMETHING WRITERS
ACCENTURE. THE SCAMMERS ARE-
THEY ARE MUCH SMARTER THAN ME
WHEN THEY ARE TRYING TO- IN THE
SYSTEM BUT YOU KNOW LUCKILY
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE ID ME THOMSON
REUTERS X. CENTER IN OUR STAFF
INTERNALLY WE HAVE A FRONT. THE
WHOLE FRONT TEAM POLICY TEAM
THAT LOOKS AT THESE THINGS- WE
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO- NOTICE WHERE-
THERE IS POSSIBLE FRAUD WHETHER
IT'S- YOU KNOW WHAT OTHER OTHER
WHATEVER OTHER MECHANISM THEY
ARE DOING THEIR JOB BOARDS I
THINK I'D MENTIONED LAST TIME-
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO- STOP THOSE
BEFORE THEY HAVE STARTED OR
BEFORE THEY'VE GOTTEN OUT OF
HAND. WE NOTICED THEM THANKS TO
THE FRAUD TEAM BASICALLY THAT WE
HAVE INTERNALLY HERE AT ET SO-
YES THERE IS YES TO THAT I MEAN
THEY ARE THEY ARE GOING TO FIND
ANY WAY THAT THEY CAN. BUT
LUCKILY- WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO-
REALLY STOP IT BEFORE IT GETS
OUT OF HAND. OKAY THIS IS A SIDE
NOTE WE I THINK WE HEARD BACK
FROM YOUR AGENCY ON THE ON THE
ISSUE OF ASSET FORFEITURE GOING
UP FOR SOME IS ASSETS. THAT REAL
GOTTEN BY SOME OF THESE
FRAUDSTERS- ON THE U. I. AND D.
II THINGS I WOULD LOVE TO HEAR.
BACK FROM YOU GUYS ON THAT
OFFLINE ON WHAT YOU'RE DOING ON
THAT. YEAH WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO
DO THAT AND TO BRIEF YOU ON THAT
OKAY THANK YOU. AND ACTUALLY S.
ON. MAY IT IN THE MAIL JIM THERE
IS TWENTY THREE MILLION
SPECIFICALLY GEARED TOWARDS.
IDEA A FRAUD IN EDT SO THEY HAVE
A PROPOSAL THAT'S PROVIDING.
FUNDING TO LOCAL DJS THEY HAVE
OTHER EFFORTS INTERNALLY THAT IS
ALSO GOING TO BE- GOING TOWARDS
THOSE PROCESSORS AND FOUND
TRYING TO RECOVER SOME OF THOSE
ASSETS. I DID. SEE THAT- SO.
THAT MONEY I GUESS THAT NOT A
GREAT OBVIOUSLY THE TO DO THAT
BUT- THERE'S A LOT OF FOLKS WERE
OUT THERE THAT. YOU HAVE SEVERAL
THOUSAND. WORTH OF- ITEMS THAT
OF THE COULD BE GOTTEN BACK SO.
JUST READ THAT REAL QUICK- WHAT
WE ARE WORKING WITH- YOU KNOW
OTHER STATES OF COURSE TO SEE
WHAT THEY'RE DOING WE HAVE OUR
FRONT SPECIAL COUNSEL AS YOU'RE
ALL AWARE OF ON THE GREATER
SCOTT- WHO IS ALSO WORKING WITH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WITH NOW
AS WELL WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THIS IS IT NOT- AN ISSUE THAT IS
JUST CALIFORNIA'S ISSUE AS YOU
CAN IMAGINE SO- I THINK YOU WILL
SEE SOME SOME- YOU KNOW. SOME
POLICIES COMING OUT LIKELY ON A
NATIONWIDE LEVEL AND PROBABLY
LED BY CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT WE DO HERE BUT- SO. WE CAN
WE CAN BRIEF YOU WANT SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT WE'RE HEARING.
OKAY OKAY AS FAR AS THE
POSITIONS REQUESTING DURING THE
VARIOUS BUDGET YEARS FROM NOW
THROUGH THREE TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE. HOW MANY- ENFORCEMENT
POSITIONS VERSES. YOU KNOW
TECHNICIANS ARE FOR FOLKS IN THE
OFFICE. SO PEOPLE ARE CARRYING
GUNS AND BADGES VERSUS- NOT
SWORN STAFF. I REQUEST DOES NOT
HAVE ANY POSITIONS FOR- A STAFF
. OKAY AND THEN AS FAR AS I SEE
THE STATUTORY CHANGES HOW THE
LEGISLATURE BEEN ON THE
STATUTORY CHANGES FOR YOU GUYS.
I'M I'M SORRY I'M NOT AS FAR AS
FAR AS THE LAW TO HELP TO HELP
EDT WHAT CAN WE DO AS
LEGISLATORS- WELL. APPROVING
THIS B. C. P. WOULD BE HELPFUL.
YOU KNOW WE- I'M- THE NOTHING
YEAH- YOU KNOW I MEAN I WHICH IS
JUST TO WRAP THIS UP I MEAN I
WOULD THAT WE ARE IN THE
BEGINNING STAGES OF A LOT OF
THESE INVESTIGATIONS AND
PROSECUTIONS I MEAN THAT IS NOT
A SECRET WE ARE NOT ALONE
CALIFORNIA IS NOT ALONE IN THAT-
AND I THINK AS WE GO ALONG AND
WE SORT- YOU NOW LOOK AT LOOK
AT WHAT IT IS THAT WE ACTUALLY
NEED IT. YOU KNOW IF THERE IS
SOMETHING IN IT MAY NOT BE AN
EDT ASK IT MAY BE A LAW
ENFORCEMENT ASK YOU KNOW IT MAY
BE A DIFFERENT ASPECT I MEAN. WE
WOULD BE HAPPY TO KEEP YOU
UPDATED ON ON THOSE THINGS SURE
JUST ONE LAST QUESTION AS FAR AS
THE- INFORMATION SHARING WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT. WHERE WE HAD ON
THAT BECAUSE THAT'S THE
COMPLAINT I HEAR CONSISTENTLY.
THAT YOU GUYS CAN SHARE
INFORMATION WITH THEM SO. IT
HAMPERS THE INVESTIGATION
INVESTIGATIVE PROCESS. YEAH THAT
THAT SHOULD NOT BE AN ISSUE
ANYMORE SO IF THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT YOU'RE HEARING I WOULD I
WOULD- LIKE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH YOU WE HAVE A
DATA SHARING AGREEMENT WITH. ANY
LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT WANTS TO
HAVE A DATA SHARING AGREEMENT
AND WE ARE. MORE THAN HAPPY TO
PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION OKAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- MISTER
COOPER AND DIRECTORS- DIRECTOR
FOR THE INFORMATION AND I DO
BELIEVE AND I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE
TWENTY THREE MILLION AND THE MAY
REVISED. BECAUSE A PART OF THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE HAD LAST
YEAR WAS JUST LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS NOT HAVING. ACCESS
TO RESOURCES SURE L. AS WELL AS
DIRECT WILL LAST QUESTION. DO
YOU SUPPORT CHANGED A LOT
AUTHORIZED- ASSET FORFEITURE.
I'M NOT SURE I'M NOT FAMILIAR
WITH WHAT YOU'RE IT SPEAKING
ABOUT BUT I'D BE HAPPY TO LOOK
AT SOMETHING AND I'LL BREAK IT
DOWN FOR YOU. SO SOMEONE DURING
THE U. I. D. I. TO BUCKLE IF
SOMEONE. WAS A FOSTER. AND HAS
ILL GOTTEN GAINS YOU KNOW WE
NEED FOLKS THAT- RECEIPT OVER
SEVERAL HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
NAY PURCHASED ITEMS WITH THAT.
OR THIS LOVE CASH ON HAND
WHATEVER. WOULD YOU BE
SUPPORTIVE OF ASSET FORFEITURE.
TO REGAIN THOSE FUNDS FOR THE
PUBLIC. AND RETURN TO THE PUBLIC
COFFERS. I YOU KNOW I WOULD HAVE
TO DEFER TO FINANCE BECAUSE I
HAVE NOT SEEN THAT I'M SORRY I
DID I MEAN WITHOUT KNOWING IT IN
DETAIL I MEAN I AM AN ATTORNEY
AFTER ALL. ABOUT THE LAST YEAR
WE TALKED ABOUT SO FOUR FEATURED
ON THE SAME TOPIC. AND WE NEVER
HEARD ANYTHING FROM ANYONE ABOUT
THAT. SO FINANCE. I DON'T THINK
I DON'T THINK WE HAVE A POSITION
ON THAT AT THIS TIME ASSET
FORFEITURE OKAY THIS IS THE
PEOPLE'S MONEY THAT'S WHAT IT
COMES DOWN TO AND FOLKS ARE OUT
THERE THAT THAT STOLE THIS MONEY
ILLEGALLY AND THEY'RE OF AVENUES
TO RECOUP THAT MONEY BUT MISSED
I'M I'M NOT AWARE OF ANY CURRENT
LAW THAT ALLOWS FOR THAT. OR OR
DARE DISALLOWS THAT I'M NOT
FAMILIAR WITH WITH THE CURRENT
LAW ON THAT BUT IF YOU'RE ASKING
FOR THE POSITION ON WHERE WE
WOULD BE AT IF LEGISLATION WERE
TO SPECIFY THAT I DON'T THINK AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE A POSITION
BUT- OKAY. I BELIEVE THERE WAS
LEGISLATION THIS YEAR ON THAT
SAME TOPIC. AND I MEAN I CAN SAY
WE ARE DOING EVERYTHING POSSIBLE
TO GET EVERY DIME BACK THAT WE
CAN SOWE WOULD BE HAPPY TO LOOK
AT THAT. IT'S OKAY THANK YOU.
WE'RE GONNA- JUST A QUICK
QUESTION I WANT I'D LIKE TO GO
BACK ON THE ENCAMPMENTS FOR JUST
A BIT. HOW TO THE IN CAMPING
GROUNDS IN NEW HOMELESSNESS
PROGRAM ELPS YOUTH HOMELESSNESS
AND HOW CAN WE BEST ADVOCATE FOR
YOUTH. HOUSING AT THE MOMENT.
BEFORE I TURN IT OVER TO- VICTOR
AT KELLY C. H. I. WOULD JUST
KNOW I DON'T THINK THERE'S
ANYTHING SPECIFIC IN THE CAN'T
MAKE GRANTS THAT SETS ASIDE OR
DOES ANYTHING SPECIFIC FOR
YOUTH. I WILL SAY I AND I THINK
YOU MAY BE FAMILIAR WITH THAT
HOME HE DOES HAVE A SET ASIDE.
FOR A REQUIREMENT. FOR YOUTH
HOUSING AND I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT THERE'S A SET ASIDE IN THE
HOT FUNDING. FOR YOUTH- AS WELL
BUT VICTOR IS THERE ANYTHING
SPECIFIC IN THE PLANS FOR THE
AND CAN'T MAKE GRANTS- FOR YOUTH.
EXCUSE ME THAT'S THE SUBJECT
AGAIN DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR
HOUSING FROM B. C. S. H. VICTOR
HAD TO STEP AWAY FOR A MOMENT IF
WE COULD COME BACK TO THIS- BUT
I. APPRECIATE WHAT CHRIS COOK
SHARED ABOUT THE FOCUS WITHIN
THE HUNKY PROGRAM THAT'S FOR
TRANSITION AGE YOUTH AND THAT
SET ASIDE IS ALREADY SHOWING
SHOWN A LOT OF- BENEFIT- IN THAT
WE'RE FUNDING TRANSITION AGED
YOUTH UNITS- AND REALLY FOCUSING
ON THAT COMPONENT. I'M VICTOR
ARE YOU BACK ON YET. APOLOGIES
CARE AND YES YOU KNOW WE'RE JUST
HOLDEN LITERALLY TWO DIFFERENT
PLACES RIGHT NOW TO APPRECIATE
YOUR NOT PRETENDING HE'S- TRYING
TO GET BACK IN. NOT A PROBLEM
I'M HAPPY TO PAUSE FOR A MOMENT
AND THE TWO GUYS COMMUNICATE
WHEN HE'S BACK AND WE CAN
REVISIT THE QUESTION. OUT WE CAN
GO AT THIS TIME TO A QUESTION I
HAVE ON KELLY ATC. SO REALLY
GLAD TO SEE THE TEN MILLION AND
ONGOING FUNDING BUT- NOT ENOUGH
WONDERING IF THERE'S- A SOMEONE
THAT CAN SPEAK ON. THE NEED
TOWARDS- THAT WE HAVE DISCUSSED
IN THIS COMMITTEE BEEN A FOR.
TOWARDS OUTREACH PLANS- THAT
ACTUALLY BENEFIT. THE ABILITY
FOR MORE PEOPLE TO BECOME I TEND
TAX HOLDERS AND THEREFORE GET
OPPORTUNITIES. TO BE ABLE TO
APPLY FOR KELLY ITC. RIGHT SO
BEFORE I ASK ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES FROM F. T. B. THE
JUMP ON AS NOTED THAT- IN THE L.
A. WAS TESTIMONY THERE IS ALSO-
OUT REACH FUNDING AT F. T. B. TO
DO THEIR OWN- INTERNAL KELLY AT
ATC OUR REGION I THINK I NOTED
IN MY OVERVIEW- THERE IS A
DEDICATED STAFF AT- FTV. TO DO
OUTREACH AND THAT IS IN ADDITION
TO THE TEN MILLION AS AS YOU
JUST MENTIONED THAT FOR THE ON
GOING FUNDING SO THE THERE HAS
BEEN- OKAY. CONCERNS SHARED FROM
THE ADVOCATES THAT THE ONE TIME
NATURE OF THOSE OUTREACH FUNDS
AREN'T CONDUCIVE TO YOU KNOW
PLANNING WITH LOCALS AND THAT
THE CONTRACT AWARDS AND SO. OUR
HOPE IS THAT NOW THAT THE
FUNDING IS ON GOING THAT THERE
IS A IS A ESTABLISHED A NETWORK
OF THAT OUTREACH AND TAX
PREPARATION FOR INDIVIDUALS. TO
PROVIDE- INCREASED AWARENESS AND
BENEFIT TO THOSE INDIVIDUALS BUT
I DON'T KNOW IF ANYONE FROM FDB
HAS ANYTHING ADDITIONAL TO ADD
UP. AT FRONT AT OXFORD YES SIR.
I WAS PROPOSAL SUGGESTING OR ITS
WITH ON FOR OF DURING THE COURSE
THE STUDY I HOW TO INCREASE THE
OF THE I. THAT'S OF THE COPS
THAT'S BUT I. YOUR YOUR FUNDING-
IS NOT AT THE AS I THINK COULD
BE SOME OF OUR GRANTEES IN ORDER
TO- RESPECT- FELT WHAT HOPE.
ABOUT THE SERVER COOK AT
MENTIONED WE DO HAVE A PROPOSED
. WITH AN ACTIVE FOUR OUR FUTURE
. DIRECTLY TO. FARMERS AND NOT
ALERT. I'M NOT SPEAK. HOUSE
THIRTY BROUGH UP IN ALASKA
SECOND OF YOUR QUOTE YOU'RE A
COMMON USE THERE WAS AN OUTCRY
FOR FILERS AND NON FILERS AND
THEN YOU BROKE UP. YES I AM
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT THAT'S PART
OF OUR- AT THE FOURTEEN ONLINE
STUDY ARE WE REALLY LOOKED AT.
WHAT ARE SOME OF THE WAYS THAT.
INCREASE THE UPTAKE OF YET YOU
SEE AS SOME OF THE LOWEST PAYING
FOR THAT WE'VE IDENTIFIED. IS
THAT YES ABOUT WHAT WE HAVE IN
HOUSE IN ORDER TO. REACH THE
FILERS AND NON FILERS. SO IN
LOOKING. AT THE DATA THAT WE
HAVE FOR FOLKS WHO FILED. BUT
DIDN'T- PLAY YEAH I TO SEE WE
ARE LOOKING AT THIS WOULD BE-
EXCUSE. OUR SUMMER. THE THREE.
IN. ORDER I'M ACTUALLY AN
LETTING THEM KNOW ABOUT THE PRO
AS WELL WIDESPREAD SAYS ADDING.
TO APPLY ALSO LOOKING TO DO THE
SAME FOR NOT FILERS SO BE
LOOKING WITH OUR FILER DAY. TO
IDENTIFY TO BE A LARGE BUT THE
NOT **** AND ALSO IN THE LET LET
THEM ABOUT THE PRO THAT VALUABLE
CREDIT THIS. SO CHAIR IF I MAY
AS NOTED F. T. B. DATA REESE. TO
THE THAT AND HOUSE THAT IS WHAT.
SHE WAS JUST A IS THOSE. FOR
FILE ENOUGH. IN ADDITION TO THE
CAN BASED. GRANTS THE TEN
MILLION THIS IS WHAT'S FDB GOING
TO BE DOING AND HOUSE TO TRY TO
INCREASE- THE ATC PARTICIPATION.
AND WHAT ARE GOING TO BE SOME OF
THE MEASUREMENTS OF SUCCESS LIKE
HOW IS THE TRACKING OF SUCCESS
INCREASE THE ATC CLAMOR. WHAT
WHAT IS AND COLONISTS AND TAX
FILERS- I DON'T KNOW THAT THEY
HAVE TO BE HAVE THE PERCENTAGE
OF THE EXPECTED- INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF TAX FILERS. THANK L.
FOR THE QUESTION- TAKE LONG
ENOUGH TO BE SO WE ARE IN OUR
FOLLOW AND UNFOLLOW ALTHOUGH WE
ARE ESTIMATING A 5% RESPONSE
RATE- THE AVAIL NOTED. THE
RESPONSE RATE COULD BE HAS BEEN
VERY LOW TRADITIONALLY- HOWEVER
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE POPULATION
OF FOR EXAMPLE LET'S LOOK AT
THAT ON TOP. OF THE- NINE
HUNDRED THOUSAND I DON'T OUT
BEACH TO. WEAR INTO GETTING
ALMOST STRAIGHT UP. HOUSE YOU
KNOW WE'RE HAVING- I'M HAVING A
HARD HEARING YOU LET'S CAN WE
TRY MAYBE TAKING OFF THE VIDEO
AND JUST HEARING- JUST HEARING
YOU THE LAST I HEARD WAS NINE
HUNDRED THOUSAND NON FILERS. YES
THE WE'VE IDENTIFIED NINE
HUNDRED- DOT NON FILERS- BUT WE
CLING OUTREACH TO- RESPONSE RATE
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT- IT. I
ALSO TO CHECK THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ANSWER EARLIER QUESTION ABOUT
HOW ARE WE MEASURING I'M SUCCESS
I THINK WE DID DISCUSS THIS LAST
TIME- OUR VITAL. IS THAT WE ARE
WORKING- AND HAVEN'T SPECIAL
PROGRAMS- IN ORDER TO PUT THE
METRICS SUCH AS THE PLACE ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE ARE LOOKING
AT IS- OUR GRANTEES ARE LOOKING
AT REALLY. THE POPULATION WAS
CARTONING USING OUR BY OUR
BUSINESS DAY. FOUR THREE. TO IT
. SO AVERAGE. ACT IN ORDER. TO
NUMBER. THANK YOU FOR THE
RESPONSE FOR JUST DOING SOME
QUICK MATH 5% OF NINE HUNDRED
THOUSAND IT'S FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND. BUT WHICH IS A
SIGNIFICANT A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
- LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING HOW
THAT'S GONNA WORK OUT MISTER
LUCKY TO HAVE A COMMENT YEAH. I
HAD A FOLLOW UP QUESTION WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ABOUT- MY
COLLEAGUES QUESTIONS ON THE
NEUTRALITY THAT. POSITION THAT
YOU SEEM TO TAKE ON THE ASSET
RECOVERY- QUESTION THERE'S A
BULLET POINT IN HERE THAT SAYS
THAT THERE SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS. BEING REQUESTED
ANNUALLY ON THE TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE AND TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR FOR THREE POSITIONS
DEDICATED TO ASSET RECOVERY
PROCESS. SO WHY THE NEUTRAL
POSITION. YEAH I THINK I WASN'T
FAMILIAR WITH THE SPECIFIC
LEGISLATION IF ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOPER WAS REFERRING TO
SPECIFIC- THAT LEGISLATION- AND
MAYBE JUST NOT MY FAMILIARITY
WITH- THOSE THOSE RESOURCES THAT
ARE BEING PROPOSED. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IT'S NANCY FROM IT FROM
EDT YEAH AS I AS I MENTIONED I
MEAN WE ARE 1100% DEDICATED TO
ASSET RECOVERY- THERE'S ALREADY
RESTITUTION WHEN SOMEONE IS
PROSECUTED. YOU KNOW AND WE ARE
. THERE I SEE NO SITUATION WHERE
WE WOULDN'T GO AFTER ASSETS-
WHEN WE FELT WHEN THEY ARE
FOUND- SO IF I DON'T ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION I DON'T THINK WE ARE WE
ARE WE CAN SPEAK SPECIFICALLY ON
THE LEGISLATION BUT GENERALLY.
CORRECT THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE IN
OUR B. C. P. AND THAT IS FOR
ASSET RECOVERY AND WE PLAN ON
GOING AFTER MIGHT THE PREVIOUS
DOCTOR SAID AND I WILL SAY IT WE
PLAN ON GOING AFTER EVERY DIME
THAT WE CAN POSSIBLY GET IT NO
MATTER WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE. IT'S
MORE COURAGE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER LUCKY YES AND CHAIR I
BELIEVE. MY COLLEAGUE FROM-
KELLY C. H. IS BACK ONLINE TO
ADDRESS YOUR QUESTION. ON YOUR
COMMON SENSE. ON YOUTH. YES
SEVENTH ST THAT THE SET ASIDE IF
THERE'S ANY IN. ANY CLOSELY FOR
VICTOR. THANKS SO MUCH AND-
WEBER LET ME TRY. JUST WHAT
YOU'RE ASKING. SO VICTOR I
BELIEVE THE WAS- IF I MAJOR I
BELIEVE THE QUESTION WAS IS
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE AND CAN'T
MAKE GRANTS IF THERE'S ANYTHING-
EARMARKED OR SET ASIDE FOR TO
ADDRESS YOUTH HOMELESSNESS AND
MY AND MY RESPONSE WAS I DON'T
BELIEVE THERE'S ANYTHING
SPECIFIC BUT IF MAYBE YOU COULD
ELABORATE ON WHAT YOU'VE SEEN IN
THE A CAP MEANT- PROPOSALS THAT
HAVE BEEN TARGETED TOWARDS YOU.
THAT'S WHERE THE QUESTION WAS
ABOUT THE ENCAMPMENTS BETTING
ENCAMPMENTS YES THANK YOU.
ABSOLUTELY SO- HE HAS CURRENTLY
AS CURRENTLY DESIGNED THE NEXT
GENERATION OF INCOME AND
RESOLUTION GRANT WOULDN'T HAVE A
SPECIFIC SET ASIDE FOR YOU-
HOWEVER ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT IN OUR
PROPOSALS. IN BOTH THE FIRST
ITERATION AND THIS NEXT
ITERATION WILL BE UP- PROPOSALS
THAT LOOK AT COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
I'M OF COURSE USE BEING ONE OF
THOSE COMMUNITIES I'M AND OTHER
COMPONENTS AROUND EQUITY AS
WELL- ALTHOUGH I WOULD ALSO
SHARE THAT ALL OF OUR- FLEXIBLE
. PRO WHICH ARE KNOWN AS HAPPY
HABIT YOUTHS ASIDE AND THAT
WOULD SET ASIDE HAS BEEN
INCREASING WITH EACH GENERATION-
IN FACT THE LATEST ROUNDS OF CAP
REQUIRED THAT TEN PERCENT. OF
THE BLOCK GRANTS E UTILIZED
SPECIFICALLY FOR SERVICES. FOR
YOUTH AND I JUST- BECAUSE THAT
INCIDENTALLY SIR IF YOU BUT THAT
ARE DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE
FOR THE NEEDS OF USE AND SO AS
WE LOOK AT HALF THREE AND A HALF
FOR AND THE LOCAL ACTION
PLANNING. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE WILL BE LOOKING AT IS HOW ARE
THEY LEVERAGING OTHER PROGRAMS
THAT COME ONLINE- IN
IMPLEMENTING THOSE LOCAL ACTION
PLANS FOR HAPPENED THAT'LL OF
COURSE INCLUDE HOW ARE THEY
LEVERAGING THE ENCAMPMENT
RESOLUTION GRANT AND WILL THERE
BE ANY SYNERGY THERE BETWEEN.
THE US SATISFIED INDIAN CAPTAIN
RESOURCES. ARE GOING TO BE
COMING ONLINE. THANK YOU FOR
THE- FOR THE RESPONSE. WE'VE HAD
SOME CONVERSATIONS WITH-
HOMELESS YOUTH. WHO LIVE IN
ENCAMPMENTS. AS WELL AS FOSTER
YOU WHO FIND THEMSELVES LIKE IN
THIS LIMBO SPACE OF TRYING TO.
YOU KNOW. FIGURE OUT WHAT THEIR
LIVES GOING. LIFE GOING TO LOOK
LIKE AN END UP OFTEN TIMES- FUND
HOUSE. SO I. I'D BE CURIOUS TO
KNOW. WHY ONLY. WHY IS THE FOCUS
ONLY ON HALF FUNDING AND
POTENTIALLY NOT HAVING FUNDING
FOR THAT NEXT YEAR. I WANT TO
GET MYSELF CONFUSED WITH ALL THE
PROPOSALS THAT WERE. CURRENTLY
LOOKING AT I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S A CONVERSATION
ABOUT YOUTH HOUSING- AND YOUTH
ENCAMPMENTS AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
NO ABSOLUTELY APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION AND- YOU KNOW SOMETHING
WE WILL TAKE A GOOD LOOK AT LIKE
I SAID WE'VE BEEN REQUIRED A
YOUTH SET ASIDE ALL OF OUR OTHER
PROGRAMS- AND IN FACT WE WILL BE
LOOKING AT THE EFFICACY OF THOSE
PROGRAMS. THAT SET ASIDE AS WELL
. THANK YOU MISTER LUCKY. YEAH
MY QUESTION HAS TO DO WITH- THE
CALVET INITIATIVE AND THE- I
DON'T KNOW WHO WOULD BE ABLE TO
ANSWER MY QUESTION BUT- THERE'S
OBVIOUSLY IF I'M LOOKING THIS
CORRECTLY FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
OF A ONE TIME FUNDING THAT WILL
BE GOING TO THIS INITIATIVE TO
SUPPORT MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUICIDE AWARENESS WHICH IS
CLEARLY. AN IMPORTANT
DISTRIBUTION OF FUNDS HOWEVER-
HOW TO RURAL AREAS COMPETE FOR
THESE FUNDS AND HOW WILL WE BE
ASSURED THAT THEY ARE JUST-
CLUSTERED IN URBAN REGIONS. TIM
WEBER DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I
BELIEVE WE SOME FROM CAVAN WHEN
THEY CAN ANSWER YOUR QUESTION.
SURE GOOD AFTERNOON THANKS FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TALK UP
CALIFORNIA BETTER HEALTH
INITIATIVE. OF THE GRANTS WILL
BE DISTRIBUTED STRATEGICALLY-
FOCUSING ON THEM HE BOTH
INCLUSIVE AND EQUITABLE. WE WILL
TARGET DIVERSE BETTER
POPULATIONS. GEOGRAPHICALLY BOTH
IN RURALAND URBAN SETTINGS AS
WELL AS VETERANS OF ALL AGES
SERVICE TYPE OF SERVICE
DISCHARGED STATUS DISABILITY
RATING AND SO ON. SO AS YOU
KNOW- RURAL AREAS TEND TO HAVE A
HARDER TIME THAT COMMUNITY BASED
SYSTEM CARE IS GENERALLY NOT IS
STRONG IN THOSE AREAS SO TO
STAND UP PROGRAMS IT OFTEN.
TAKES A LOT MORE EFFORT ON CAL
THAT'S PART AS WELL AS WORKING
CLASS VERY CLOSE TO THAT
COMMITTEE BASSIST MARK KERR WE
SIMILAR TO THE WAY WE STRUCTURED
IN THE VETERAN HOUSING THE
HOMELESS PREVENTION PROGRAM. TO
GET DEVELOPMENTS FOR THAT
PROGRAM INTO RURAL AREAS THERE'S
A LOT OF LEG WORK ON OUR END IN-
ACTING THAT LOCAL. MANY BASIS TO
OF CARE. AND HELPING THEM. STAND
UP THE STRUCTURE IDENTIFY THEIR
PARTNERS IN BUILDING NINETEEN
WITHIN THAT COMMUNITY TO. TO
PROVIDE SUCH EFFORTS.
ADDITIONALLY WITH THIS PROGRAM
THE IDEA OF IT ALSO. IS TO FOR
THOSE AGENCIES WITHIN. EIGHT
MORE OWNERS LIKE SAN DIEGO FOR
INSTANCE TO REACH OUT TO
IMPERIAL COUNTY OR OR FOLKS IN
THE SACRAMENTO AREA TO REACH OUT
FURTHER UP NORTH THERE IS
ADDITIONAL EFFORT WILL BE
ADDITIONAL EFFORT UNDER WAY TO
COORDINATE AND CONNECTING THOSE
COMMUNITIES TOGETHER. ON INFILL
MORMON NETWORK OF CARE
ADDITIONALLY WILL BE PROPOSED
THE BE CERTAIN PARTS OF THE
FUNDING THAT ARE SPECIFICALLY
FOR TELE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
SO HOPEFULLY THAT WILL. ALSO
ASSIST IN FILLING SOME OF THAT
GAP THAT- COULD BE AN OBVIOUSLY
FROM A MORE URBAN SETTING. OKAY
MY FEAR IS THAT- THE DIFFICULT
THAT YOU'VE DESCRIBED. AWFULLY
EQUATES TO DENIAL. AND THAT'S
WHAT I STILL FAIR AND I HOPE
THAT- MY FEARS ARE. NOT
JUSTIFIED AND THAT YOU ACTUALLY
WILL MAKE AN EQUITABLE OUT
REACH. TO THESE I KNOW IT'S MORE
DIFFICULT BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT THOSE PEOPLE ARE DESERVING
OF THEIR- OF THEIR SUPPORT IT'S
NOT FAIR. FOR THEM TO BE DENIED
JUST BECAUSE IT'S MORE DIFFICULT
TO DISTRIBUTE THE FUNDS SO I'M
HOPING THAT- YOU GUYS WILL TAKE
US A- THIS REQUEST- SINCERELY
THANK YOU. YES SIR AND THAT AND
THAT'S AGAIN THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE FEEL VERY PASSIONATELY
ABOUT AS WELL AND THERE ARE
OTHER PROGRAMS MUCH OF WHETHER
BECAUSE SUPPORT ARE ANY VETERAN
SERVICE OFFICERS WHO ARE
SUBVENTION FUNDING IN THAT
PARTNERSHIP- WE ALWAYS DEVELOP A
WAY TO- SHOULD SHARE THAT NEED
IS ALSO ADDRESSED IN THOSE MORE
RURAL COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU
MUCH APPRECIATE THAT WE WILL
SOON BE GOING TO PUBLIC COMMENT-
MY LAST SET OF QUESTIONS- BEFORE
WE DO THAT OUR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT SO I JUST. SHERA A
FEW QUESTIONS CAN THE
ADMINISTRATION PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL DETAILS ON THE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM PROPOSED
UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS ONE. WHAT
TYPES OF APPRENTICESHIPS WILL BE
SUPPORTED TO. POWER THE
DEPARTMENT ENSURE UNDER
REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES CAN
LEARN AND TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
PROGRAM THREE QUESTIONS. GREAT
RISK UP FRONT PART IN FINANCE
AND I DON'T. OKAY MY COLLEAGUE
FROM DEPARTMENT OF
GENERALIZATIONS WILL JUMP ON IN
THE SECTOR EXPAND A LITTLE BIT
MORE ON THE PRINCIPLES OF BUT-
AS SHE'S PREPARING I WOULD JUST
SAY THEIR PARTNERSHIPS- IS.
PROPOSING THAT PRINTER PROPOSALS
IS- IT TO EXPAND NONTRADITIONAL
PRINCES IN AREAS SUCH AS LIKE
FARM AND RANCH COMPUTER SCIENCE
SOFTWARE IT COMPUTER SUPPORT
AUTOMOTIVE MANUFACTURING AND
HEALTH CARE. AND MY COLLEAGUE
FROM DR WILL EXPAND A LITTLE BIT
MORE ON THE BROADER APPROACH FOR
THAT- THE PROPOSAL. GOOD
AFTERNOON FOLKS AND THIS IS A
DAHLE BURNS AND I AM THE DEPUTY
CHIEF OF THE DIVISION OF
APPRENTICESHIP STANDARDS AND
IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE HERE THIS
AFTERNOON AND- I'M HAPPY TO.
ANSWER ALL YOUR QUESTIONS HERE
SO JUST TO GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT
MORE CONTEXT ABOUT FRIENDSHIP
INNOVATION FUNDING. WAS
MENTIONED BY CHRIS THAT BETTER
IDEA HERE IS TO BE EXPANDING.
NEW ALKA APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
TO SCALE TO SERVE MORE EMPLOYERS
AND MORE APPRENTICES AND
ULTIMATELY. TO ADVANCE MORE
QUICKLY TOWARDS THE GOAL OF
SERVING FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
APPRENTICES BY TWENTY TWENTY
NINE. SO WHEN YOU'RE TRYING TO
LAUNCH AN APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM. IT REALLY IT'S
NECESSARY TO HAVE A CONVENING
FORCE THAT BRINGS TOGETHER ALL
THE DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS AND
PARTNERS NEEDED TO CREATE A
PROGRAM. INCLUDING EMPLOYERS
EDUCATORS OF COURSE APPRENTICES-
AND SOMETIMES ALSO WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARDS OR COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS. AND WE
REALLY NEED THAT CONVENING FORCE
TO BRING THOSE PARTNERS TOGETHER
TO DESIGN REGISTER. AND LAUNCH A
PROGRAM SO THE TRADITIONAL
APPRENTICESHIPS SCIENCE IN THE
C. A. C. FIVE IN THE BUILDING
AND THE FIRE TRADES. OFTEN THIS
CONVENING ROLE IS PLAYED BY A
UNION. BUT AS WE LOOK TO TRY TO
EXPAND APPRENTICESHIPS TO LOTS
OF DIFFERENT SECTORS. WHO PLAYS
THIS CONVENING ROLE CAN LOOK A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT IN
DIFFERENT CONTEXTS WE CALL THIS
CONVENING ROLE AN APPRENTICESHIP
INTERMEDIARY. AND REALLY WHAT WE
WANT TO BE DOING WITH THE
SUBCONSCIOUS IN ADDITION.
FUNDING IS TO BE. OR TOWARDS THE
SYSTEM. AGREES FOR THESE PRINTER
SHOULD TO MEET AND ALL WE WANT
TO BE. A WHOLE. OF THESE
APPRENTICESHIP INTERMEDIARIES SO
TO YOUR QUESTION- I DON'T YOU
KNOW WHO ARE THE POTENTIAL
RECIPIENTS OF THIS PROGRAM- AS
YOU KNOW AS I'VE TALKED ABOUT I
ACCURATE APPRENTICESHIPS WHAT
THAT MEANS IS. APPRENTICESHIPS
IN ALL SECTORS THAT ARE NOT THE
BUILDING PRIOR TRADES SO THAT
INCLUDES HEALTH CARE EARLY CARE
AND EDUCATION TAX CYBER SECURITY
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES PUBLIC
SECTOR TRANSPORTATION. I COULD
GO ON BUT BASICALLY EVERY SECTOR
THAT'S NOT THE BUILDING AND FIRE
TRAINS- AND SO THIS. INVESTMENT
IS INTENDED TO REALLY CULTIVATE
MORE PROGRAMS AND PROGRAMS TO BE
ABLE TO SCALE MORE- SERVE MORE
APPRENTICES IN SECTORS SUCH AS
TO GIVE YOU A FEW. CONCRETE
EXAMPLES OF WHO COULD BE
POTENTIAL RECIPIENTS OF THE FUND
- ONE EXAMPLE IS THERE'S A GROUP
CALLED THE LAUNCH APPRENTICESHIP
NETWORK WHICH IS IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE. AND THIS IS AN EXAMPLE
OF A REGIONAL APPRENTICESHIP
INTERMEDIARY SO THEY HAVE THEY
ALREADY HAVE OCCUPATIONS
REGISTERED IN AUTOMOTIVE HEALTH
CARE T. MANUFACTURING AND SUPPLY
CHAIN EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
SO THEY ARE A REGIONAL
INTERMEDIARY THAT'S SERVING
MULTIPLE OCCUPATIONS. I'M A
DIFFERENT KIND OF EXAMPLE IS WE
HAVE A PROGRAM WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL HEALTH
CARE SERVICES AND SEIU LOCAL ONE
THOUSAND. AND BAND HAVE CREATED
A PATHWAY FOR LICENSED
VOCATIONAL NURSES TO BECOME
REGISTERED NURSES AND THIS
PROGRAM IS PHENOMENAL IT HAS 75%
WOMEN 80% OF MINORITIES AND-
THROUGH THAT PROGRAM THEY MORE
THAN DOUBLED THEIR WAGES THEY GO
FOR MAKING FORTY TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR TO OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR SO THIS
IS. JUST ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF THE
KIND OF PROGRAMS THAT WOULD BE
ABLE. TO SCALE- WITH THIS
FUNDING SOME OTHER EXAM. IS- WHY
IN THIS HOW WHICH IS OUT OF. HAS
AND- DEVELOP UPON PRO. SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY SCHOOL
APPRENTICESHIPS IS ANOTHER
PROGRAM WITH INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY SUPPORT SPECIALIST.
AND THAT PROGRAM ACTUALLY STARTS
IN HIGH SCHOOL SO I'M NOT
CERTAIN EXAMPLE ABOUT- AN EARLY
MOVER IN TERMS OF HIGH SCHOOL
AND YOUTH APPRENTICESHIP- AND
THEN I'VE ALSO MENTIONED THE
CALIFORNIA FARM ACADEMY
APPRENTICESHIPS THAT'S BEGINNING
FARM AND RANCH MANAGERS SO. THIS
IS JUST THAT A SET OF EXAMPLES
TO OFFER YOU THERE ARE
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN REGISTERED
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS ALREADY
TODAY IN THIS AYE ACCESS SPACE
OF APPRENTICESHIP- BUT THAT. THE
MEAN NUMBER OF APPRENTICES IS
TWELVE SO WHAT THAT SHOULD TELL
YOU IS THAT WE HAVE PROOF OF
CONCEPT BUT THERE'S REALLY A
NEED TO SCALE AND AS WE'VE
TALKED TO THESE PROGRAMS THEY
REALLY IDENTIFIED. FUNDING FOR
THE ON GOING RUNNING AND
SOMETIMES THE TRAINING COSTS IN
ORDER TO SERVE MORE
PARTICIPANTS. SO THIS FUNDING
AIMS TO ADDRESS THE FACT THAT
YOU'RE TO SCALING AND THEN-
FINALLY TO YOUR QUESTION AND
HOWEVER WE MAKING SURE THAT WERE
MAKING USE OPPORTUNITIES
AVAILABLE TO. UNDER REPRESENTED
POPULATIONS AND THOSE THAT HAVE
FACED BARRIERS. TO EMPLOYMENT-
AS WE TO APPRENTICESHIP AND NO.
IT'S IN OUR AND LEARN TALK. SO%
BY. THIS EARLY LEARN TO. INTO A
OF DIFFERENT CAREERS AND ARE
TRYING. WORKFRONT CREATE A MORE
ACT AND MORE ACCESSIBLE. ON RAMP
INTO A CAREER THAT'S THAT'S MORE
ACCESSIBLE TO WOMEN MINORITIES
JUSTICE INVOLVED. ALMOST FASTER
YOUTH PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
AND REALLY OTHERS THAT FACE
DEGREE BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT
AND I WILL SAY. PERSONALLY THIS
IS WHY I DO THIS WORK IS BECAUSE
I'M REALLY PASSIONATE ABOUT
CREATING IS ON RAMPS INTO LOTS
OF DIFFERENT PARTS OF OUR
ECONOMY. I'M AND INCLUDED IN
THIS YEAH- FUNDING THAT IS BEING
PROPOSED IF THE WHOLE COMPONENT
AROUND OUTREACH AND TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE MAKING
THESE PATHWAYS AVAILABLE. TO THE
FOLKS THAT REALLY NEED THEM THE
MOST AND- JUST I WILL SAY THAT
SOME EXAMPLES OF HOW WE WERE
ALREADY DOING THIS- WE ARE
ALREADY WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF BE ABILITY SHIN TO
ELEVATE DIFFERENT APPRENTICESHIP
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE
POPULATIONS THAT THEY'RE
SERVING- ANOTHER WAY THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO MAKE. THESE PATHWAYS
MORE VISIBLE AND AVAILABLE IS BY
PARTNERING WITH WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD SO. HERE YOU
GO DIAZ RECEIVED A TEN MILLION
DOLLAR DEAL WHILE GRANTS FOR
EXPANDING EQUITABLE
APPRENTICESHIPS. WE HAVE TURNED
AROUND AND DONE A SOLICITATION
FOR PROPOSALS. INVITED
COLLABORATIONS BETWEEN WORKFORCE
BOARDS AND THESE APPRENTICESHIP
INTERMEDIARIES AND WE JUST
ANNOUNCED THE RECIPIENTS OF
THOSE FRANCE ON MAY FOURTH AND
SO WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
BUILDING ON THOSE
COLLABORATIONS. SO THAT REALLY
ADDS WE'RE SCALING THESE IRAQ
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS THAT
WERE MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
MAKING THEM AVAILABLE TO THOSE.
WHO HAVE BEEN HISTORICALLY
EXCLUDED. MUCH OF. THE DETAIL
RESPONSE AND I CAN I CAN TELL
THAT YOU ARE. INCREDIBLY ABOUT
THE WORK THAT YOU DO SO THANK
YOU FOR THAT MUCH NEEDED THEY
MENTIONED FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
NEW APPRENTICES BY TWENTY TWENTY
NINE THAT'S SEVEN YEARS THAT'S
ON AVERAGE. SEVENTY ONE THOUSAND
FOUR HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT
NEW APPRENTICES EVERY YEAR TO
MEET THAT GOAL YOU THINK THAT'S
FEASIBLE. PRESIDENT SO WE
CERTAINLY DID A LOT OF-
FORECASTING AND MODELING TO TRY
TO THINK ABOUT. WHAT WHAT WAS I
REQUEST FOR FUNDING THIS
PARTICULAR FUNDING REQUEST IS
FOR TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WILL BE
SPENT OVER THREE YEARS AND TWO
YEARS IS NOT SEVEN YEARS RIGHT.
MMHM SO THE IDEA HERE IS THAT WE
WANT TO BE DEMONSTRATING HOW
THIS NEW FUNDING MECHANISM WILL
INDEED HELP SCALE I AKA
APPRENTICESHIPS- SO RIGHT NOW
THERE'S ABOUT SIXTEEN THOUSAND I
ACT APPRENTICESHIPS AND WE WANT
TO BE DOUBLING NOT ROUGHLY BY
MAKING THIS INVESTMENTS OVER THE
COMING THREE YEARS- THAT WOULD
GET US ON THE RIGHT TRAJECTORY
TOWARD SERVING FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND APPRENTICES BY TWENTY
TWENTY NINE- BUT WE WANT TO
START WITH THIS INVESTMENT TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT THIS IS GOING
TO PROVIDE A BRIDGE OF FUNDING.
THAT REALLY BROKE INTO THE KIND
OF SCALING UP IRAQ
APPRENTICESHIPS THAT THAT WE
WANT. TO BE MAKING AN- THANK YOU
AND JUST. UP TO US I NEED SOME.
WIRED THE- WHERE BUILDING TRADE
APPRENTICESHIPS NOT INCLUDED IN
THE PROPOSAL. GREAT QUESTION SO
ACTUALLY IN- IN THE MAY REVISED
THERE ARE TWO INVESTMENTS IN
APPRENTICESHIP GENERALLY ONE IS
WHAT WE HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
IN SCALING I ACT THAT
APPRENTICESHIPS- BUT THERE'S
ALSO A PROPOSAL TO INCREASE THE
RELATED AND SUPPLEMENTAL
INSTRUCTION FUNDING WHICH IS TOP
NINETY EIGHT FUNDING- AND THIS
IS UTILIZED HEAVILY BY THE C. A.
C. PROGRAMS TO COVER THE
TRAINING COSTS. AND HISTORICALLY
THAT HAVE BEEN BENCHMARKS TO THE
NOT FOR CREDIT EDUCATION RATES
IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM
AND- IN THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL IS
BEING PROPOSED TO BRING THAT UP
TO THE FOR CREDIT RATING AND
REALLY IT'S DEMONSTRATING HOW
MUCH WE VALUE APPRENTICESHIP
EDUCATION AND- WE REALLY WANT TO
BE CULTIVATING THE WHOLE
ECOSYSTEM OF APPRENTICESHIP AND
WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT WITH THIS
OMBINED INVESTMENT THAT'S BEING
PROPOSED. THAT WILL BE- LIFTING
THE TITLE BUT IT'S RIGHT THAT
REALLY INVESTING BOTH AND- WELL
ESTABLISHED CA SEE PROGRAMS AND
ALSO SPARKING A WHOLE LOT BROKE
THE INDIA. AFTER PROGRAMS AS
WELL. THANK YOU FOR THAT. ONE
FINAL QUESTION FOR ME- FOR WE GO
TO PUBLIC COMMENT. THE MAY
REVISE INCLUDES TWENTY FOUR
MILLION FOR THE BUREAU OF POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION OVER THREE
YEARS TO SHORE UP THE BUREAU'S
FUNK- CONDITION. WHAT IS THE
PLAN TO CHANGE THE BUREAU FEE
STRUCTURE AND ARE THREE YARS
NEEDED TO REVISE THE FEES.
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION. REPORTER PUT SECONDARY
EDUCATION PROVIDES OVERSIGHT OF
HAVE A CONFECTIONERY EDUCATION
INSTITUTION. WHAT IS THE NOBLE
INDUSTRY- WHAT WE WOULD LIKE TO
DO AND THE AND THE COMING HERE
IT IS THINKING THANK YOU STUDY
AND A NEW APPROACH TO FIGURING
OUT HOW TO BEST FUNDING HE WILL
REGULATORY AGENCY. OR A PRIVATE
. I LOOKED AT A BROAD ARRAY OF
UNDENIABLE INTENSE AND THEN.
SORRY WE'RE A HARD HEARING YOU-
MAYBE IF WE TURNED OFF YOUR
MICROPHONE I'M SORRY YOUR VIDEO
WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO HEAR YOU.
STOP WHAT MICROPHONE A LITTLE
BIT CLOSER THAT'S MORE HELPFUL.
JUST KEEP GOING THEN WE'LL SEE.
OKAY GREAT THANK YOU. WHAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO DO IN THE COMING
YEARS IT IS- IT'S AFFECT THE
BROADER RANGE OF INDUSTRIES AND
WAYS TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
STRONG ABLE OVERSIGHT. EVEN IN
INDUSTRY THAT FLUCTUATES OVER
TIME AS THE PRIVATE SECTOR
EDUCATION AND STRAIGHT FROM TO
DO. SO I'M IN TERMS THAT WE
BELIEVE A THREE YEAR TIMELINE
FOR THE GENERAL FUND PROPOSAL IS
ESSENTIAL TO SUPPORTING THE GOAL
OF ENSURING STRONG STABLE
OVERSIGHT OF THE INDUSTRY. THE
HIGH LEVEL TIMELINE TO EXPLAIN
WHY IS FIRST TO BE GROWTH SLATED
TO GO TO YOUR SUNSET REVIEW IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO THIS YEAR. WE
EXPECT AT THAT PROCESS MAY
RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT CHANGES TO
THE CURRENT CHARGER
JURISDICTION. IN THE CHANGES
THAT WOULD NEED TO BE REFLECTED
IN NEW FUNDING APPROACH. SO THIS
. WOOD COMPLETED IN THE FALL OF
TWENTY TWO TWO. AND THEN THE
CHANGES LAW BE OFFERED AT THE
START TWENTY TWENTY THREE. EARLY
TWENTY TWENTY THREE THE BUREAU
BEGIN AND- CHANGES STEMMING FROM
SENATE THAT REVIEW PROCESS. AND
WE WOULD ALSO ENGAGE EXPERTS TO
DO THAT BROADER ANALYSIS
APPROACHES. WE ESTIMATE THAT
PROCESS WOULD CONCLUDE IN LATE
TWENTY TWENTY THREE BY EARLY
TWENTY TWENTY FOR THE BUREAU
WOULD HAVE A NEW FUNDING
PROPOSAL TO SHARE WITH
LEGISLATORS TO TURN STAKEHOLDERS
. BUT JEAN. IT SHOULD BE FINE
YOU MAY BE PASSED BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND INTO LAW
INVOLVED FALSE TWENTY FOUR
EXACTLY GOING BACK TO TWENTY
FIVE THAT IS REALLY WHY WE
BELIEVE THREE YEARS NECESSARY
TIME YOU THE GOAL AT A ABLE
REGULATORS THE FACE. THANK YOU
MUCH. THAT AND IF THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS- I WANT TO THANK. ALL
OF YOU THAT PARTICIPATED IN-
TODAY'S HEARING. THANK YOU
GENTLEMEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO
THE PERMANENT FINANCING ONLY- AS
WELL AS OUR BUDGET SOUTH. WE'RE
GOING TO GO ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENTS. IN THE HEARING ROOM
AND ON THE PHONE THE PHONE
NUMBER IS CONNECTED TO THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND SHOULD
ALSO BE ON THE SCREEN IF YOU'RE
WATCHING OVER THE INTERNET. THE
NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN.
THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR FOUR.
ARE IS THERE PUBLIC COMMENT IN
THE ROOM. PLEASE GO AHEAD- MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS NICHOLA- TO LOOK I'M
HERE TO. COMMENT ON TWO THINGS-
THE FIRST IS I'M HERE BEHALF OF
THE OAKLAND MAYOR LIBBY SCHAAF
WHO IS A CHAIR THE BIG. CITY
MAYORS IN THE TOP THIRTEEN WAS
POPULATED CITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
A HEARTFELT THANK YOU TO THE
ASSEMBLY TO THE SENATE TO THE
ADMINISTRATION YOU'LL HAVE BEEN
GREAT PARTNERS. WHEN IT COMES TO
SEEKING TO ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S
MOST PRESSING ISSUE WHICH WE
HAVE WHICH WE FEEL IS
HOMELESSNESS- THE BIG THIRTEEN
MAYORS OR- VERY FOCUS ON
ENSURING THAT ALL FUNDING WE
RECEIVED. PASSED WRECKED
ALLOCATIONS AND HOPEFULLY
FUTURE. IS PUT TO THE BEST USE
POSSIBLE TO HELP OUR MOST
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS. WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR THE ONGOING
FLEXIBLE HOMELESS FUNDING CALLED
HAP- IN OUR TOP BUDGET PRIORITY
REMAINS A THREE YEAR. ALLOCATION
THREE BILLION FOR THREE YEARS
FOR HALF. A TO THE BIG TO THE
THIRTEEN CITIES. THESE FLEXIBLE
DIRECT ALLOCATIONS HAVE ALLOWED
OUR CITIES TO CREATE AN
ADDITIONAL NINE THOUSAND SHELTER
SPACES. AND SERVE OVER TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS. THESE
CITIES WE RELY ON THESE FUNDS
OPERATE THOUSANDS OF
INTERVENTION SUCH AS- COMMUNITY
CABINS SAFE RV PARKING TINY HOME
VILLAGES. AT TA WHY SHELTERS
OUTREACH IN SUPPORT OF SERVICES
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT THE LIST
GOES ON FOR ALL THIRTEEN CITIES
WE HAVE VERY DIFFERENT NEEDS IN
VERY DIFFERENT PROGRAMS.
OBVIOUSLY OUR FEAR AND OUR
CONCERN IS WITHOUT HALF FUNDING
THEN WE HAVE TO DEMOBILIZE SOME
OF THESE PROGRAMS AND THEN
UNFORTUNATELY OUR MOST- IN
JEOPARDIZE THAT RESIDENTS WOULD
BE HITTING THE STREETS HEADING
BUT THE STREETS AGAIN SO. IN A
NUTSHELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
PAST PARTNERSHIPS VERY GRATEFUL
FOR THE WORK OF THE ASSEMBLY THE
SENATE THE ADMINISTRATION- WE
WORK LOOK FOR TO AN ONGOING
PARTNERSHIP- AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO PARTNERING WITH YOU ALL ON A
FUTURE ALLOCATION OVER THE NEXT
THREE YEARS FOR THREE BILLION-
THE SECOND ITEM. IS ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF SOUTH SAN FRANCISCO
HALF MOON BAY AND COLMA WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE A DO ES A
REVISED THE RAFT TRAILER BILL-
BREACH OF THE WORK THAT THEY'RE
DOING BUT WERE IN OPPOSITION OF
THE CITIES SO ANYWAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LOOK FOR TO THE
PARTNERSHIP APPRECIATE ALL OF
YOUR WORK THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON CAN LARA'S
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YOUTH AND I WANT
TO THANK THE CHAIR FOR HER
QUESTIONS TODAY AROUND YOUNG
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
THAT IS A CRISIS NOW YOUNG CHILD
SHOULD HAVE TO SLEEP ON THE
STREETS. WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
WHAT THE PET DEFINITION OF WHAT
COUNTS AS SOMEBODY. WHO IS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS IT
MEANS THEY'RE SLEEPING A PLACE
NOT MEANT FOR HUMAN HABITATION.
AND IT'S UNCALLED FOR THAT OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE UNDER AGE
TWENTY FIVE WHO HAVE TO
EXPERIENCE THAT BECAUSE THEY
HAVE NO SAFE PLACE TO GO. IN AN
EVER COMMUNITIES. GRANTED WITH
THE OVER REPRESENTATION OF OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE LGBT Q. AND
YOUNG PEOPLE OF COLOR. WHO ARE
IN THE HOMELESSNESS POPULATION
SO WE ARE ALWAYS APPLAUDED YOUR
LEADERSHIP AROUND THE SET ASIDE
FOR OUR YOUNG PEOPLE. BECAUSE
OFTENTIMES THEY GO AND MESS AND
I THINK WHEN WE FIRST OF THE
FIRST SET ASIDE. UNDER THE FIRST
PROGRAM WE ACTUALLY A COMMUNITY
SAID IT WAS LIKE WELL WE HAD NO
IDEA WHEN YOUNG PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
BECAUSE THAT'S THE KIND OF TIMES
THAT THEY GET OVERLOOKED. AND SO
WE SUPPORT YOU IN TERMS OF
TRYING TO GET ADDITIONAL ONGOING
FUNDING FOR YOUNG PEOPLE IT IS
CRITICAL. FOR THE OVERALL
HOMELESSNESS SYSTEM TO SURE THAT
WE CAN NOT ONLY PREVENT IT. BUT
THAT WE ALSO HAVE. A ONE TIME
DOLLARS FOR THE INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDED FOR THEM. AND THAT ARE
CBO TO DO THIS WORK DAY IN AND
DAY OUT WHO ARE COMMITTED TO
GETTING THE OPERATING SUBSIDIES
TO SUPPORT THESE PROGRAMS CAN
APPLY FOR THE FUNDS DIRECTLY.
THAT IS A CURRENT ISSUE WITH THE
CURRENT HOME KEY PROBLEM AND
WE'D LIKE TO SEE. A SOLUTION
PROPOSED INVOLVED AND WE HAVE
ONE THROUGH THE SUPPORT ACT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SMITHFIELD
SHORT- MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
KATHY VAN AUSTIN REPRESENTING
JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH-
HERE TO TAKE TODAY TO ALSO TALK
ABOUT A COUPLE OF ISSUES ONE-
THE FOSTER YOUTH TAX CREDIT- WE
ARE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
INCLUSION OF THAT IN THE BUDGET-
FIRST I'D LIKE TO- WOULD LIKE TO
THANK SECT OF STATE CONTROLLER
BETTY YEE SHE CO SPONSORED THE
REQUEST OF WHAT'S J. BAY. AND WE
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION
INCLUDING IT IN THEIR JANUARY
AND MAY REVISED JEFF WE
APPRECIATE THE LEADERSHIP OF
THIS COMMITTEE TO KEEP IT IN
THERE AS WELL THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT I'M TOLD THAT WE CAN
SEE THAT WILL HELP YOU NOT ONLY
ASSIST THEM FINANCIALLY BUT-
SHOW THEM HELP. TO DO THEIR
THEIR TAXES WONDER AT A YOUNGER
YOUNGER AGE- SO THAT THEY
DEVELOP THAT HABIT GOING
FORWARD. THE OTHER ISSUE THAT-
WE WANT TO. SHARE WITH YOU AS WE
DO SUPPORT ONGOING FUNDING FOR
HELP- MINIMALLY BUT WE WOULD
APPRECIATE AS ONGOING CONTINUED
FUNDING FOR THE YOUTH OUT SET
ASIDE OUT OF HELP- IT IT'S A
FACT OF AS WE ALL KNOW- YOUTH-
SHOULD NOT BE. HOUSED OF WITH
THE ACUTE AND CHRONIC- HOMELESS
POPULATION SO- WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THOSE AND
MAKING SURE THAT- OUR- OUR YOUTH
A LOT OF OUR HOMELESS YOUTH THE
FOSTER YOUTH. THEY'RE PROTECTED
AND THAT THEY- FIND A HOME THANK
YOU THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
MARKS DIVERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP AND- I JUST
WANT TO SECOND THE COMMENTS OF
ASSEMBLY WOMAN WAKES EARLIER
THAT WAY ABOUT THE NEED FOR
GREATER INVESTMENT IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AS WE FACE AN
UNPRECEDENTED SORT HOUSING
CRISIS. OF PARTICULAR IMPORTANCE
ARE REALLY TWO PROGRAMS ONE IS
THE VERY SUCCESSFUL HOUSING
ACCELERATOR THAT THE STATE
CREATED LAST YEAR- IT ALLOWS
PROJECTS THAT ARE STUCK IN THE
QUEUE FOR LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX
CREDITS TO ACTUALLY MOVE TO
CONSTRUCTION WE ARE HEAVILY
OVERSUBSCRIBED WE'VE MAXED OUT
OUR FEDERAL RESOURCES AND THE
STATE CAME IN AND MADE THOSE
PROJECTS MOVE FORWARD- WE NEED.
THAT WOULD LIKE THAT THAT
PROGRAM NEEDS TO CONTINUE AND
THEN THE SECOND IS THE MULTIPLE
MULTIPLE A MULTI FAMILY HOUSING
PROGRAM WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND THIS IS HOW WE GET
THE NEXT GENERATION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS
STARTED THEY NEED SOME
ASSISTANCE FROM THE STATE AT WE
ARE GOING TO MAKE THE LAST AWARD
UNDER THAT PROGRAM BY NEXT YEAR
THERE'S A SMALL AMOUNT LEFT NEXT
YEAR THE BOND FUNDS ARE PRETTY
MUCH GONE SO- WITH NO SORT OF
LONG TERM FUNDING AND- IT.
COMING FOR THAT PROGRAM WE
ESSENTIALLY ARE STOPPING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PRODUCTION
GOING FORWARD SO THOSE ARE TWO
THINGS THAT WE DESPERATELY ASKED
THE COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER AS IT
AS IT LOOKS TO THE MAY REVISE
INTO THE FINAL BUDGET. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NOW LET'S GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT OVER THE PHONE
OPERATOR YOU MAY BEGIN. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO PROVIDE A PUBLIC
COMMENTSREQUIRED TO STAY AND
LISTEN TO PUBLIC COMMENTS. JUST
KIDDING JUST KIDDING. I THANK
THE GENTLEMAN. OPERATOR PLEASE
BEGIN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT TODAY YOU MAY DO SO BY
PRESSING ONE BUTTON ZERO. OUR
FIRST PUBLIC COMMENT THE LINE
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ANNA JOHNSON FROM
RICHMOND CALIFORNIA CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE ITEMS AROUND THE
FOSTER YOUTH TAX CREDIT THAT
CALIFORNIA EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT AND THE YOUNG CHILD TAX
CREDIT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP AROUND-
DECREASING POVERTY ESPECIALLY
AMONG FOSTER YOUTH. THANK YOU.
AN OUTLINE TO THIRTY FIVE. AND
THIRTY FIVE YOUR MIKE AT THE
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE CAN
HEAR YOU. I'M SORRY ABOUT THAT-
MY NAME IS LOOKING UPON NINE
NEXT CALLING ON BEHALF OF-
CLIENTS- TRANSACTION. OUR LOCAL
YEAR- IN THE CENTRAL COAST AND
COALITION WITH BIG ENOUGH ALL
I'M AN WERE EARNING A SPOT
ADDISON TODAY A SIX HUNDRED AND
NINE MILLION DOLLARS. FOR AN
IMPLANT BENEFITS FOR A THE
GROUNDWORK UPON THEIR PRIDE FOR
THE BUDGET THIS YEAR- A WEEK I'M
COMPANY BELIEVE THAT YOU FIVE
AND A YOU FIND A THAT THE FIRE
IN OUR RE. IT WAS MODELED VERY
SIMPLE FUNDS WERE CREATED ACROSS
THE- BECAUSE IN WORKERS MOVING
JOBS AND THE DISASTER NOT- THEY
DON'T HAVE A WHICH REPLACEMENT
AND SO IT SHOULD BE UP TO LOCAL
NONPROFITS TO BE ABLE TO CREATE-
SOME TYPE OF FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE WE NEED THE STATE TO
TAKE ACTION TO PROTECT THE
IMMIGRANT WORKERS. ON THIS
SHOULDN'T BE- YEAH SO AT SHORT
TERM JOB LOSSES CAN BE HAD A
STRONG. FOR WERE AND NO SHOULD
EXPOSED. RT CAN'T WAIT FOR THE
NEXT DISASTER THANK. LINE.
THIRTY SEVEN. FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
. YES WE CAN AREA. OKAY PERFECT
I REMEMBER- HI CARE MEMBERS MANY
WITH ALEXA BERRIES AND I'M FROM
CEMEX HELP COUNTY OR
INFRASTRUCTURE WHERE THE BUCKET
CARE SYSTEM I ALSO EXPERIENCE
PUBLIC. AS I TRIED TO FIND OUT.
HELP ME AND A FULL REASON ED MY
BOOK COGNITIVE POLICY THAT
BETTER. I'M IN SUPPORT OF ITEM
THAT I SUPPORT THAT WILL WORK IN
THIS AGE YOU HEALTH. FIRST PARTY
THE REQUEST MAKE HALF A MINUTE
WHAT THE PARK AND YOUTH
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS AND THE
SECOND NUMBER OF YOUR- FOR THE
REQUESTED INCREASE ITEM SEVENTY
SEVEN THIRTY DASH ZERO ZERO ONE
DE ZERO ZERO ONE. REGARDING THE
USE TAX CREDIT YOUNG ADULT YOUNG
HELP TAX CREDIT IN CALIFORNIA-
INCOME TAX CREDIT THE SIMPSONS
THANK YOU. SO MUCH. FAULTLINE
SIX OUT- YOU MADAM CHAIR
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS HEATHER
BACK I'M CALLING ON OF WHICH
ABOUT AND MORE THAN FIFTY
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE COACHELLA
VALLEY IN ADDITION TO THE
HOUSING PRODUCTION EXPENDITURES
DISCUSSED TODAY WE WANT TO
REVIEW OUR PUSH FOR FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
COACHELLA VALLEY HOUSING
POPULOUS FINE. MODEST INVESTMENT
THE GENERAL FUND WE WILL BE ABLE
TO JUMP START IMMEDIATELY MORE
THAN TWO THOUSAND UNITS IN OUR
REGIONAL PIPELINE OF MORE THAN
FIVE THOUSAND UNITS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE WATCH THE
FUND BOX HERE AND WHAT THE QUITE
MORE THAN A HALF A DOZEN MOM. IN
OUR WORLD DIFFERENT VESTED
WEEKENDS MORE THAN FIVE HUNDRED
UNITS IN THE LAST FEW MONTHS
ALONE WE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
ASSEMBLY GARCIA PERSIST ARE
THANKFUL FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU. LINE FOURTEEN. HI
MY NAME IS NINE IRWIN GRANDMA
BARBARA BOXER YOU THAT MONEY LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WHERE OUR DENTURE
THE FOSTER CARE. FALLING APART
THE REQUESTED INCREASE ACROSS
STREET HOCKEY CREDIT YOUNG.
CHILD AND CALIFORNIA EARNED
INCOME CREDIT PROVISION THANK
YOU. WHY FORTY EIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS FINALLY
MILAN BUT LONDON MONARCH
PERTAINING CENTER CALLING A PART
OF THE FIFTY NET FOR ALL
COLLECTION HERE TO- ASSEMBLY
THOUGHT ABOUT THE SIX HUNDRED
NINETY MILLION DOLLAR REQUEST
FOR UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS
CORRECT WATER WORKERS PART OF
THEIR PRIORITIES BY THE BUDGET
THIS YEAR. ALI I. AM THANK YOUNG. LINUS. ONE AFTER SHARING
MEMBER MY IS LAURA ASK BIRTH BUT
THEY CAN HELPING TO THE TEACHER
CAN REP THE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT WE WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS CONCERNS WITH THE KOBE
NINETEEN OUTREACH AND AWARENESS
PROPOSAL TO SHIFT TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY MILLION FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICE OPINION A
PARTNERSHIP AND STRATEGIC
COMMUNICATION WE WOULD LIKE TO
UNDERSCORE THE CONCERNED BY THE
L. RADIO REGARDING THE POTENTIAL
FOR THE LACK OF COORDINATION AND
DEPORTATION. A LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS ARE KEY PARTNERS IN
LEADING COMMUNICATION AND
OUTREACH EFFORT I'M DANGER LOCAL
NETWORKING AND RESOURCES. ARE
PROVIDED THANK YOU. BLINDNESS.
EIGHT GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS ELECTED TO HI ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY THE REDWOOD
CITY FOSTER THIRTY BELMONT AND
THE KIND BOROUGH FINANCE
OPPOSITION TO THE PROPOSED
AMENDED BUDGET TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE SPECIFIC TO BE POSITION
BILLS AND DON'T PREVIOUSLY THE
BUT IT. IN AN EFFORT CERTAIN
LEGAL OBLIGATIONS SOME OF AGENT
ARE FAIR SHARE OF L. ACT
KNEELING WOULD MAKE THE RECORD
CUT TO LIKE AT THE YOUR IN
EXISTENCE OF LOCAL DOLLARS THE
IF THEY ARE THAT WOULD RESULT IN
FAMILY COUNTY IT WILL BE HIGHER
NINE OF DOLLARS YEAR SIGN BETTER
BY DID BY THE EVENING REPORT
MOBILE SERVICES. SUCH AS FOR
BACK WITH EITHER- OF REGINALD
REVENUE AND FIND THE FRIEND
CRITICALLY IN PUBLIC SERVICES
PROGRAMS QUICKLY FIRE EMT HOME
APART APART HOUSING FOR ABOUT IT
RESULT IN A PERCENT IN POLICE
FOR AND PERCENT OF THE ORGAN
MAINTENANCE WORKER WHO MADE
STREET FROM RAIN PARKS BUT JUST
HE WOULD RESULT IN A REDUCTION
OF SEVENTY OFFICER AND MAY AND
PARKER KING THREE WORKS. STAFF
AND FOR HELP BUT RESULT IN
ACCORDANCE ELEVEN PER STOP
SERVICE PRODUCTION AND DIFFERENT
THE FUNDAMENTALS THEM WAS
PROPOSED WITH THE FOR SERVICE
FOR THE FOR BY LOCAL BARGAINING
GROUPS ACROSS THE AND WE
STRONGLY URGE COMMITTEE BUT THE
ITEM THANK YOU.
WE APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
CONTINUATION OF THE JANUARY
PROPOSAL TO THE REMOVE THE ONE
DOLLAR EARNINGS REQUIREMENT FROM
THE YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT. AND
FOR INCLUDING AN INVESTMENT IN A
FOSTER YOUTH TAX CREDIT. HOWEVER
WE STRONGLY URGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO DO MORE TO PROVIDE TARGETED
INVESTMENT FOR CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES BY EXPANDING THE YOUNG
CHILD TAX CREDIT TO ALL AGES AND
MAKING IT. HER CHILD. THE DATA
TELLS US THAT ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA
ARE FALLING BACK INTO POVERTY ON
OUR WATCH RIGHT NOW. BILLS OVER
THE BRIDGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
ESTABLISH THE KELLY AGENCY
MINIMUM OF TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
FIVE DOLLARS IMPACTING WELL OVER
THREE MILLION CALIFORNIANS. AND
I WAS NOTED DURING THIS HEARING
INCREASE FUNDING FOR OUR REGION
FREE TAX PREP IS MUCH NEEDED SO
MORE FAMILIES CAN RECEIVE THESE
TAX CREDITS. AND GET THE FULL
POVERTY FIGHTING EFFECTIVE THEM.
AT THE CHAIRED MENTIONED TEN
MILLION DOLLARS IS NOT ENOUGH
AND IN FACT IS A REDUCTION FROM
THE CURRENT YEAR'S FUNDING.
PRIORITIZING THE ABILITY OF
CBO'S ACTIVE TRUSTED MESSENGERS
AN IRS CERTIFIED TAX PREPARERS
IS CRITICAL. WE ARE SUPPORTIVE
OF INCREASING- THE PARTNERSHIP
WITH FTP ON TARGETED TARGETING
ELIGIBLE FAMILIES. AND WE MUST
FOCUS HIS EFFORTS ON EXPANDING
FREE TAX PREP SERVICES IN
COMMUNITY SETTINGS. FINALLY THE
LEGISLATURE MUST ENSURE TAX
CREDIT FOR LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
ARE NOT INTERCEPTED. BY THE
STATE. THANK YOU SO MUCH. LINE.
EIGHTY GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT OUR MEMBERS WHICH MANY
OF MY NAME IS ANGELA TERRY WITH
THE INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE ACCESS
AND SUCCESS TEACHER CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
INVESTMENT FOR THE BUREAU FOR
PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION
THIS AGENCIES SERVED AS THE
FIRST LINE OF DEFENSE FOR
STUDENTS TO ENROLL IN PRIVATE
PUT. GRAHAM THANK PUMP FOR THE-
OF. YOUR HOWEVER THE AGENCY HAS
STRUGGLED WITH UNSTABLE FUNDING
AS A RESULT OF AN- OUTDATED FEE
MODEL. THIS THREE YEAR
INVESTMENT WILL ALLOW THE BUREAU
TO ACHIEVE THE LONG TERM FISCAL
STABILITY NEEDED FOR EFFECTIVE
CONSUMER PROTECTION. AND FOR
THESE REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU
SO MUCH. LINE. EIGHTY THREE.
EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FIVE NINE EIGHTY FIVE. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ED GONZALEZ
I'M WITH THE WAREHOUSE WORKERS
RESOURCE CENTER AND I'M CALLING
AS PART OF THE SAFETY NET FOR
ALL COALITION. CONTOURED THE
SENATE TO ADOPT SIX HUNDRED
NINETY MILLION FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS WERE EXCLUDED WORKERS.
AS PART OF THE PRIORITIES FOR
THE BUDGET THIS YEAR. NO WORKERS
SHOULD BE EXCLUDED THANK YOU.
LINE. EIGHTY SIX. KEVIN AND CO
WITH THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR
INVESTMENT IN A FOSTER YOUTH TAX
CREDIT WE'D ALSO LIKE TO VOICE
THEIR SUPPORT FOR ESTABLISHING
HOPE ACCOUNTS TO BENEFIT
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA WHO'S
LOST A PARENT TO KOBE AS WELL AS
YOUNG PEOPLE IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM AND WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO EXPAND THE YOUNG
CHILD TAX CREDIT TO ALL AGES AND
MAKE IT AVAILABLE PER CHILD AND
WE ARE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
ONE POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS.
EXCUSE ME ONE POINT SEVEN.
FOLLOWING BACK THE POVERTY THIS
YEAR THANK YOU. THIRTY RENTAL
THEN I AM FROM THE SACRAMENTO
COUNTY AND I HAVE WELL
EXPERIENCE WITH HOMELESSNESS.
ONE OF THE VERY FEW. FUNDING
SOURCES THAT EXACT YOU PUBLISH
THAT I ASK THAT YOU PLEASE MAKE
A PERMANENT THANK YOU. LINE.
TWENTY SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TERRY ONLY WITH
ECONOMIC SECURITY PROJECT ACTION
CALLING REGARDING ISSUES THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LETTERS
REGARDING THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD TAX CREDIT I ALSO ECHOED
THE SENTIMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES
APPRECIATING ME AND CONTINUED
INCLUSION AND LEDERSHIP TO THE
GOVERNOR AND IT'S COMMITTEE
ATTITUDE INCLUDE THE FOSTER
YOUTH TAX CREDIT AND EXPANSION
OF THE YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT TO
FAMILIES WITH ZERO EARNINGS. I
ALSO URGE ALLEGED TO DO MORE FOR
FAMILIES IF YOUR- YOUNG CHILD
TAX CREDIT TO ALL AGES AND
MAKING IT PER CHILD. IN TWO
THOUSAND MINIMUM CAL YET YOU SEE
IT TURN FIFTY FIVE DOLLARS AND
OF COURSE ENSURE THAT CREDIT FOR
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS ARE NOT
INTERCEPTED BY THE STATE. I
WOULD MAKE A SPECIFIC COMMENT ON
THE INVESTMENT IN OUTRAGE THAT
AS DISCUSSED EARLIER TODAY. THE
FUNDING AND EFFORTS TO REACH
MORE NON FILERS SUCH AS WELL AS-
PROPOSED BY THE FCC AND THE
CAPTAIN DAY THAT IS A CRITICAL
PART OF INCREASING ACCESS TO
THESE VALUABLE TAX CREDIT. THE
OTHER PART IS FREE TAX PREP
PROVIDED BY CBO RUN BY THE
SIGHT. OF RICH REALLY DO GO HAND
IN HAND TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERY. IN GRANTS- IS REALLY A- FOR
THE THEY CAN. CAPACITY THE TREE
TECH PREP OTHERWISE LOAN FILERS
AND SPENDING. ON AVERAGE HNDRED
DOLLARS TO ACTUALLY CLAIM THESE
CREDITS OUT BY HAVING TO PAY
PAID PREPARERS. URGE YOU TO
INCREASE INVESTMENT IN THESE
IMPORTANT SERVICES TO RECOGNIZE
HOW CRITICAL THEY ARE TO
EVERYONE GETTING TAX CREDITS
THANK YOU. BLIND THE THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MARKET
HE JOHN BEHALF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSED
EXPANSION OF THE YOUNG CHILD TAX
CREDIT TO HOUSEHOLDS WITH NO
EARNED INCOME THANK YOU. LINE
SEVENTY TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHECK CAREER NUMBERS MY NAME IS
JACKIE MENACE CALLING ON BEHALF
OFGREAT AND CAL POLY CALIFORNIA
AND I'M SPEAKING SPECIFICALLY IN
SUPPORT OF THE REQUEST INCREASE
ITEM REGARDING THE FOSTER YOU
TAX CREDIT YOUNG CHILD TAX
CREDIT AND THE CALIFORNIA EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT- WE APPRECIATE
THE GOVERNOR'S CONTINUATION TO
PRESERVE THE FISHES WITHIN THE
NAVY VICE I'M HOWEVER I AM ALSO
CALLING TO URGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO ENSURE TAX CREDITS FOR LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. ARE NOT
INTERCEPTED BY THE STATE IN
MARCH OF LAST YEAR THE STATE
PROVIDED RELIEF MILLION
CALIFORNIANS BY PLACING A
MORATORIUM ON THE COLLECTION OF
ALL THAT OKAY COMMITTEE CAN BE.
HURT BADLY FOR THE LOW INCOME
MANY OF WHICH ARE PEOPLE OF
COLOR KEPT THEIR MUCH NEEDED TAX
REFUNDS AND CREDITS THIS RELIEF
REMAINS INCOMPLETE IF WE DO NOT
PROVIDE PROTECTIONS MOVING
FORWARD AND ONE FAMILIES KNOW
THAT THE GOVERNMENT WILL USE THE
TAX CREDIT OKAY ALL GOVERNMENT
THAT THEY'RE LESS WILLING TO
**** TAX RETURNS ARE PART FOR
THE CREDIT THAT THEY ARE STILL.
IN NEED OF- AND SO WE YOU WILL
NOT.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS IN THE
TANK AND ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND KIND OF CRAP. MY
COMMENT INTO THE CABIN
PROVISIONS IN THE NAY REVISED IN
THE CORRESPONDING TRAILER BILL
WHICH WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
INVESTMENT OF TWENTY MILLION AN
INCENTIVE FUNDING TO ENCOURAGE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO EXPAND.
LEGAL CANNABIS RETAIL WE'RE ALSO
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL TO ZERO
OUT THE CULTIVATION TAX
INDEFINITELY. AND STREAMLINE AND
SIMPLIFY THE MANNER IN WHICH
CANADA TAXES ARE COLLECTED AND
WE MET AT. THE SAME TIME WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS WITH THE
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD TRIGGER AN
AUTOMATIC INCREASE IN THE EXCISE
TAX FROM 15% TO NINETEEN
PERCENT. AND FIND THESE
PROVISIONS. INCONSISTENT WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION'S STATED
OBJECTIVE TO CREATE A SPACE
EXPANDABLE AND EQUITABLE LEGAL
CANNABIS MARKET AND TO SUPPORT
SHIFTING CONSUMERS TO THE LEGAL
MARKET. WE ALSO QUESTION THE
METHODOLOGY. THAT WAS USED TO
GET THE 19% BASED ON OUR OWN
ANALYSIS WE DO NOT BELIEVE THAT
SIMPLY EXCEEDS REVENUE
NEUTRALITY. THE ILLICIT MARKET
IS ALREADY ROBBING THE STATE OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN TAX
REVENUE. AND WE URGE THE- THE
LEGISLATURE. TO CONSIDER. WE
THINK THE LANGUAGE TO WRITE THAT
DENVER THE AUTOMATIC SUCH. IN OF
THE TAX TONIGHT FIRST. IT WE
WOULD RECKON. THAT THE LET. CAN
OF. A TRIGGER THAT ALLOWS THE
EXCISE TAX FLUCTUATE UP OR DOWN
YOU NEED TO FEED THE DOG. OF
FUNDING IMPORTANT PROGRAM AND
MIGRATING CONSUMERS TO THE LEGAL
MARKET WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT TODAY
THANK YOU. LINE SEVENTY EIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME AT THE
MONTERREY COOLEY AND I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF JOHN
BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE PUBLIC
HOUSING ASSISTANCE AND
PREVENTION PROGRAM WHICH
INCLUDES THE YOUTH SATISFIED TO
ADDRESS SIGNIFICANT ISSUE THAT
YOU COMICAL CALIFORNA. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR YOUR
COMMENTS ON YOUTH EARLIER AND TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS YOUR
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF ONGOING
FUNDING FOR HOMELESSNESS JOHN
BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH HAD
ISSUED ANNUAL PUBLICATION ON
HAPPENED AND FOUND THAT THE
PROGRAM IS AN EFFECTIVE STRATEGY
TO ADDRESS YOUTH HOMELESSNESS.
IT'S EXPANDED THE CONTINUUM OF
HOUSING OPTIONS FOR HOMELESS
YOUTH AND INTEGRATED USAGE THE
LOCAL HOMELESS RESPONSE NETWORK
CITIES AND COUNTIES REPORT BUT
PERHAPS YOU SATISFIED IS A
SINGULAR STRATEGY TO PREVENT
ADULT. HOME WITH NET. THE
APRICUS IT OVER LET THOUSAND
PEOPLE. BASED ON RECENT DATA WE
CALL. IN WE RESPECT WORK. AN
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT AND HAPPY
PREFERABLY ON GOING. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. BLIND. FIFTY FOUR.
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JACK WHERE
MEMBERS QUALITY ASSOCIATE
CALLING ON BEHALF OF HOUSING
CALIFORNIA THIS ALMOST HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS FOR BOTH IS THE
UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
OUR AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS WE
APPRECIATE THE INVESTMENT FOR
BOTH SO FAR WE BELIEVE THAT WE
CAN DO MORE TO BUILD. AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. BUT GOING WITH THE OLD
ANYTHING HOME LOOK AT THE TABLE
HOUSING AND PREVENT
HOMELESSNESS. ALONG WITH MANY
PARTNERS WE ARE PUSHING FOR
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS IN THE
MULTI FAMILY HOUSING PROGRAMS
AND HEALTH AND ACCELERATOR. FIND
COULD CREATE MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. ONE BILLION ANNUALLY AS
LIKE FLEXIBLE STATE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE FOR CURRENTLY HOW
CALIFORNIANS. THE HUNDRED
MILLION OVER FIVE YEARS FOR THE
RENTAL OF NEED SORRY FOR THE RE
ENTRY HOUSING AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM OUTLINED IN
THE FAMILY MEMBER BRIAN. AB
EIGHT SIXTEEN OVER TWO HUNDRED
MILLION SUPPORT THE CAPACITY IN
EQUITY. OF THE HOMELESSNESS
RESPONSE WORKFORCE. AND FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION FOR THE
COMMUNITY AND I DISPLACEMENT AND
PRESERVATION PROGRAMS TO
PRESERVE UNSUBSIDIZED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND PREVENTIVE
TREATMENT. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORK WEEK WORKING CLOSELY WITH
EVERYONE AT TODAY'S HEARING TO
DO WHAT IS. NECESSARY TO AND.
HOMELESS IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
. BLINDER NOW. SEVEN I NINETY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS CHRISTINA AND I AM A
CURRENT I'M A FORMER BOSS USED
AND BAKER SO. AND I'M CALLING TO
SUPPORT OF THE REQUEST FOR ITEM
SEVEN SEVEN THREE ZERO DASH ZERO
ZERO ONE DASH ZERO ZERO ONE
REGARDING THE FAR HUGE TAX
CREDIT YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT IN
CALIFORNIA EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT POSITION THANK YOU. NINE
NINETY FIVE. I NINE BELOW THE-
HELLO MY NAME IS ADRIAN I'M
CALLING- WITH THE WAREHOUSE
WORKER LEADERS CENTER CALLING TO
PARTICIPATE FOR ALL COLLECTIONS
AND I'M CALLING TO URGE THE
MEMBER YOU CAN ADOPT SIX HUNDRED
AND NINETY MILLION FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS FOR
EXCLUDED WORKERS AS PART OF THE
PRIORITIES. FOR THE BUDGET THIS
YEAR THANK YOU. LINE. THIRTY
THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRED
MEMBERS JASON BRYANT ON BEHALF
OF THE CANNABIS DISTRIBUTION
ASSOCIATION THE STATE'S LICENSE
DISTRIBUTION COMPANIES SPEAKING
ON THE CANNABIS TAX REFORM
PROPOSAL THAT WAS DISCUSSED
DURING TODAY'S HEARING- WE THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF ADVANTAGES TO
THE PROPOSAL THAT IS CONTAINED
IN A REVISED. HOWEVER AB THE
DISTRIBUTION ASSOCIATION HAS
MAJOR CONCERNS WITH THE TAX PLAN
THAT IS. EFFECTIVELY AN
AUTOMATIC TRIGGER TO THE 19% TAX
RATE. WHICH WE WOULD BE
EFFECTIVE TAX INCREASE AS
COMPARED TO THE CURRENT TAX
STRUCTURE THAT'S IN PLACE TODAY.
ADDITIONALLY OUR MEMBERS ARE
CONCERNED WITH THE IMPLICATIONS
OF THE TAX COLLECTION SHIFT AND
THE IMPACT THAT IT HAS TO
DISTRIBUTORS AND THEIR ABILITY
TO COLLECT PAYMENTS FOR GOODS.
IN ORDER TO ADDRESS THIS WE ARE
LOOKING AT OFF THE SHELF
SOLUTIONS. LIKE ESTABLISHMENT OF
A CREDIT LAW THAT IS USED IN
OTHER INDUSTRIES SUCH AS ALCOHOL
WE LOOK FORWARD TO SHARING THOSE
CONCEPTS IDEAS OF THE
LEGISLATURE ADMINISTRATION AS
THIS- I JUST POLICY MOVES
FORWARD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WHINE AT NINETY TWO- NINETEEN
AFTER GABBAY AND I'M A FORMER.
WHO HAS A PERSONAL. ALMOST AND
IS CURRENTLY IN DAHLE. PERFORMER
AFTER YOU. I'M CONTACT PREVENT
THAT OUT HE I AM IN STRONG. OF
THE REQUEST ITEMS. SEVEN THREE
ZERO ZERO ONE IT THERE ARE ZERO
ONE THE ONE. THE FOSTER YOU
CREDIT YEAH CHILD TAX CREDIT
CALIFORNIA- GET TAX CREDIT. THE
BUT HOW. ME LEVEL. YOU YOU ARE
INCREDIBLY. YEAH THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THREE LINE ONE HI TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M SHARING REPORT
WITH THE CORPORATION FOR
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING- WE ARE
SUPPORTING ONGOING FUNDING FOR
HALF AN MORE INVESTMENT IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. WE ALSO URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT TO NEW INVESTMENT
THE FIRST IS ONE TIME REQUEST OF
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
CREATE THE REENTRY HOUSING AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM.
BETWEEN TWENTY AND 50% OF THE
THREE THIRTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
EXITING PRISON EACH YEAR WILL
BECOME HOMELESS WITHIN THE FIRST
YEAR AFTER DISCHARGE. WEALTHY
SIERRA TO OPERATE TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING PROGRAM THEIR SIX MONTH
PROGRAMS AND MANY PEOPLE BECOME
HOMELESS WHEN LEAVING THESE
PROGRAMS. USING EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICES THIS PROPOSAL WILL
ALLOW PEOPLE TO ACCEPT
HOMELESSNESS PERMANENTLY AND
ACCESS LIVING WAGE JOBS THAT
WILL ALLOW THEM TO TAKE OVER
THEIR BRENT. WE ALSO KNOW THAT
RECENT STATE FUNDING TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS REQUIRES BUILDING
ARE HOMELESS SERVICES CAPACITY.
ONE TIME PROPOSAL OF TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS OVER FOUR YEARS
WILL HELP US STRENGTHEN OUR
HOMELESS RESPONSE SERVICES
SYSTEM. TO ENHANCE FRONTLINE
WORKER PATRIOTS TITANS AND
CREATE CAREER PATHWAYS TOWARD
ENTERING THE WORK FORCE AND
REFORM CONTRACTING PRACTICES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. BLIND OF.
ONE HUNDRED ONE. KAREN MEMBERS
AT LEAST CREATE A ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION WE
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH THE
OTHER CANNABIS TRADE
ASSOCIATIONS RELATED TO TAX
REFORM NOT CONCERNED WITH A
COMPACT METHODOLOGY AND
AUTOMATIC INCREASE OF THE EXCISE
TAX IN NINETEEN PERCENT. WE WILL
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND LEGISLATURE
ON THIS IMPORTANT MATTER TO
TRULY ENSURE- THAT THAT THE
STATE PROVIDE RELIEF TO THE
LEGAL MARKET- IN ADDITION ON
BEHALF OF THE CALCHAMBER IN
SUPPORT OF THE CALIPHATE OF THE
CANNABIS LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
RETAIL ACCESS. GRANT PROGRAM
FUNDING THANK YOU. BLIND ONE
HUNDRED THREE. HELLO MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS ELENA SANTA MARIA
WITH NEXT IN CALIFORNIA HERE TO
SPEAK ON A COUPLE OF ITEMS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA IS IN STRONG
SUPPORTER OF THE TWENTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT FOR
THE BUREAU OF PRIVATE POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION IN THE ME
REVISED I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THE ASSEMBLY SUPPORT TO INCLUDE
THIS IN THEIR FINAL STATE
BUDGET. ADDITIONALLY THROUGHOUT
THIS HEARING THE WORD EQUITY WAS
MENTIONED SEVERAL TIMES THE
GOALS AGENCIES SEEK TO
INCORPORATE IN THEIR WORK
HOWEVER THERE IS NO DEFINED
DEFINITION FROM THE STATE AS TO
WHAT THAT TANGIBLY MEANS IN
TERMS OF OUTCOMES PROGRESS AND
IMPLEMENTATION WE FEAR THESE
DOLLARS WILL BE ALLOCATED THAT
NOT MEANINGFULLY ADDRESS
INEQUITIES THAT CONTINUE TO
PLAGUE OUR STATE WE HOPE THE
LEGISLATURE WILL HOLD THE
ADMINISTRATION ACCOUNTABLE TO
MEANINGFULLY ADDRESS EQUITY IN A
SYSTEMIC WAY WITH A CONCRETE
PLAN. THROUGH THE POLICIES AND
PROGRAMS THAT THEY OPERATE. WE
WERE CUT THE LEAD TO FUND THE
FORTY MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET
REQUEST. THE FUND ESTABLISHMENT
OF THE OFFICE OF RACIAL. EQUITY
TO HELP INSTITUTIONALIZE THIS
WORK FOR THE FUTURE THANK YOU.
BLIND ONE HUNDRED FOUR. BUT
AFTER MANY MCCARTY ABOUT THE FAT
AND THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR WITH THE
PALMER ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY
CENTER CALLING ON THE PART OF
THE FIFTEEN ALL CALLED MENTION-
WE WANT URGE THE ASSEMBLY TO
ADOPT THE SIX HUNDRED NINETY
MILLION BUCKS FIND EMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS FOR EXPEDIA BARKER
AFTER PART OF THEIR PRIORITIES
FOR THE BUDGET. THIS YEAR THANK
YOU SO MUCH. BLIND ONE HUNDRED
FIVE. ALL LARA WILL BE A LOT
BETTER NUMBER EIGHT BILLION
BECOMES BIGGER THAN THE BUT A
HUNDRED AND IT WILL BE. I WOULD
ASSUME LAB ON THE APPS BATTLE
THINK PEOPLE ON IT BUT I
ANYTHING OF THE ALL BUT I HAVE
ONLY SIX CAN YOU OPEN UP POINT
OF THE DAY I YOU BUT AFTER. LINE
EIGHT. HELLO GOOD CHAIR NUMBER
SIXTY ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
CENTER ON AND POVERTY HOUSING
WILL WORK HARD YOU SEE THAT
BATSMEN HOUSE AND HOME WE
BELIEVE MORE MUST BE DONE TO
MEET THE CRITERIA GAIL
PARTICULAR WE LIKE THE UP WHEN
THE COMMENTS ABDOMEN WICKS AND
MARK SEPARATE FROM THE HOW
PARTNERSHIP. ABOUT THE HOUSING
IN ADDITION WE LET FIFTY FIVE
HUNDRED NINE IN THE CAN YOU AND
DISPLAYS AND PERSON PRO CAP TO
AND SUBSIDIZE THE PART HOUSING
MAKE THEM IF. TO HUNDRED MILLION
IN THE REAR HOUSE AND WORK THAT
PROGRAMS PROVIDE PEOPLE HOUSING
SUPPORT SERVICES TO THOSE WHO
ARE FORMALLY. AS OUTLINED IN AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN AND A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION PREDICTION
DEFENSE FUNDING AND COMMUNITY
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH WHAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FAILED TO
COMPLY WITH LEGAL REQUIREMENTS
FOR THE STATE TO FULLY FUND
RENTAL ASSISTANCE APPLICATION
SUBMITTED BEFORE MARCH THIRTY
FIRST BY PAYING THE TENANTS A
100% OF THE RECRUIT CARE ACT AT
THE TIME THEY WERE APPROVED HE-
AT THE PUMP OF THE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM ENACTED
BUDGET SURPLUS MUST BE USED TO
FULLY FUND TENANTS RENTAL THAT
AND ENSURE THAT ALL THE BOOKS.
FROM HOUSE THANK YOU MUCH. LINE
TWO. HI NAME IS AGENTS SOMEONE I
AM A FORMER YOUTH JOHN BURKE
WITH THE FOR YOU AND I THE
HOMELESSNESS STE I AM STRONG OF
RICK DOCTOR YOU THE FACTS CREDIT
YOU CHARLES FACT CREDIT HELLO-
INCOME TAX CREDIT THANK YOU.
FIND AT NINETY SIX. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS DANIEL
GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA WHICH STANDS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
MAY REVISE PROPOSAL TO SUPPORT
THE BUREAU FOR PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION IF
YOU'RE A NEED THESE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO CONDUCT THEIR WORK
PROPERLY AND TO ACTIVELY
PRIORITIZE CONSUMERS. THANK YOU. LINE. TWENTY FIVE. I TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I KNOW.
THIRTY GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS KAREN LAYING
ON TOP OF THE NAPA COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN YOUR
VIEW ARE THE FIRST OF. OKAY
LEAST I KNOW. AGAIN TODAY IT'S
NOT THE PUBLIC TO BE HER AGAIN I
WAS TRAILER BILL PROVIDED FOR
THE- ON FRIDAY. VERY PUMP. AND
PROBABLY. AS FAR AS AXE OF THE
PUBLIC. THE I THINK. HARM COULD
ACCOUNT PROGRAM. WITH A WRY.
WHAT I THINK. DO YOU THINK SEVEN
FIVE APPEAL AFTER. BUT THE THING
I. FROM HARM. BY THE TIME. BLIND
ONE HE LET. HI MY NAME IS ANDREA
I'M WORKERS BECAUSE WE CENTER
CALLING IN THE PROCTOR GONZALEZ
SAYS BOB SCHMIDT THE CURRENT
THEN THERE'S DOLLARS FOR
BENEFITS FOR THANKS TO WORKING
ARE ARE PRIORITIES FOR THE-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WHY. NINE
THREE. WAIT WILL HAVE A TICKET
CENTER IT PART OF THE FIFTEEN
FALL. I'M CALLING TO URGE THE
SENATE TO SIX HUNDRED NINETEEN
DOLLARS FOR BENEFITS. FOR READ
WORKERS AS PART OF THE PRAYER
FOR THE BUCK THIS YEAR THANK YOU
. ONE THIRTY. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBER MY IS
MONICA ON THE OF BOTH STATE OF
AND I AM SPECIFICALLY TO THE
ISSUE AND THE DEAL F. LETTER
REGARD THE FRENCH TAX BOARD INTO
CREDIT. THE GOVERNOR'S
CONTINUATION AND HE- YOUNGER
PROPOSED TO ROOM THE DOLLAR
EARNING TO. FOR THE WHITE STILL
AND PRINT AND- IN THE PAST YOUTH
TECH CREDIT. HOW WE STRONGLY
URGE THE LEAD. TO DO TO PAY
TARGET AND THE- FOR CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES BY EXPANDING THE WHITE
PTC TO OUR AGES AND MAKING IT
PER CHILD. ADDITIONALLY WOULD
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
ESTABLISH A COUNTY ITC MINIMUM
OF TWO HUNDRED FIFTY BY FIFTY
FIVE DOLLARS. EXPAND FREE TAX
PREPARATION FUNDING SO MORE
FAMILIES CAN RECEIVE THESE TAX
BENEFITS AND ENSURE TAX CREDITS
FOR LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. ARE
NOT INTERCEPTED BY THE STATE WE
HOPE YOU WILL PUSH BECAUSE
INVESTMENTS BUT THEN YOUR FINAL
BUDGET DECISIONS. THANK YOU.
LINE OF ONE HUNDRED TEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS NORMAN
ROGERS I'M WITH THE REST OF THE
LOCAL SIX SEVENTY FIVE AND I'M
CALLING IN AND IS A MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA THIS CALIFORNIA
LABOR FOR CLINTON JOBS COALITION
- THE CAST STATE HAS MADE IT.
WELCOME TO THE FUTURE HOUSE GAS
EMISSION REDUCTION. DOES PLAN
FOR THE FUTURE MEANS THAT
OCCIDENTALIS THEIR JOB SO WHAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR IS FIFTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN DIRECT. FOR
DISPLAY ONE WORKERS AT THE PILOT
PROJECT ALSO PEOPLE WORKERS THIS
WOULD BE SEPARATE AND AN COULD
NEVER BE IN IS A FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IT'S ALREADY THERE.
THAT'S WORKER FONG THIS WOULD BE
THESUPPORT SO FAR REPLACEMENT
HEALTH CARE- FOR PARKS ACROSS
THE STATE THAT ARE LOSING THEIR
JOBS BECAUSE. OF THE CONTRACTION
OF FOSSIL FUELS. AND FOR TWO
REASONS JAMES THOSE FOLKS. THAT
HAVE LAW THEIR JOB. IN THE
FUTURE POSTED TO LOSE THEIR JOBS
AND ALL JUST. THAT THEY HAVE NOT
BEEN. THESE COULD NOT BE
FORGOTTEN IT'S BEEN A LOT OF NEW
ABOUT THE GOAL BEHIND LITTLE
GOLD THAT HAVEN'T BEEN A LOT
NEWS ABOUT WITHIN THE STEPS ARE
TO BE FOR WORKERS- THIS WOULD BE
ONE FOR THE STATE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THIRTY MONTHS. A
LONG TERM GOAL IS TO FIND A WAY
FOR OIL AND GAS COMPANIES TO PAY
FOR THIS BUT TO GET THE PILOT
PROGRAM STARTED IT WOULD BE
FIFTY MILLION. TO FIFTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS OVER THIRTY
MONTHS. XPATH LEVY AT THE CHANGE
IN LANGUAGE. FOR A BI- PARDON
ME. FOR THIS W. D. B. WELL. ON
WORKFORCE PILOT. WE WEREN'T TO
LOOK A LINK CHANGE. LANGUAGE
THAT IT GOES WITH SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORKERS. FOR THOSE FOLKS
COVERED BY A COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT. TO BE MORE
INCLUSIVE OF WORKERS THAT ARE
ALREADY DOING THAT. WORK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WINA. ONE HUNDRED
SEVEN. HELLO EVERYONE MY NAME IS
UNDER ONE SILENCE WHEN COLLEEN-
WITH ON BHALF OF THE CLEAN CAR
WASH WORKER CENTER CALLING PART
OF THE FIFTY NOT PAUL COALITION
WE REALLY URGE THE SENATOR
ADOPTED HUNDRED NINETY MILLION
DOLLARS REQUIRED BERMAN BERMAN
BENEFITS BURKE PUT IT WORKERS AS
PART OF THE PARTY. FOR THE.
BUDGET THIS YEAR THANK YOU SO
MUCH. FIND. ONE HUNDRED EIGHT.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AUDIBLE MEMBERS MY NAME IS EDGAR
CHEESE I'M TRYING BUT THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN SOLIDARITY WITH CIGNA
FOR ALL COALITION WE URGE THE
ASSEMBLY TO LEVERAGE THE
HISTORIC SURPLUS AND SUPPORT THE
INCLUSION OF THE SIX HUNDRED
NINETY MILLION DOLLAR REQUEST TO
CREATE AN EXCLUDED WORK A PILOT
PROGRAM TO SUPPORT. IT'S ACROSS
THE STATE WHO WILL CONTRIBUTE TO
THE ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL FABRIC
BUT CONTINUE TO TAKE STARK IN
GRADE SIX STUDENTS FROM
ACCESSING UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS
IN TIME TO MEET ONE EXPERIENCE
SEPARATION FROM EMPLOYMENT.
FURTHERMORE WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
LEGISLATURE TO DO MORE TO
EFFORTS DIRECTED AT FAMILIES IN
GREATEST NEED INCLUDING
EXPANDING THE YOUNG CHILD TAX
CREDIT TO ALL AGES. CREATING
INTEL YET YOU SEE MINIMUM
EXTENDED PRE TAX PREPARATION AND
ALSO ENSURING THAT TAX RATES FOR
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS ARE NOT
FINISHED AT THE BUT STATE. WE
THINK IT'S MUCH FREE TIME FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION AND HELP THAT
YOU SELECT TO ADVANCE THESE
LIFESAVING AND FAMILY SPENDING
INITIATIVES FORWARD. THANK YOU.
BLIND. SIX AFTERNOON BOTTOM
CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME ORIGINALLY
AND I AM FINANCED FOR THE CITY
OF SAN. WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOU OPPOSE THE EXCESS AFTER THE
BILLING THAT'S BEEN INCLUDED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE BUDGET
. BECAUSE TRAILER BILL WOULD
CHANGE CURRENT LAW IN A WAY THAT
WOULD PERMANENTLY CAP ECSTASY BY
FUNDS THAT WOULD OTHERWISE BE
RETURNED TO CITIES AND COUNTIES.
AFTER NON BASIC IT'S CALLED
DISTRICTS HAVE BEEN FULLY
FUNDED. AND WOULD USE THOSE
FUNDS TO PAY FOR THE STATE IN
THE VEHICLE LICENSE FEE
OBLIGATION. SACRAMENTO COUNTY
THE MAJORITY OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ARE ABLE TO FULLY FUND
THEMSELVES THROUGH LOCAL
PROPERTY TAXES WHICH MEANS THAT
THE FULL ALLOCATION OF EUROPE
FUNDS ARE NOT NEEDED. AS A
RESULT SOME ENOUGH FUNDS WHICH
WERE ORIGINALLY LOCAL FUNDS THAT
WERE SHIFTED TO THE STATE. THAT
CAN MEET ITS BUDGETARY
OBLIGATIONS. CAN BE RETURNED TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS VIA ACCESS THE
RAF. THE MAJORITY OFSCHOOLS
BEING ABLE TO FULLY FUND
THEMSELVES WITH LOCAL PROPERTY
TAX DOLLARS. AND THAT'S ALARMING
LOCAL FUNDS THAT WERE ORIGINALLY
SHIFTED AWAY FROM CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO BE RETURNED TO THE
CITIES AND COUNTIES. GOOD
OUTCOME AND DOES. NOT HARM THE
STATE FINANCIALLY. IN THE TWO
THOUSAND FOUR BUDGET COMPROMISE
WAS REACHED THERE WAS NEVER A
CONSIDERATION. FUNDS THAT WOULD
BE UTILIZED TO PAY FOR THE IN
THE VEHICLE LICENSE FEE WOULD BE
INSUFFICIENT. AND WE ARE
APPRECIATIVE OF THE STATE
REIMBURSING US FOR THESE
SHORTFALLS IN THE PAST. THE
PROPOSAL IS UNTENABLE BECAUSE IT
SHIFTS MORE LOCAL FUNDS AWAY
FROM THE CITIES AND THE COUNTY.
AND WHAT THREATEN OUR ABILITY TO
PROVIDE CRITICAL MUNICIPAL
SERVICES SUCH AS POLICE. FIRE
LIBRARY STREETS TRAFFIC
TRANSPORTATION AND RECREATION. I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO OPPOSE
THE LANGUAGE AND THE TRAILER
BILL AS A RESULT. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION. LEVINE.
THIRTEEN AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS WHICH MAKE A GAS CAN
AT THE NET AT GREAT AND AT THE
END OF THE CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
HOPE ACCOUNT BOB MAY REVISION
HAS BEEN CREATE RESOURCES
GESTURE THEY HAD THE BILL
BOMBERS BECAUSE- AND INTO THE
COVER NINETEEN RESPONSE TEAM TO
BORROW POPULATIONS REQUIRING
URGENT SUPPORT OUR. THE EX
THIRTY CHOOSE FIVE CHILL
ORPHANED BY CORBIN I. AND BY
YOUTH THE- WE ARE REQUEST THE
LEGISLATURE AND THURMOND. AND
SERVED IN THE- TO TRUST FUND
ACCOUNTS TO BE W. AND ALTHOUGH
THE PASSWORD FOR THE ONE POINT
SEVEN MILLION CHILDREN LIVING IN
POVERTY IN OUR STATE. WE ARE
PLEASED AT THE CONCLUSION OF
HOPE ACCOUNT FROM THE SENATE
BUDGET PRIORITIES AND I
RESPECTFULLY URGE THESE
INVESTMENTS INCLUDED WITHIN YOUR
FINAL BUDGET DECISION TO FIND
AND KEEP THE FUTURE OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CHILDREN. I KNOW THE
FUNDS WILL ENSURE THAT THEY ARE
ABLE TO SUCCESSFULLY TRANSITION
INTO ADULTHOOD ALSO INVOLUNTARY
THAT THE THINKING THAT FOR ALL
COALITION WE ARE THE ADOPTION OF
THE SIX HUNDRED NINETY MILLION
REQUEST FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS. COULD IT WORKERS IN
PART OF YOUR PRIORITY THIS YEAR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. LINE AT ONE
HUNDRED. I'M. HI MY NAME IS
SPELLED RODRIGUEZ. NUMBER ORGAN
WHAT THE CALL CAR WASH BECAUSE
CALLING PARTY TO FIFTEEN FOR
LISTEN I'M CALLING TO URGE THE
ASSEMBLY TO DR NINE. SIX NINE
ZERO BILLION REQUEST OR ON THAT
FOR WITH A WORKERS PARTY THEIR
PARTY WITH A BUNCH IN THE YEAH
THANK YOU. BLINDED NINETY- GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS YEAH EVAN
POLICY THE BILL LOOKING FOR AND
TALLER FOR I'M GOING FUNDING
PERHAPS A GRAND WHICH INCLUDES A
FIVE FOR YOU AND URGES YOU THINK
THE MINIMUM TAX SHELTER PLAN FOR
THAT YOU OFFICE OF THE MAXIMUM
OUT OF POCKET ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT MAKES SENSE SUPPORT
THE NEED OF PEOPLE BECOMING
STREET. HOW MANY HOW MUCH THE
CRITICAL IN CALIFORNIA WELCOME
THAT'S QUITE THAT'S BECAUSE
YOUNGER PEOPLE.
DURING AND POST. THE GOVERNMENT
I THANK GOODNESS FOR MEDICATION
CONCERNED ABOUT PROGRAM. YEAH
OKAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
PUBLIC YEAH I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT THE LEGISLATURE
FACT HAVE THREE DECLARES ANY
CAMPUS THAT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE REQUEST. YEAH WHY DON'T
HUNDRED SIXTY. I MEMBER I MEMBER
MY NAME IS BILL BELOW AND I
CALLING FROM MARK AND YOU
SERVICES AND DIFFERENT THE- I DO
MY COLLEAGUES FROM THE WILL
CENTER- YOU TO THE ONGOING
FUNDING THE HALF PROGRAM AND
MARIO INCREASING THE TEN BECAUSE
BUT IF FOR YOU 225% HEARING
SEVEN NEARLY HALF OF ALL THOSE
WHO ARE HOME A EXPERIENCE THERE
BOUT OF COMMERCE THAT BEFORE
THEY TURN TWENTY FIVE SO IT'S
WHAT THE 25% THAT. IN THE FAR
MORE REASONABLE- THRESHOLDS OR
HAPPENING WHICH HAS PROVEN TO BE
A SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM UP FURTHER
- WHILE THE WHOLE HE INITIATIVES
BEEN UP SUCCESS LOCAL. AS
NONPROFIT- HE WOULD. WE BENEFIT
FROM A PROGRAM THAT WE COULD
HAVE TO THE- THIS WOULD AND
SMALLER NOT- THE POSSIBILITY OF
THE GETTING MORE USED HOW CREATE
THAT. WE ASK YOU FUND SUPPORT
ACT. THAT WOULD BE JUST THAT AND
IS CURRENTLY THE ASSEMBLY
HOUSING COMMITTEE THANK YOU SOME
FOR YOUR COMPUTER. LINE. ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTEEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARING MEMBERS RGB
PAYCHECK FROM CREEK STRATEGIES
ON BEHALF OF THE SAME APPEAL
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS FOR
CALLING IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES
PROVIDE EXPECT ROCK TRAILER BILL
THAT WOULD CHANGE CURRENT LAW IN
A WAY THAT SIGNIFICANTLY HARM
COUNTY WITH CITIES LIKE A- BY
PERMANENTLY CAPPING THE RAP
THANK THAT WOULD BE RETURNED TO
US. AFTER SCHOOL THAT THANKFULLY
PACKAGE AND INSTEAD USE TAX
LOCAL TAX REVENUE TO PAY THE
STATE IN BLUE BL OBLIGATION IF
ENACTED THE PROPOSAL WOULD POP
TO GET TO GET FINANCIAL LOSSES
THE LOCAL PEOPLE I REQUIRED.
ACTION BEEN CRITICAL PUBLIC. THE
BILL WALTON RESULT DAMAGING
COUNTY IN ITS CITIES HUNDREDS OF
DOLLARS OF DOLLARS YEAR. IN OUR
MUNICIPALITY HAVE ALREADY THE
FOR QUITE LOCAL. IT TOOK THIRTY
TREATMENTS WE ARE. TO THE
TRAILER TELLING. THANK YOU. LINE. NINE EIGHT. THANK YOU MESSAGE
AT MADAME CHAIR AND MEMBERS JEAN
HURTS CALLING TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA
THE RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES
OF CALIFORNIA AND ON BEHALF OF
THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS ECHOING THE COMMENTS
OF MY CITY AND COUNTY COLLEAGUES
EXPRESSING OPPOSITION TO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S AMENDED ACCESS
HE WRAPPED TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. INSTEAD WE STAND READY
ALONG WITH THE AFFECTED CITIES
AND COUNTIES TO SIT DOWN AND
WORK THROUGH- AN APPROPRIATE AT
APPROACH WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
THAT- DOESN'T. AND THE COMMUNITY
CURRENTLY OPERATED BY THE
PROPOSAL- WE RESPECTFULLY URGE I
YOUR REJECTION OF THAT- TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE WHEN IT COMES
BEFORE YOU DON'T- FINALLY I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO ADD ON BEHALF
OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA ARE SUPPORT FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION ADDITIONAL HOME
HE INVESTMENT. AS WELL AS THE
PROPOSAL FOR FINDING- INTERN
HOUSING ON STATE OWNED LAND WE
ALSO LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUED
DIALOGUE AND COLLABORATION WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION ON FUTURE
ROUNDS- THAT HAPPENED PROGRAM
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE. ONE
HUNDRED SIX- OF THE DETROIT
NINETEEN CONCORDANCE WITH
WAREHOUSE WORKERS BECAUSE THERE
TO CALLING A TAKING A FOR ALL
COALITION I'M CALLING REALLY
URGE THE SPEND BOB THE COUNTRY
MILLION DOLLARS. FOR ON AND
BENEFITS FOR MARC ARE OF THE
PROGRAM FOR THAT BUDGET THIS
YEAR OKAY BUT THAT. THANK YOU
AGAIN MY- LINE. ONE NINE.
SCHERING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
BENEFIT THAT ON POLICY DIRECTOR
CALLS ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
GOING TO CANNOT COMMUNITY
ORGANIZING PROJECT ALSO PARTNER
THE SAFETY NET FOR ALL COALITION
THE INDIGENOUS UNDOCUMENTED
COMMUNITY FORUMS OVER 60% OF THE
AGRICULTURAL WORKFORCE IN
CALIFORNIA GET LITTLE TO NOTHING
IS RETURNED TO THEM AND THE
BENEFITS AND BENEFITS WHEN THEY
LOSE HOURS AT THEIR JOB HE TO
THE PANDEMIC OR LOSE THEIR JOBS
DUE TO ILLNESS OR OTHER LIFE
CIRCUMSTANCES. I'M CALLING TO
URGE THE ASSEMBLY TO ADOPT THE
SIX HUNDRED NINETY MILLION
REQUEST FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
pBENEFITS PRECLUDED WORKERS AS
PART OF THE PRIORITIES. FOR THE
BUDGET THIS YEAR THANK YOU SO
MUCH. LINE. ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY NAME
IS CORPS INVOLVED SHE'S GIVEN
THE YMCA OF SAN DIEGO COUNTY
CALLING WITH PARTNERS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOUTH
WE HAVE OVER FIFTY YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE IN WORKING WITH YOUNG
PEOPLE AND FAMILIES WHO ARE
UNSHELTERED AND ARE CALLING TO
SUPPORT THE ONGOING GOING
FUNDING FOR THAT PROGRAM WHICH
INCLUDES THE CENTER THANK YOU.
WE URGE YOU TO INCREASE THE
MINIMUM THRESHOLD THE 25% TOO
OFTEN THE 10% IS BEING OF THE
MAXIMUM AMOUNT OF FUNDS WITHOUT
CONCERN FOR WHETHER THAT MAKES
SENSE TO SUPPORT THE NEEDS OF
YOUTH LIVING ON THE STREET BASED
ON THE TWENTY NINETEEN ANNUAL
HOMELESS ASSESSMENT REPORT TO
CONGRESS CALIFORNIA HAS THE
HIGHEST NUMBER OF UNACCOMPANIED
YOUTH EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
IN THE COUNTRY WITH ELEVEN
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED AND NINETY
THREE YEARS. BETWEEN THE AGES OF
TWELVE TO TWENTY FOUR. IN DIEGO
CA. ARE COUNTY. FUNDING TO YOU
pTO HAVE TO WE HAVE EXPERIENCE
FOR MORE. UP TO TRANCE OUR
SERVICES. EVIDENCE INFORM. HUMAN
CENTER COLLABORATE ACROSS ACROSS
YOU PROVIDERS FOR THE HOUSING
OUR YOUTH PROGRAM. IT IS WORKING
AND OVER THIRTY THOUSAND
DOCUMENTED IMPRESSIONS WITH
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE DOCUMENTED AND
OVER THIRTY YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
PERMANENTLY HOUSE AND UNDERAGE
HI TWO YEARS IT IS SCALABLE WITH
INCREASED FUNDING. FURTHER WHILE
HOME SHE HAS BEEN A PHENOMENAL.
OPPORTUNITY FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AS A NON PROFIT- A
PROGRAM CAN ONLY APPLY DIRECTLY.
AND SHOULD WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT MORE YOU SPECIFIC HOUSING
IS CREATED IN SAN DIEGO ARE HOME
KEEP PROPOSAL DOES NOT HAVE A U.
COMPONENTS BUT WE KNOW THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT NEED. WE ASK YOU TO
FIND THE SUPPORT ACT CHAMPIONED
BY SENATOR WIENER. THAT WOULD DO
JUST THAT AND IS CURRENTLY IN
ASSEMBLY HOUSING COMMITTEE THANK
YOU. ONLINE AT. ONE TWENTY
THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JONATHAN LATER AND I'M JUST
CALLING TO SPEAK SPECIFICALLY TO
THE ISSUES THEN- DEPARTMENT
FINANCE LETTERS REGARDING THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD AND TAX
CREDITS- WHILE WE APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S CONTINUATION OF THE
PROPOSALS TO REMOVE- ONE DOLLAR
EARNINGS REQUIREMENT FOR THE Y.
C. T. C. AND FOR INCLUDING AN
INVESTMENT IN THE FOSTER YOUTH
TAX CREDIT LIMIT STRONGLY URGE
LEGISLATURE TO INSURE TAX
CREDITS FOR LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS ARE NOT INTERCEPTED
BY THE STATE. IN PARTICULAR A
REPORT PREPARED BY UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA RESEARCHERS FOUND
THAT DURING THE PANDEMIC
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS WHO WITHDREW FROM
PUBLIC COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
FOUND HIMSELF GOING
INSTITUTIONAL THAT'S CREATED
WHEN THERE ARE COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES WE PAID FEDERAL
GRANT AID TO THE GOVERNMENT AND
THEN BUILD STUDENTS FOR THOSE
AMOUNTS- RECEIVING INCOME FROM
THOSE STUDENTS. THE GOAL OF THE
EITC IN MY TTC WHICH WERE MEANT
TO PROVIDE A CRITICAL BOOST TO
FAMILIES ACROSS THE STATE.
ECONOMY AND MAKE US ALL STRONGER
IN THE PACE OF ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTY WHICH. WE CURRENTLY
FACE WE HOPE THAT WE WILL. I
HOPE YOU'LL FOR THE INVEST
WITHIN YOUR FINAL BY THIS. THANK
YOU. ONE SEVEN. BUT AFTERNOON
BALANCE AND MEMBERS DANIEL
BRADLEY BEHALF THE TELL STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES HERE TO
SPEAK ON A CUP OF ISSUE AT FIRST
ME ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MEMBER
COUNTY DIRECTOR THAT APART
FINDING I PROPOSED TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE RELATED TAX BY IRAQ. I
CAN'T WE WANT WE WOULD LIKE TO
ASK OUR SUPPORT AT THE END OF
HOMELESSNESS AND- HOME HAS A
COUNTY IS THAT THE ABILITY
FINANCE THOUSANDS OF INTERIM HOW
THE WITH ME ARE PERCENT OF THAT
BECAUSE DISH FUNDING FOR
CURRENTLY OVERSTEP THE BRANCH
PROGRAM WE ALSO LOOK FORWARD TO
AT THE END. ON ADDITIONAL FOR
THAT HUNDRED DOLLAR MILLION AND
TOWARD USING OUR TWENTIETH OF
PREPARING RIGHT FOR AN ARM
HELPING ON EIGHT OWNED LAND
THANK YOU. THE LION ONE FIVE. HI
MY NAME IS LIZ- IN BOCA WITH THE
INLAND FOR IMMIGRANT ALSO INFO
WITH THE THANK NET FOR ALL
COLLEGE- CALL INTO- G. ASSEMBLY
ADOPT SIX NINETY MILLION
REQUESTS FOR UNEMPLOYED BENEFITS
OR- I COULDN'T. IN THE BUDGET
THIS YEAR THANK. WHY. ONE THREE.
I REMEMBER THIS I AM VERY
PASSIONATE ABOUT THEIR IN GET.
ALL OF THE CONTROL SHOULD
NONPROFIT WHICH MAKE SURE YOU
AND FAMILIES I. HE ARE INVOICE
ARE SUPPORT AND REQUESTING ITEMS. SEVEN THREE. DASHNER ZERO ONE
DASH ZERO ZERO ONE REGARDING THE
PROCTOR TAX THE YOUNG TRIAL TAX
CREDIT AND THEY HELP BRING-
INCOME TAX. THANK YOU. BLIND ONE
TWENTY NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON-
CHECK BRIO AND MEMBERS NAME AS
WELL CAN AND I'M BETTER OF
GOVERNMENT RUN FOR THE IN OF
BOTH WORKERS HELLO CHIU. WE WANT
WORDS TO IN THE SENATE BUT YOUR
PRIMARY BY IN HOPE. WE REALLY
NEED TO THAT THE THIRTY TWO FIVE
HUNDRED OPEN ORPHANED BY COMPANY
AND CITY IS AROUND THE STATE AND
THIS ACCOUNT WHAT ESTABLISH
TRUST FUND FOR THESE CHILDREN.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
. LINE ONE TWENTY SIX. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS THAT MY NAME IS
DELHI JIMENEZ AND I'M A
PROFESSOR AT THE COSTS OF THE UC
IRVINE SCHOOL OF LAW WHERE I
DIRECTED DIPLOMA AND SHOULD'VE
I'M CALLING TO URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE THAT TAX
CREDITS ARE FROM LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS ARE NOT INTERCEPTED
BY THE STATE TO THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD. RESEARCH THAT I
CONDUCTED WITH THE UC PROFESSORS
FOUND IN THE LAST FEW YEARS THE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS WITH YOUR PUBLIC
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES DURING
THE PANDEMIC FOUND THEMSELVES
GOING INSTITUTIONAL THAT'S
CREATED WHEN THEY'RE EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS REPEAT GRANTS AND
OTHER AID TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND THEN CHARGE TO
BUILD STUDENTS FOR THOSE AMOUNT
MANY UNIVERSE CALIFORNIA CSU AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES HAVE USED THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD INTERCEPTOR
GRANTED HE'S TAX REFUNDS FROM
THE SENATE AND- OF FOR EXAMPLE
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE MORE THAN
EIGHTY THREE HUNDRED CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS HAD
TO REFUND. FEES TO PAY THESE
INSTITUTIONAL DEBTS ABOUT 70% OF
THE STUDENTS WERE ACTUALLY
ELIGIBLE FOR THE EARNED INCOME
TAX CREDIT OR THE YOUNG CHILD
TAX CREDIT- FEEDING INCOME FROM
THE STUDENTS THAT COULD REDUCE
THE NUMBER OF FAMILIES CLAIMING
THESE TAX CREDITS AND ULTIMATELY
UNDERMINES THE PURPOSE OF
REDUCING POVERTY AMONG
CALIFORNIANS WITH THE LOWEST
INCOME I URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
PREVENT THE STATE ANY PARTICULAR
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS FROM
SEIZING INCOME TAX CREDITS FOR
LOW. INCOME TAXPAYERS THANK YOU
. BLIND FAITH. THREE HELLO WE
ARE HERE I WAS I WAS WAITING A
LOT LOCAL MANAGER TO FIGURE HOW
TO GET A ON PAPER BE HERE THANK
YOU FOR- ALLOW ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK I AM HERE
IN SUPPORT OF THE HAP PROGRAM
AND MAKING THE MIDDLE MOM- UP
FROM 10% 225% AND MAKING SURE
THAT ONE NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
ARE ABLE TO ACCESS WHAT HOME KEY
IS SUPPOSED TO BE DOING- WHICH
THEY ARE DOING AND THAT IS THERE
IS- THE SUPPORT ACT- THAT. IS
CHAMPIONED BY SENIOR- SCOTT
WIENER WHERE WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT- IT'S FUN IN THAT I KNOW
THE GREATEST SOLUTION TO ENDING
ADULT CHRONIC HOMELESSNESS AS BY
ENDING YOUTH HOMELESSNESS OP
WITH THE FORMER FOSTER YOUTH AND
I'LL MY EXPERIENCE WITH
HOMELESSNESS AND I UNDERSTAND
THE IMPACT THAT HAS ON YOUR LIFE
AND NOW SERVING AS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YOUTH. EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT PRIVILEGE TO FIGHT FOR
THESE FUNDING SOURCES TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOUNG PEOPLE THAT ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND
OUR GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA
HAVE WHAT THEY NEED TO SIXTY
FIVE AND SUPPORT CALIFORNIA IN
THE FUTURE THE TOP THANK. YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE TIME. AND MATTER
CHAIR HAVE NO FURTHER. AT THAT
TIME. THANK YOU OPERATOR AND I
WANT TO EXTEND A THANK YOU TO
ALL OF THE INDIVIDUALS THAT
CALLED IN FOR PUBLIC COMMENT TO
SHOW YOUR ADVOCACY FOR THE
POLICY AND BUDGET PROPOSALS THAT
YOU ARE SUPPORTING. OR
POTENTIALLY OPPOSING ANYONE
THINK MOMENT TO THANK OUR BUDGET
STAFF AS WELL AS THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND ALLELE FOR ALL
THEIR WORK THIS BUDGET SET FOR
HEARING IS ADJOURNED